Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie ist die Lage?
Na ja, es ist ja doch wieder einiges passiert.
Was ist ein Buch mit, das die Lage heißt?
März hat ja versucht, noch einen weiteren Antrag durchzudrücken, ist aber dann gescheitert.
Wir müssen jetzt ganz genau sein. Anträge, ja. Das erste war ja ein Entschließungsantrag. Also alle Welt wusste, macht keinen Sinn, ist nicht mal ein Eckpunktepapier, ist einfach nur ein Appell. Der ging ja durch.
Ja.
Und das zweite war ja ein konkreter Gesetzesvorschlag. Der beinhaltete Grenze zu, Ausländer raus, niemand darf hier rein, ich hasse Menschen, ich mag das nicht, bitte macht alle mit, sonst machen wir es mit der AfD. Ja. Und sehr viele FDP haben sich gesagt, ne doch nicht und auch die CDU war nicht geschlossen anwesend.
Zehn haben glaube ich gefehlt bei der FDP, zwölf etwa, was schon recht viel ist. Die AfD hat zugestimmt der Sache, BSW hat sich auch positiv dazu verhalten, was wirklich schrecklich ist. Interessant ist aber jetzt folgendes, der Stern hat recherchiert, einen Tag zuvor, also man sagt, es gibt diesen Tabubruch, den März da plant, wir müssen auch Demos machen und so weiter, einen Tag zuvor, also einen Tag vor dem Entschließungsantrag, der durchging oder? Nein, vor diesem Gesetzesänderungsantrag.
Ausländer-Rausgesetz.
Sagen wir es so, ja wie es ist. Folgender.
Wir können es natürlich auch, das macht es aber nicht besser, zu Strombegrenzungsgesetz nennen. Das ist quasi Ausländer-Rausgesetz. Die Natur, der Strom, die Gewalt.
Und wir haben ja schon gehört bei Markus Lanz, war Habeck zu Gast, dass Habeck durchaus bereit war, mit März zu diskutieren und zu telefonieren und Gemeinsamkeiten zu finden, aber wie das so sich anhörte, wollte März nicht mit Habeck telefonieren oder nicht privat sprechen.
Die reden nicht.
So. Ist doch schon mal interessant, dass die Grünen so einen Schritt überhaupt dann auf März zugehen und sich dann auch die Frage stellt, warum ist März dann nicht gewillt, einen Kompromiss zu schließen, denn alles, was dann Habeck vorgeschlagen hat, klingt zwar sehr viel höflicher, meint aber sehr häufig auch eher Ausländer lieber draußen bleiben. Und da ist auch interessant, dass also ohne Not quasi März das so eskalieren ließ, wo man sich fragen kann, warum, welcher strategische Plan ist das? Ist das vielleicht der Plan zu sagen, wenn ich jetzt tatsächlich einen sehr scharfen Anti-Asylkurs mit den Grünen zusammen als Kompromiss präsentiere, wird man mir aus der rechten Blase sagen, ich bin eingeknickt vor den Grünen? Oder ist es wirklich so, dass man von März-Seite aus sich sagt, ich versuche doch noch einen Schritt weiterzugehen? Insofern, als ich mal schaue, wie ist die Reaktion darauf, wenn das noch mal mit der AfD hier versucht wird, ist das vielleicht doch auf Dauer eine Option für die CDU? Weshalb ja dann jemand wie Michel Friedman, Jahrzehnte in der CDU ausgestiegen ist?
Also meine Vermutung ist, ich hab jetzt alle Männer-Podcasts dazu gehört. Also den von Gordon Rybinski und den von Michael Brücker und den von Robin Alexander und den von Paul Ronsheimer. Wir hören auch heute Clips, die ein bisschen damit zu tun haben. Alle sagen, Friedrich Merz hat ja nicht so richtig Regierungserfahrung. Also der kann halt eine Kanzlei leiten und selbst in diesem BlackRock-Aufsichtsratschef war es mehr so, wir brauchen dein Adressbuch und dann stellen wir fest, du hast eigentlich gar keins, müssen wir so tun als ob und dann ist er da 10 Jahre irgendwie. Und Friedrich Merz hat wohl Orientierung gesucht und sie im Fernsehen gefunden. Das kennen wir ja von Donald Trump, wacht morgens auf, weiß nicht, was soll er halt machen, schaltet Fox ein und dann wird ihm erklärt, was er machen muss. Und er sieht dort Donald Trump, der sagt, am Tag eins bin ich Diktator, das ist kompromisslos und so weiter. Und er kopiert genau das, er übersetzt es nur auf Deutsch, aber es ist sozusagen in der gleichen Blöderheitsklasse. Und er sieht Österreich und weiß, der Kiekel kann jetzt mit 28 Prozent eine Kanzlerschaft aufbauen. Gelingt ihm noch gerade nicht so gut, aber mal gucken, was die Verhandlungen da bringen. Also mit 28 Prozent kann man selbst als AfDler, als FPÖler Kanzler werden. Dann schaff ich das doch als CDUler allemal. Ich muss nur sozusagen langsam vorbereiten.
Und meine Partei von 32 Prozent den Umfragen auf 29 Prozent bringen.
Genau, also man bringt sich erstmal auf 28 Prozent wie der FPÖ und dann macht man das irgendwie. Aber man muss halt die Radikalität darstellen und so meinen und vehement durchprügeln. So wie Kicke. Niemals zurückstecken. Wenn die Medien sagen, das ist scheiße, double down. So und das ist Märzstrategie aus Orientierungslosigkeit. Wir können auch sagen, heute haben wir ja einen Salon, der uns das Wort dumm auf Grundbegriffsebene politischer Beobachtung holt mit Marc Schiritz. Deswegen, das ist halt wahnsinnig dumm, was Märzstrategie macht. Aber das heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass das heute im politischen Felde, wie es ist, nicht von Erfolg gekrönt ist. Am Ende will er nur Kanzler werden.
Ja, vieles ist so dumm.
Weiter ist ja egal. Also er will nur Kanzler werden.
Dumm ist das interessante Wort. Mir hat ein Bekannter aus Wien geschrieben, die FPÖ erwägt, hierzulande Deutsch als vor der Schule verpflichtend einzuführen, sowie universitäre Abschlussarbeiten nur auf Deutsch zu erlauben. Das wäre das Ende der Unis, da wir wohl gut die Hälfte der Doktoranden und damit einen substanziellen Teil der Forschungsleistung damit verlieren werden. Und trotzdem gibt es eben diese Bestrebungen. Natürlich versuchen sich vor allem die Unis dagegen zu stellen. Aber ja und für ihnen bedeutet das auch, dass dann eine Deutschpflicht ja ihnen dazu bringen würde, dann darüber nachzudenken, Österreich zu verlassen. Und dass das überhaupt das österreichische Geistesleben sehr stark dezimieren würde. Und jetzt frage ich dich aber, wenn wir das so mitbekommen. Und wir sagen, also wie der Diskurs ist, also der nicht rechte Diskurs ist, Tabubruch, Brandmauer eingestürzt etc. Und dann bekommen wir von einer Sternrecherche folgendes. Nach Sterninformationen lud der frühere CDU-Chef Armin Laschet am Donnerstagabend, also am Vorabend zu diesem Showdown, zu einem Treffen in seiner Berliner Wohnung, bei dem mehrere hochrangige schwarz-grüne Politiker anwesend waren. Zu den Gästen zählten Top-Grüne wie Annalena Baerbock, Cem Özdemir und Katrin Göring-Eckardt. Auf CDU-Seite waren unter anderem Kanzlerkandidat Friedrich Merz und der frühere Gesundheitsminister Jens Spahn dabei. Das schon länger geplante Treffen hieß Auf ein Glas mit Armin Laschet. Das hieß Auf ein Glas mit Armin Laschet, wäre bestimmt auch eine schöne Sendung im WDR. Ich bin gespannt. Will aber hier keine Ideen geben. Jedenfalls, was machen wir jetzt mit dieser Meldung? Sagen wir, ach toll, dass die noch miteinander reden, das gehört ja in der Demokratie dazu. Und wir würden erstmal sagen, ja natürlich müssen die noch irgendwie miteinander reden und die könnten ja auch möglicherweise Koalitionspartner werden. Aber welches Theater beobachte ich dann in sozialen Medien, im Bundestag und sonst wo, wenn genau diese Politiker sich gegenseitig bekämpfen, als seien sie der Todfeind, der jetzt alles einreißt und kaputt macht. Also entweder ist es ein Tabubruch, dann kann man doch nicht dann abends feiern gehen. Also die haben, ich will das nochmal deutlich machen, es geht ja hier nicht um eine inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung, bei der man sagt, da sind wir anderer Meinung. Also wir könnten uns jetzt, weiß ich nicht, hier zanken über die Höhe der Einkommensteuer und da würde kein Platt mehr dazwischen passen. Dann könnten wir ja trotzdem danach essen gehen. Aber es ist ja doch was anderes, wenn ich sage, ich parktiere jetzt mit der AfD, da würde man nicht sagen, naja, es war trotzdem alles super, auf ein Glas Wein los mit Armin Laschet. Und das finde ich doch so, dass man hier den Eindruck gewinnt, also wird irgendwo Theater gespielt, entweder in der Wohnung von Armin Laschet, was ich nicht glaube, oder es wird doch Theater gespielt bei dieser Empörung.
Also was wir sehen, ist die hohe Attraktivität von Macht per se. Annalena Bärböck will einfach nur Außenministerin bleiben, Scholz will einfach nur Kanzler bleiben, Merz möchte Kanzler werden und Armin Laschet, keine Ahnung. Alle haben ja Vorstellungen, auch Ricarda Lang kann man ja offenbar aus diesem Amt da raus drängen durch ihre eigene Partei. Und dann ist sie halt einfach weiter die Twitter-Vorsitzende von den Grünen. So sie bleibt einfach und spielt das Medienspiel weiter. Im Gespräch bleiben für den Fall, dass mal wieder Posten aufgehen und irgendwelche Verlierer aussettiert werden oder so. Ich will mal anknüpfen an Wien einfach als Hashtag, um zu klären, was passiert da in dieser kleinen Wohnung. Ja. Wien vor 100 Jahren war ja der Zufluchtsort für alle, in die in Gedanken waren. Also ich weiß noch mein Musiklehrer damals, als wir uns alle so fragten, wo und wann würden wir gern mal leben, kamen wir dummen Schüler natürlich so New York, alle wollen nach Hongkong, keine Ahnung. Und er so Wien vor 100 Jahren. Also sozusagen Zustroben der ganzen Welt nach Wien. Wenn wir heute Wien sagen, schwingt das immer noch mit. Wien ist eigentlich nicht Österreich. Wien ist viel mehr als Österreich. Wien das ist unser, jetzt liegt es ja weit im Osten, das ist eigentlich das Europa. Slota Dyck hätte irgendwann mal gesagt, heute ist es die Ostküste Amerikas, damals war es Wien, so ungefähr. Auf der Ebene reden wir über Wien. Wenn jetzt in Wien in die Regierung an den Start geht, die sagt, in unseren Universitäten bitte nur noch auf Deutsch Abschlussarbeiten schreiben, was ein Abschiedsbrief an die ganze Welt darstellt, also kommt nicht nach zu uns, wir sind jetzt nur noch Wien, wir sind nicht mehr Wien. So und jetzt dieser Transfer nach Deutschland, eigentlich ist Deutschland, fühlt sich auch immer so ein bisschen Wienerisch an. Ja ja. Exportweltmeister, den Holocaust zum einen veranstaltet, sind wir nicht so stolz drauf, aber diese Aufarbeitung, wir sind sozusagen das Schlagen der Herz der Menschlichkeit der Welt, wir sind das Vorbild und so.
Ja und Berlin ohnehin die 20er Jahre und all das.
So und jetzt wird aber die Zukunft Deutschlands ausgeklüngelt in einem schwarz-grünen Bündnis, das sich nicht traut, ehrlich damit umzugehen, dass das Problem, was die Schwarzen da verursacht haben, natürlich nicht das gemeinsame Abstimmen ist mit der AfD, sondern ein Gesetz vorzulegen, bei dem die AfD einfach sagt, ja machen wir, weil es ja unverkennbar ist, ja unser. Ja. So. Also alle reden gerade über die Brandmauer, aber dass die CDU schon längst allein über die Ausformulierung so eines Gesetzes und sich zu trauen, das auch als Vorschlag in den Bundestag zu bringen, wo einfach drinsteht, wir machen mal alle Grenzen zu und wir sind da auch so.
Wir haben vor vielen Monaten mal einen Clip gespielt von Bas und Proc, der sagt, das Schlimme ist mit der AfD, dass alle Politiker es sich jetzt leicht machen können. Sie deklarieren, dass sie nicht AfD sind, weil die AfD sind die Rechten, das sind die Nazis. Deshalb ist alles, was wir tun, egal wie scharf unsere Anti-Flüchtlings-Gesetze sind, immer auf der richtigen Seite, weil es sind nicht AfD-Positionen. Die AfD ist die böse Seite, wir sind die gute Seite. Und das finde ich auch, dass inhaltlich gar nicht darüber diskutiert wird. Und man ja sogar sieht an den Zugeständnissen, die dann Habeck in so einem Interview macht oder auf die man von Franziska Branden hört, dass man offenbar sagt, na generell sind wir eigentlich schon für diesen Rechtsruck inhaltlich. Nur formal hat es uns nicht gepasst, dass das mit der AfD stattfindet. Und das ist das Skandalöse. Und das muss man auch noch mal den Leuten so klarmachen, weil das auch in vielen Podcasts so durcheinandergeht. Es ging nicht um irgendeine Abstimmung, die vernünftig war, wo man sagt, ja genau, es wäre gut. Wir haben keine Sommer- und Winterzeit mehr. Und da hat jetzt auch die AfD ihre Stimmen dazu gegeben. Und damit ist sie ad acta Sommer- und Winterzeit. Ja, da würde man sagen, okay, völlig egal. Hätte man nicht machen müssen, na ja. So hier haben wir es mit einem inhaltlichen AfD-Gesetz zu tun, das dann auch von der AfD gotiert wurde natürlich.
Bodo Ramelow sitzt in der Bundesprässekonferenz und sagt, also in Thüringen gehen jetzt 300.000 Menschen in Rente und es kommen aber nur 150.000 nach. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Flüchtlingsdiskussion, wie wir sie gerade führen, den Kern der deutschen Probleme betrifft. So und man denkt sich so, ja genau, das ist das Thema. Hoch abstariert auf ganz Deutschland, so und so viele Menschen gehen in Rente, nur halb so viel kaum nach. Wir lesen heute dieses sehr gute Buch Gemeinsinn, also wirklich ein fantastisches Buch. Es ist für mich Augenhöhe mit Grabbers, Anfänge und so weiter. Naja, ist wirklich spektakulär. Aleida und Jan Aßmann haben den halben Salon gelesen. Also alles, was wir lesen, kommt da wieder vor. Die lesen Oschmann, die lesen Triggerpunkte, die lesen einfach alles so. Und sie lesen auch Karl Schmidt. Und Karl Schmitts Definition von was ist ein Arya ist, naja, ein kein Nicht-Arya. So. Ja, also was ist das deutsche? Na, das ist nicht jüdische. Also da wird einfach so Zwangsalternativen aufgebaut. So, das auf heute transportiert stellt uns ja wirklich wieder die Frage, sind wir wieder da angekommen? Ist eine demokratische Politik einfach demokratisch, weil sie nicht AfD ist? So wie du es eben beschrieben hast. Und die AfD macht einfach immer, was die AfD macht. Und wir sind einfach nicht die AfD. So, das ist die Argumentation. Ja, könnten Sie uns das noch ein bisschen ausführen. Reicht Ihnen das nicht, nicht die AfD zu sein? Also haben wir nicht die Diskussion, diese moralische Fernab aller politischen Inhalte so weit getrieben, dass es Ihnen einfach reicht zu wissen, na hauptsache nicht AfD, so, ne? Und da sind wir ja genau nicht. Der Punkt ist ja, die CDU macht AfD-Politik. Das wird gar nicht diskutiert. Weil alle über die Brandmauer. Und ja, die CDU ist aber nicht die AfD. Ja, aber in diesem Gesetzestext steht, wir machen die Grenzen zu, wir bewachen 3800 mit Gewaltkilometer. Niemand kommt hier rein. Und alle, die da sind, werden auch nochmal hinterfragt, ob sie denn damals zurecht kamen. Vielleicht nehmen wir in den Pass wieder ab. Und lauter so ein Scheiß, ja?
Ja.
Also das ist doch AfD-Politik. Jetzt kann noch keiner kommen und sagen, puh.
Bei Straffähigkeit passend zu. Und all diese Dinge, Jens Spahn, fühlt sich ja dann auch nochmal aus.
Also die CDU ist jetzt die AfD. Und nicht, ahja, da müssen wir uns mal über die Brandmauer Gedanken machen oder so. Nein, das ist doch längst geschehen. Also diese Grenzüberschritte intellektuell sind doch längst gegangen.
Und gibt es nicht vielleicht auch ein Problem, dass viele Sympathisanten von AfD-Positionen, nennen wir es jetzt einfach mal, egal ob sie jetzt von CDU oder AfD selbst vertreten werden oder dann auch von den Grünen mitgemacht werden. Und der SPD geht ja da auch gerne weit, wie wir ja schon während der Ampelkoalition gesehen haben. Also es war jetzt nicht so, als wäre das eine migrationsfreundliche Politik, die jetzt beendet wird. Und dann haben wir aber interessante Umfragen. Es gab so einen kleinen Bericht bei SWR 4 über die sogenannten Deutsch-Russen oder Russland-Deutschen, die durchaus in Umfragen zur AfD tendieren und sehr konservative Positionen einnehmen. Wir haben...
Wie relativ viele islamischen Völker.
Wir haben eine AfD, die sich gerade unter Maximilian Krah stärker nach Türkei ausrichten will. Was interessant ist, weil du auch den Diskurs kennst der Nullerjahre von Rechtsradikalen. Es gibt zu viel Türken im Land oder sowas, haben die von sich gegeben. Jetzt ist ja so die Türkei und sind die Türken Verbündete im gemeinsamen Kampf gegen liberale Demokratie oder Genderwahn oder was auch immer. Ja, in Anführungszeichen natürlich jetzt gesetzt. Und dann haben wir ein Video, das viral geht, dass dieser auch sehr abgetriftete Moderator Achim Winter eine POC auf der Straße anspricht und zum März und der Brandmauer befragt und sagt, nein, alles richtig, die sollen mal Deutsch lernen, sich benehmen und so weiter. Und dann haben wir noch, das ging jetzt gestern, glaube ich, rund, von einer schwulen Dating-Plattform namens Gay-Romeo. Eine Umfrage haben die gemacht, wen die Leute da wählen. Allerdings konnte man wohl da freiwillig abstimmen, es war jetzt nicht irgendwie, man wurde nicht angerufen oder dergleichen. Und das wurde von Focus Online und so weiter aufgegriffen. 28 Prozent, 29 Prozent für die AfD. Dann nochmal ein großer Satz für die CDU.
Und jetzt wunderst du dich darüber, dass Menschen nicht nur im ökonomischen Feld gegen ihre Interessen wählen, sondern auch auf anderen.
Auch noch auf diesen. Ja, mich wundert das gar nicht. Ich finde es, was heißt wundert mich, ich finde es erstaunlich erst einmal, dass es einen solchen Rechtsruck gibt. Auch bei Gruppen, wo man eigentlich denken würde, naja, die würden ja von einer an sich progressiven Politik doch profitieren. Jetzt gibt's natürlich, werden jetzt sofort Leute sagen, ja, aber es gab doch immer wieder auch so Leute wie Harpe Kerkeling und so, der jetzt nicht rechts ist, aber der dann sagte, er fühlt sich nicht mehr so wohl in Berlin. Und das sei problematisch, wenn er da mit seinem Partner Hänzchen halb über die Straße geht. Und ich glaube auch, dass das ein Problem ist, also dass das jetzt nicht rein imaginiert ist. Aber ich finde interessant, dass man dann so weit geht, ob man jetzt Migrationsuntergrund hat oder eine nicht-heteronormative Lebensweise an den Tag legt, dass man dann so weit geht und sagt, man wählt AfD.
Ja, da muss ich dich immer wieder begeistern und faszinieren für ein großes Thema, Familie. Denn es ist ja nicht nur Michael Thatcher, sondern es ist auch Philipp Hopf, der in seinem Podcast immer wieder betont, wähle, was das Richtige ist für dich und deine Familie. Jetzt ist es so, egal wo du herkommst, ob aus der Türkei, aus Ghana, wie auch immer, so nach einer Zeit hast du dich in den Sing-Sang in Deutschland eingelebt und dann weißt du, alle sind für Familie. Und wenn jemand ein zweijähriges Kind töte, dann weißt du, das geht gegen ihn und gegen uns alle als Familie. Das war quasi unser Kind, hat ja Markus Söder gesagt. So er ist aus unserem Schoß gerissen. Wir wollten es noch lieben. Wohin jetzt mit unserer Liebe? Er hat uns das Kind genommen. Also dieses, wir kommen nachher ausführlich drauf zurück. Karl Schmidt, die Juden zwingen über die Nürnberger Prozesse der Welt ihre Moral auf. Schon wieder werden wir von ihnen besiegt.
Das ist ja Karl Schmidt.
Genau. Das finden wir immer wieder, überall. Wir kennen dieses Phänomen auch aus Amerika.
Und das ist unabhängig erstmal von der Identität. Also ich finde, dass diese Sachen, die ich jetzt gerade vorgetragen habe, das streicht quasi nochmal eine gewisse Identitätspolitik durch. Ich glaube, man hat sich bei der Identitätspolitik sehr lange darauf konzentriert, dass man glaubte, wenn alle repräsentiert sind oder so, dann gibt es eine generell fortschrittliche Entwicklung. Und dass dies aber nicht der Fall ist, das sehen wir da sehr deutlich. Und das sind glaube ich nicht nur Schlaglicht. Und man wird sicherlich sagen, wenn die da so eine Umfrage machen auf einer Datingplattform, werden vermutlich die Leute, die AfD-Anhänger sind, sich gegenseitig auch motivieren zu sagen, stimme da mal ab, damit die AfD kräftig da sind. Denn das werden ja die Medien aufgreifen, haben sie ja dann auch gestern getan. Und überall war das dann zu lesen, was ist los, die Schule, Community, Welt, die AfD. Okay, da gibt es solche Mobilisierungstendenzen. Ich glaube aber trotzdem, dass da eine gewisse Trendenz drin liegt, dass überhaupt solche Zahlen zustande kommen. Und das ist glaube ich das, was du dort beschreibst. Und bedeutet ja dann auch, dass dieser Rechtsruck vollzogen ist eigentlich schon in den Köpfen. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wer übt ihn nochmal politisch in einer besonders harten Weise aus?
Also die Ansprache, also Rechtsruck klingt immer so nach hochtrabend und so weiter. Rechtsruck beginnt, wenn die Ansage ist, du hast dich in der Schule angestrengt, du hast dein Zimmer aufgeräumt, du hast dir einen Walkman gekauft, der ist ab jetzt deiner. Und sobald du einen BMW gekauft hast und vielleicht darüber nachdenkst, dir ein Haus zu kaufen, ist unsere Ansprache deine Ansprache. Wir werden dafür sorgen, dass keine Mörder auf der Straße stehen und dein Kind auf dem Schulweg angreifen. Wir werden dafür Sorge tragen, dass niemals jemand kommt und sagt, du willst deinem Sohn diese zwei Quadratmeter vererben. Wir sorgen dafür, dass niemand da irgendetwas von 8 Knaps für den Staat hat. Das ist die Ansage. Die funktioniert und zwar auch dann, wenn man sagt, im Übrigen komme ich übrigens aus Ghana ursprünglich, aber das ist ja egal. Ich bin ja Held meines eigenen Schicksals jetzt gerade in diesem Moment, wo all das in Gefahr steht. Und dann kommt jemand und sagt, du und deine Familie, das ist uns heilig. Und man sagt sich, ja genau, ich bin der, der sich in der Schule angestrengt hat und nicht der Mörder. Also schlage ich mich auf diese Seite. Man kommt aus dieser Falle natürlich sehr schnell raus, wenn man sich nur, sagen wir mal, zehn Minuten am Tag mit jenseits des Horizontes und der eigenen Interessen beschäftigt. Aber wenn man das nicht macht, dann ist man leider zu dumm für die Demokratie. Also wir gehen da heute in diesem Buch durch, da wird es ja auch beschrieben. Der Mechanismus ist immer sehr viel einfacher als man glaubt. Man versucht ja immer die einfachsten, wahrscheinlich nur gefühlten intuitiven Mechanismen mit so überbordender Akademie und hier nochmal eine Studie und da nochmal irgendeine Theorie. Nein, man kann einfach kurz, also diese politischen Fragen aufzuklären, dafür reicht eine kurze Meditation. Weshalb ich auch mittlerweile denke, wenn ich so Karim Jostka sehe, wie sie ihre Talkshow moderiert oder Dunja Hayali, wie sie in der heutigen Sendung moderiert, einfach kurz zehn Minuten meditieren, einfach kurz zehn Minuten in sich gehen. Man braucht nicht viel um die Stolpersteine, über die, die die ganze Zeit stolpern, einfach zu bewältigen. Es ist eigentlich gar nicht so kompliziert. Man muss nur ganz kurz mal über die eigenen Gefühlswelten so nachdenken und sich denken, die anderen sind genauso Menschen wie ich. Anstatt hier irgendwie, ah ja, Hanna hat mir das vorhin noch mal, das ist ja super interessant, das verbinde ich mal damit und dann trage ich das so in zwei Sätzen, die ich schnell als Moderation geschrieben habe, vor. Funktioniert nicht. Deswegen ja auch, wir kommen halt auch darauf zu sprechen, dieses Geplauder in dem Podcast, wo man nur einen Termin einhält und dann findet der Podcast statt und man sich nicht groß vorbereitet. Das sind die Erfolgsrezepte, weil das Publikum hört sich dem Podcast auch einfach so an als Geplauder nebenbei und hält nicht mal einen Termin ein, sondern drückt zeitsouverän auf Play, wenn man halt soweit ist. Und das Publikum da einfach zu matchen ist ganz wichtig. Und das, was da stattfindet, ist nicht richtig im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk zum Beispiel.
Und damit natürlich auch die Aufmerksamkeit auf, ewig dieses Thema zu ziehen. Also es ist ja interessant, du musst ja, damit sich die POC auf der Straße, die gefragt wird, die Russlanddeutschen, die interviewt werden, die User einer Dating-Plattform, die gefragt werden und so, die musst du ja erstmal dazu bringen, dass sie als erstes, wenn sie eine politische Entscheidung treffen sollen, über Sicherheit und Migration nachdenken. Also das ist ja erstmal eine Leistung, die ja gebracht werden muss. Denn man könnte ja auch sagen, ich guck mir jetzt erstmal die Steuer an. Das wäre ja auch sehr naheliegend und auch an sich selbst gedacht, aber das wäre ja etwas, wo man dann wahrscheinlich zu anderen Ergebnissen käme.
Wir haben Geld als Gesundheit. So viele Sachen, Freundschaft. Wie finde ich meinen Lebenspartner, wie auch immer. Das sind so viele Fragen, die sich mit dem beschäftigen. Und dann wird ja so, jetzt machen wir eine politische Wahl. Okay, was ist mit den Ausländern? Was ist mit der Grenze, die 800 Kilometer weit weg ist von mir und so weiter. Also es ist wirklich eine super Leistung. Erfordert eben auch, dass ich der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk in Deutschland komplett der AfD unterwirft.
Im Prinzip, ja, ja.
Also komplette Kapitulation.
Und dadurch werden ja auch Themen gar nicht besprochen.
Vielleicht müssen wir dieses Bild mal... Wir haben alle gesehen, wie Mark Zuckerberg als größter Medienunternehmer der Welt eine Kapitulationserklärung abgegeben hat.
Ja.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich Karamioska sehe, sehe ich quasi Karamioska mit so einem schwarzen Hemd, mit so einer Goldkette und Locken, wie sie sich komplett unterwirft. Also ich hab jetzt Alice Weidel zu Gast. Ich konnte da nichts dagegen machen. Ich hab nachgeguckt, also das interessiert alle Leute. Und jetzt stelle ich ihr eine Frage. Und wenn ich die Antwort nicht verstehe und ich glaube, sie verstehen ihn auch nicht, dann sage ich, ja dann reichen wir morgen einen Faktencheck nach. Ja. So, Punkt. Das ist Kapitulation. Also es dann einfach nicht zu machen ist sehr viel besser.
Ja, weil wir die ganze Zeit darüber reden, was die AfD für eine Reichweite auf TikTok bekommt. Ich brauche überhaupt gar keinen TikTok dafür, um die ganze Zeit AfD-Content wahrzunehmen. Ich brauche nur das öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen und noch das Privatfernsehen dazu einschalten. Und die BILD-Zeitung, die sich dann rühmt, dass sie eine Distanz zur AfD haben, ja ihr macht die ganze Zeit AfD-Themen und Inhalte. Ihr braucht die gar nicht nochmal. Sie sagen dann, wir nehmen keine Werbegelder von der AfD an, um Wahlwerbung zu machen. Dann denke ich mir, ja die AfD wäre ja blöd bei euch nochmal Geld überhaupt abzugeben. Ihr macht ja die Werbung für die.
Es ist im Grunde überall derselbe Joke. Bei Horst und Hopf, die machen es halt explizit. Die sagen uns einfach, aber wir sagen euch nicht, wen wir wählen. Genau, das ist auch Bildtenor. Die sagen mir auch nicht, wen sie da wählen.
Nee, die wählen wahrscheinlich alle in Linkspartei. Auch noch ein Thema, in der Bildzeitung stand es, ganz interessant, kommt dann mal so kurz auf. Mehrwertsteuererhöhung. Veronika Grimm findet, das ist eine ganz gute Idee. Rürup sagte auch, ist eine gute Idee. Politik schweigt sich dazu aus. Die Ansage wäre drei Prozent Erhöhung, also um drei Prozent. Das heißt, wir hätten eine Mehrwertsteuer von 22 Prozent. Das ist die Idee. Ich habe den großen Verdacht, dass wir über diese, das könnte natürlich auch noch sein, dass wir dieses Problem bekommen werden. Also du findest nichts dazu in den Wahlprogrammen, das sage ich gleich. Es gibt so ein paar Vorschläge für Senkungen auf Lebensmittel oder Gastronomie, solche Mövenpick-Steuern, sage ich mal, solche Modelle gibt es natürlich. Es gibt soziale Ideen von einer Null Mehrwertsteuer auf lebenswichtige Güter. Aber wir finden nicht etwas von einer Mehrwertsteuererhöhung. Und eigentlich ist ja die Mehrwertsteuererhöhung eine perfekte neoliberale Strategie. Du weißt, die wollen eigentlich immer mal an die Renten ran, können das nicht, weil sie da ihre Wähler haben. Du kannst die Renten erhöhen, kannst aber die Mehrwertsteuer zugleich erhöhen und dadurch hast du dann die Renten wieder abgeschöpft. Die Leute, die nicht reich sind, die besteuert man ja dann besonders. Das heißt also, man entlastet mit der Mehrwertsteuererhöhung reiche Leute. Ja, man kann sogar die Steuersenkungen für Reiche, die von der CDU ja geplant sind, kann man wunderbar finanzieren durch eine Mehrwertsteuererhöhung. Jetzt werden manche sagen, naja, aber die Reichen zahlen doch auch Mehrwertsteuer. Die Sache ist nur, die zahlen ja nur einen Teil von ihrem Gehalt. Haben sie eine hohe Sparrate, sie investieren etc. Das heißt, sie verkonsumieren ja keineswegs ihr gesamtes Geld. Während die Normalverdiener und Niedrigverdiener müssen ja ihren Lohn fast komplett verkonsumieren. Das heißt, bei denen ist eine Mehrwertsteuererhöhung ganz einfach zu rechnen. Sie haben drei Prozent weniger in ihrem Portemonnaie. Für Reiche gilt das nicht. Wenn die ein Steuergeschenk bekommen, in der Form, dass sie eine niedrigere Einkommenssteuer zahlen müssen, die Unternehmenssteuer gesenkt wird und Vermögensteuer auch nicht kommt und Erbschaftssteuer noch weiter vernachlässigt wird, dann bekommen die so viel mehr Geld, dass das für die dann kein Problem ist, wenn die dann drei Prozent mehr zahlen müssen, wenn sie eine Rolex kaufen. Also das ist wirklich eine sehr, sehr ungerechte Steuer sowieso schon. Und man kann ja generell in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten sehen, wie diese Konsumsteuern immer angehoben wurden, während man Unternehmenssteuern und andere Steuern, die reiche belasten wurden, gesenkt hat. Und ich habe die große Sorge, dass dann unter einer Koalition mit Friedrich Merz, egal wer dann da drinnen im Boot sitzen wird, dass dann so etwas kommt und dass man das auch damit begründet, dass man sagt, ja uns sind die Hände sonst gebunden. Uns tut das auch sehr weh, aber wir müssen es leider machen.
Ja, Themenvorschlag für Wohlstand für alle. Wir sagen ja immer, der Staatshaushalt und der private Haushalt ist nicht eins. Nur der private Haushalt und der private Haushalt sind auch nicht eins. Es gibt private Haushalte, die mehrwertsteuererhöhungsanfällig sind. Nämlich am Ende des Monats, bis dahin wird alles Geld ausgegeben und dann kommt ein Paycheck und dann geht es halt weiter. Und dann gibt es ja Haushalte, die Wert kaufen, Aktien oder sowas. Und Scott Galloway hat das letztens beschrieben, das ist wirklich sehr clever, wie das die Superreichen machen. Sagen wir mal die Mittelreichen bis Superreichen. Man kauft sich Wertgegenstände, die als Sicherheit in der Bank dienlich sind. Und dann holt man sich Kredite für ein, zwei Prozent. Also, das sind ja immer noch relativ niedrige Zente. Was bedeutet, man muss niemals von den eigenen Wertbeständen abrücken, sondern man verschuldet sich mit ihrer Hilfe. Was bedeutet, dass man zum einen 100 Prozent Gewinne einfährt. Also diese Dividenden bleiben ja als Buchgeld-Sicherheit vorhanden. Sie werden ja nicht aktualisiert, liquidiert. Und dadurch fällt keine Abgeltung, keine Ertrags-, keine Einkommenssteuer, nichts fällt an. Also man hat einfach, man sieht abends Anja Kohl sagt in den Tagesthemen, DAX 10 Prozent oben und man weiß, ich bin 10 Prozent reicher. Darauf fällt nichts, keine Steuer, nichts an. Und dann geht man zur Bank und holt sich als, das ist meine Sicherheit, ein Kredit in der Höhe, in der man Geld braucht und achtet einfach darauf, dass man nie unter Wasser ist, sondern immer die Sicherheit größer ist als das eigene Kreditvolumen, das man da aufruft. Und für diesen Kredit bezahlt man dann ein, zwei Prozent. Und damit ist man liquide. Oder aber, man verrechnet einfach mit seinem Steuerberater oder seiner Anwaltskanzlei erstmal alle Ausgaben, die man hat gegen das eigene Einkommen. Da reicht man dann die Mehrwertsteuer erstmal weiter, deklariert das als Betriebsaufgabe, wie alles möglich ist. So werden alle Autos gekauft, 90 Prozent aller Autos. Man fragt sich immer, die Deutschen sind so arm, aber auf der Autobahn stehen, ich sehe immer nur Mercedes, Audi, BMW und so weiter. Das läuft ja alles über dieses, weil da gar kein Steuerlast anfällt. Das wird betrieblich verrechnet und so weiter und so fort. Also es gibt auch Haushalt und Haushalt. Und Mehrwertsteuer betrifft eben nur den einen Haushalt. Und im anderen Haushalt, ob ich jetzt in meiner Rechnung, in der ich das einfach weiterreiche, 19, 21, 22 Prozent, dann reiche ich mir doch gar nicht mehr.
Dann reichen es weiter, völlig egal. Es ist wirklich nur die private Rolex, die man sich dann kauft und da sagt man sich, die gönne ich mir. Naja, man kann sich auch sagen, ich habe so tolle Steuergeschenke jetzt bekommen. Ich zahle zehn Prozent weniger Einkommensteuer und die Kapitalertragssteuer wurde auch noch gesenkt. Da kann ich mir locker eine Rolex von kaufen und die drei Prozent Mehrwertsteuer habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Genau. Während wir hier wirklich eine Politik haben, die wieder die betrifft, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen und mit dem wenigen Geld, das sie verdienen, dann sehen müssen, dass sie über die Runden kommen. Die sollen dann drei Prozent weniger bekommen. Also ich sehe das als eine große Gefahr an. Wird nicht thematisiert. Ist jetzt mal hier da in der Bild so ein Vorschlag, aufgegriffen, so als Meldung hat man da mal gelesen. Wird dabei auch dem nicht weiter nachgegangen. Das ist eigentlich jetzt schon das Thema, so vorbereitet sein für das, was nach der Wahl geschieht. Und dann kann man sich Friedrich Merz schon genau vorstellen und kann sich auch vorstellen, wie alle mitmachen. Also das ist ja auch noch interessant. Wir wissen ja noch damals bei der letzten Mehrwertsteuererhöhung, war das ja so, man hatte 16 Prozent Mehrwertsteuer. Und dann gab es von der CDU den Vorschlag, sie um zwei Prozent zu erhöhen. Daraufhin sagte die SPD, never ever, das machen wir nicht mit. Dann machte man eine große Koalition mit CDU und SPD. Und die Mehrwertsteuer wurde nicht um zwei Prozent, sondern um drei Prozent angehoben.
Nach der Wahl hast du vier Jahre lang frei. Kannst du machen, was du willst. Sieht man jetzt auch in Amerika. Du musst nur den Wahlkampf durchstehen, siegreich. Und nachher kannst du machen, was du willst. Ja, nicht sehr gut für Deutschland, denn wir wählen ja demnächst. Ab dann sind wir mal gucken, auch irgend wem ausgeliefert. Wie die Amerikaner, Elon Musk, war sicher immer noch top Thema, liebe Journalisten. Ich will keine weiteren Texte zu Gaza hören, das ist alles so ein Unfug. Elon Musk ist das Thema. Gut, was lesen wir heute?
Wir lesen heute Zu Dumm für die Demokratie von Marc Schiritz. Das ist ein Buch, das die liberale Ordnung schützen will. Schiritz ist ja Zeitjournalist, der so in der Mitte und ein bisschen links steht, würde ich sagen. So würde man ihn vielleicht einordnen können.
Wenn man ihn noch einordnen muss. Ich bin ja so.
Vielleicht brauchen wir es nicht. Jedenfalls ist es ein Buch, das fragt, sind wir zu dumm für die Demokratie? Diese Frage will dieses Buch mal antworten. Wir werden darüber diskutieren, ob es das tut, beziehungsweise ob nicht auch andere Dummheiten ausgeplendet werden.
Ja, total. Aber es gibt eine klare Antwort auf die Frage, die auf dem Buch steht.
Darauf gibt es eine klare Antwort. Ich würde diese Antwort nur vielleicht erweitern wollen.
Das geht natürlich, da bin ich total dafür.
Denn ich glaube, dass man es sich dann auch nicht zu einfach machen darf, indem man zum Beispiel dann zu sehr auf die AfD abzielt. Jedenfalls ist das ein gutes Debattenbuch, über das wir diskutieren können im Salon. Ich habe außerdem dabei ein Buch über Kolipris. Kolipris sind ganz besondere Vögel. Es gibt eine Schriftstellerin, die bei einer Kolipri-Rettung dabei war oder zwei Kolipris wurden gerettet. Und sie beschreibt wunderbar diese kleinen Tierchen und zeigt damit eine sehr stille Form des Umweltschutzes. Und es ist ein sehr, sehr schönes Buch, dass einem, man möchte es fast nicht sagen, aber es ist so, Hoffnung gibt. Dann habe ich einen Erzählungsband gelesen von Mesut Bayraktar. Der schreibt über Menschen, die ganz normale Menschen sind, die also von einer Mehrwertsteuer-Erhöhung betroffen werden. Er schreibt von einer Studentin hier in Deutschland, die ihr Studium damit finanziert, dass sie auch nebenher sich verkaufen muss. Er schreibt von zwei Brüdern. Der eine versucht eine akademische Karriere, der andere arbeitet und sieht ja auch, wie Entlassungen um ihn herum stattfinden. Er beschreibt von einem Arbeiter, der morgens ins Werk geht und weiß noch nicht, ob er am Abend noch Arbeit haben wird. Es sind wirklich die Ausbeutungsverhältnisse hier in Deutschland, wie sie sind. Aber zugleich ist da eine poetische Sprache, die sehr faszinierend ist. Die Lage heißt dieser Band.
Darüber werden wir sprechen. Ich geh für mich nach links, grün, versifften, Wogscheiß über Leute, die ihr Zimmer nicht aufgeräumt haben.
So würde das wohl Haus und Hopf sagen. Ja. Dann gibt es wieder einen Musik-Tipp. Diesmal die vier Jahreszeiten. Wird man sagen, braucht man jetzt noch die vier Jahreszeiten. Brauchen wir da noch mal eine Neueinspielung?
Es ist Winter, klar.
Man braucht genau diese Einspielung.
Sehr gut.
Dann ein Text über den Weltraum-Kolonialismus von Elon Musk und Donald Trump. Und es gibt eine sehr ausführliche Recherche von zwei Journalisten, die sich gefragt haben, warum wird eigentlich immer gesagt, die Ukrainer wollen kämpfen. Stimmt das überhaupt? Und die Antwort ist nein, das können wir uns vielleicht schon denken, aber die Zahlen, die dann hier genannt werden, sind wirklich noch einmal erschütternd und hochinteressant und aufschlussreich. Und ich hoffe, dass das vielleicht ein paar Leute auch mitbekommen, die bei Twitter immer unterwegs sind und immer genau wissen, wie sehr alle kämpfen wollen.
Wir lesen meinerseits dieses fantastische Buch Gemeinsinn, das ich allen empfehle als Lektüre, die jetzt gerade sich in Wahlkämpfen verstricken und sich fragen, worum geht es eigentlich gerade und auf welchen Fundamenten sollten meine Argumentationen basieren, wenn ich in einer Talkshow sitze und über ein Thema diskutiert wird und ich über dieses Thema gar nicht reden will, sondern über ein anderes. So, also es ist ein wahnsinnig orientierungsbietendes, sehr lesereiches, also da wird sozusagen durch eine ganze Bibliothek gestreift und uns zusammengesammelt, was wir wissen müssen. Wir lesen daraus Auszüge zu Karl Schmidt, Emanuel Kant und Omri Böhm, denn es regt auch sehr zum Denken an und wir müssen über den radikalen Universalismus nochmal neu nachdenken. Das werde ich gleich vorschlagen. Außerdem strotzt dieses Buch auch mit Beispielen. Man hat ja sehr häufig bei so etwas tiefergehenden theoretischen Denken, dass so das politische Denken aufgreift und so weiter. Ja, was hat das jetzt mit Östritz zu tun? Und dann gehen die einfach auf den Marktplatz von Dörfern zur Tafel und gucken sich das genau an und sagen, hier finden wir, was wir suchen und so. Also das ist wirklich fantastisch. Alle, die jetzt politische Diskussionen führen, müssen dieses Buch in ihrem Bücherregal haben. Dann gehen wir kurz durch Bloombergs Podcast-Analyse. Darüber hatte ich auch schon Text geschrieben vor zwei Wochen. Wir gehen diese Zahlen nochmal durch, weil das unsere Fragestellung ist. Und Mark Zuckerberg auch sagt, es ist ganz erstaunlich, aber die Leute hören heute anderen Leuten zu. Also es ist nicht mehr Klaus Kleber und Joel Reed, sondern es sind jetzt neue Leute, die die Debatte trägen. Dann gibt es für mich als 200 Euro pro User von GPT die Möglichkeit mir Deep Research-Dossiers zu erstellen. Ich habe also ein Dossier erstellt über den Filmkritiker Wolfgang M. Schmidt. Das liebeste mir.
Wirklich?
Ja. Gehen wir mal den Sing-Sagen und den Textverlauf durch, was über dich herausgefunden wurde im Internet.
Vielleicht Dinge, die ich noch gar nicht von mir selbst weiß.
Ja, das ist ganz interessant. Also egal, was man an Fragestellungen los wird, man kriegt so 2700 Worte, was schon, sagen wir mal, vier, fünf Zeitungsspalten, eine ganze Seite mit einem nicht allzu großen Bild ist, also viel. Und die Zeit hat neue Grundbegriffe vorgestellt. Das ist natürlich wieder so ein Text, der mich einfach fängt über so eine, sagen wir mal, etwas einfache Art und Weise. Aber es ist doch unter den sechs Begriffen einer dabei, das Sichtbarkeitsregime, dem wir eine kleine Aufmerksamkeit widmen zum Schluss. In den Salon kommt man über die Neuenzwanziger als Webseite. Wir sind also ein Podcast mit Webseite. Das ist sehr untypisch. Versucht mal einen Podcast runterzuladen und nicht nur bei Spotify anzuhören. Das ist bei uns einfach möglich. neuenzwanziger.de. Da findet man alles und auch den goldenen Button in den Salon. Da kann man einfach folgen. Und wir haben eine Neuerung. Diejenigen, die Salon-Hörer schon sind, bekommen ab jetzt alle Inhalte dieses Podcasts im Salon. Also der öffentliche Feed hat zwar den öffentlichen Podcast, aber dieses Gespräch, was wir jetzt gerade führen, geht sozusagen pausenlos über in den Salon für Salonmitglieder, während es für Nicht-Salonmitglieder einfach abbricht und bisher auch für Salonmitglieder abbrach, die dann den Salon einzeln anklicken mussten. Ab jetzt machen wir es einfacher. Auch die Monatsfolge gibt es ab Februar im Salon. Und dieses Gespräch hier ist direkt einfach vorm Salon dran. Also man kann einfach weiterhören. Es macht wohl sehr viel einfacher und zwar vielfacher Wunsch.
Wer abonniert hat, muss jetzt nur noch einen einzigen Feed haben und alles andere fällt weg.
Und wir haben nachgeschaut, es gibt noch einige Termine für Herbst und Winter. Ungefähr so 100. Viel ist nicht mehr von 800 insgesamt. Weshalb wir euch im Salon nochmal einen Sommertermin bekannt geben.
Ja, sag aber doch nochmal gerade für alle, die noch zu dem normalen Live-Salon wollen, wo sie und wie sie da an Karten kommen. Also das sind ja, also der Märztermin ist völlig ausverkauft. Ein paar Restkarten gibt es noch für den Juni, das ist der?
20 Tickets gibt es für den Juni noch am 20. Juni.
Am 20. Juni, ja.
Da sagt uns Wolfgang auch gleich im Salon, dass wir vorher in die Oper gehen. Aber nur für hartgesottene. Diese Oper geht 5,5 Stunden. 19.9. gibt es noch Tickets und 19.12. ungefähr 100. Ja und dann sagen wir euch einen Sommersalon-Termin. Wolfgang hat ja schon ein Programm vorgeschlagen. Die E-Mail-Adresse, unter der ihr Tickets bestellt für die vier Case-Termine, nenne ich euch nicht, sondern die steht im Text, damit es nicht zu Transkriptionsproblemen kommt, wenn jetzt jemand nur zuhört, sondern in den Show-Notes dieses Podcasts ist einfach, die stehen alle Termine und die E-Mail-Adresse ist genannt. So, Termine bekannt, um in den Salon überzuleiten. Und zwar als Klebstoff sozusagen zwischen unserer Diskussion, Rechtsruck, Merzmacht, quasi AfD-Politik und so weiter. Und der Frage, sind wir zu dumm, das zu verstehen, was da passiert? Hier mal Clips, die das wirklich sehr gut illustrieren. Wir haben auf der einen Seite Wolfgang Schmidt, der Olaf Scholz rechter Hand als Chef der Staatskanzlei, als Bundeskanzleramts ist, der also die echten politischen Geschäfte führt, der die Klammer ist zwischen Parlament und Kanzlerschaft. Und auf der anderen Seite Philipp Braunsheimer, Paul Braunsheimer, der mit dem Philipp Dings da diesen Podcast macht und in dem Fall jetzt Schmidt zum Gast hat. Und wir hören jetzt einfach heraus, wo die Schieflagen sind. Wir haben es ausführlich diskutiert. Wir können es jetzt mal hier richtig hören und sozusagen als Datengrundlage benutzen für unser Gespräch zum Buch. Denn das Problem, was das Buch behandelt, wird hier zu 100% deutlich. Also es ist selten wahr, ist so klar. Fangen wir mal an. Es sind insgesamt sechs Clips. Angeblich, das Gespräch verläuft schon eine Weile, sagt Braunsheimer, sagen Sie immer nur, was nicht geht, Herr Politiker.
Jetzt zuhört und sagt, das ist die Argumentation. Dann sag mal noch einen Moment mal, Sie sind Kanzleramtschef. Sie haben ja auch Ministerpräsidenten, die SPD-Ministerpräsidenten sind und Sie beschreiben, was aus Grund von Urteilen nicht geht, was woanders nicht geht. Also Sie beschreiben immer, was nicht geht.
Ich hab gerade versucht zu beschreiben, was wir alles gemacht haben und genau mit den Ministerpräsidenten, die dafür zuständig sind, haben wir ganz weitreichende Verabredungen getroffen.
So, also es sind irgendwelche Ministerpräsidenten zuständig, weitreichend Verabredungen wurden getroffen. Es geht um juristische Texte und so weiter und so fort. Marc Schiritz klärt uns ja darüber auch auf, dass es relativ selten wegen deutscher Grundgesetzgebung zu Asylverfahren kommt in Deutschland, sondern es sind Genver-Konventionen, Menschenrechtskartas und so weiter und so fort. Also internationales Recht, wo man jetzt nicht einfach drüber fliegen kann. So, wir haben also einen Clash zwischen ja, aber wir haben doch Magdeburg erlebt und Erschaffenburg erlebt und dann sagt der andere, aber wir haben doch Ministerpräsidenten und wir haben doch internationales Recht.
Wir haben Solingen erlebt, wir haben Magdeburg erlebt, wir haben Erschaffenburg erlebt und ich könnte das weiterführen und wir würden hier lange sitzen. Der Eindruck, der entsteht, wenn wir sagen, das geht alles nicht, bedeutet doch gleichzeitig, dass wir bereit sind, das als in gewisser Weise normal anzuerkennen.
Nein, niemals. Ich bin immer sehr dafür, dass man sich genau anguckt, was sind Ursachen und was sind Gründe und dann auch überlegt, was muss man tun.
Also hier geht es doch um...
Machen wir doch mal ein ganz einfaches Beispiel. Ich habe ja gesagt, ich bin da von Belgien gekommen, dann ist so ein Grenzübertritt, man hat da ein paar Polizisten aufgestellt, man wird runter getrostet auf 20, dauert ein paar Minuten, alle fahren aber durch. Man sieht auf der anderen Spur, die LKWs, die fahren auch alle durch, auch mit 20 kmh. Jetzt stellen wir uns mal vor, man würde das, was Friedrich Merz da so verspricht, tatsächlich machen. Man würde sagen, man muss jedes Auto checken, denn ich könnte ja jemanden im Kofferraum haben. Man müsste in jeden LKW reinleuchten. Wir hätten Staus von Stunden. Wir haben ja diese EU einmal konstruiert, deshalb weil wir einen EU-Binnenhandel beschleunigen, verstärken, intensivieren wollten. Jetzt stellte man sich vor, man würde die Grenzen wieder so dicht machen, dichter als sie jemals waren, denn man müsste, um alles kontrollieren zu können, jeden einfach anhalten und da kann man nicht sagen auch der Fahrrad mir aber gefallen, sondern nein, man muss überall reinleuchten, sind da hinten zehn Leute drin oder nicht. Das würde bedeuten nicht nur, dass man zehntausende Polizisten mehr benötigen würde, sondern es würde bedeuten, dass man riesige Staus produziert, ja dass plötzlich die Importkosten extrem und auch Exportkosten extrem steigen würden innerhalb der europäischen Länder, weil ja alles wieder mit Grenzverkehr ist. Ja man hat ja, wenn man sich mal ansieht, wo die Lkw-Routen und so weiter hergehen, die haben ja 2, 3 Grenzüberträger, die müssen Österreich und Deutschland und so weiter, wenn die das alles immer unter solchen Kontrollen machen müssten, wäre das eine Katastrophe. Also das, was Friedrich Merz dort verspricht, ist nur Deklamation von irgendetwas, was sich gut anhört, vielleicht in Talkshows oder in Social Media Videos für manche Leute. Es ist aber politisch gar nicht umsetzbar. Das kann er aber nicht sagen, weil er sonst von Paul Ronzheimer hören würde, ja sie sagen uns immer, was nicht geht.
Umso einfacher die politische Lösung, umso komplizierter wird es in der Realität. Das sieht man ja gerade in Amerika. Also Trump hat jetzt einfach gesagt, ich bedrohe Kanada, Mexiko und China mit Zöllen. Dann hat irgendwie Trudeau so eine Rede gehalten, ach die lieben Amerikaner, das sind doch unsere besten Freunde und so weiter. Und man hat sich irgendwie so geeinigt und so drei Stunden vorher, ne doch nicht. Nur China hat dann gesagt, ja gut wir reden erstmal nicht mit euch, wir machen auch einfach Zölle. Wir lassen es drauf ankommen. So. Jetzt bestellen die Amerikaner aber Waren aus China, die in 1,3 Milliarden Paketen münden, die alle bislang unter einer, also 800 Dollar Warenwert gilt als Grenze. Erst danach greifen die ganzen Zollgesetzgebungen. So. Jetzt sind also nicht nur diese 10 Prozent Zoll.
Zum Teil ist ja Zoll bei, ich glaube schon bei 20, 25 Dollar. Hält an bei diesen Temu-Versendungen.
Ja, also Temu und Shi'in haben davon profitiert, dass es so eine 800 Dollar Grenze gibt. Alles darunter wird pauschal nicht, also wird sozusagen als Cams aus dem amerikanischen Waren.
Ich glaub, sie ist niedriger.
Ja, doch, das waren 800 Dollar. Was zu dem Problem führt, dass diese neuen Zölle, also die neue Regelung, die neue Executive Order, nicht nur diese Zölle von 10 Prozent deklariert, sondern auch diese Zollausnahme für einzelne Lieferungen aufhebt. Was bedeutet, alle 1,3 Milliarden jährlichen Pakete müssen jetzt begutachtet werden. So und was macht der Postal Service in Amerika? Er sagt, das ist uns zu viel Arbeit, das schaffen wir nie, wir lassen nichts mehr durch. Ja. So, jetzt sitzen einfach sehr viele Menschen in Amerika da, haben Sachen bestellt, die nicht geliefert werden. So, damit, also das war jetzt auch nicht Trumps Ansehen, aber die einfache Lösung zu sagen, ok, da machen wir jetzt die Grenze zu, ja dann ist die Grenze halt dann wirklich zu in dem Fall. Jetzt betrifft es erstmal nur die Freizügigkeit dieser Pakete. Das ist sozusagen, also Wien möchte keine englischen wissenschaftlichen Arbeiten mehr, ist sozusagen, das ist das Niveau, auf dem man dann…
Ja, ja, also ich mein man muss sich das mal vorstellen, mit dem Lkw-Verkehr, man würde den derart kontrollieren wollen, dann müsste eigentlich Friedrich Merz sagen, ja wir haben da jetzt ganz restriktive Maßnahmen vor, das kostet den Steuerzahler 100 Milliarden. Aber dafür stellen wir auch sicher, dass hier nicht einer reinkommt, der das Bürgergeld kassiert, obwohl er es eigentlich gar nicht haben dürfte. Kostet aber 100 Milliarden. Genau.
Also keine Migration bedeutet kein frisches Gemüse im Supermarkt. So und das müsste eigentlich Kram-Wioska durchdiskutieren. Und zwar nicht nur mit Politikern, die dann eine Meinung dazu haben, sondern mit Leuten, die uns Wählern beschreiben, was das bedeutet.
Ja.
Und nicht und so weiter. So, jetzt ist der Schmidt da und möchte über Details reden. Aber Paul Ronsheimer nicht.
Es tritt nach den Dublin-Regeln nach sechs Monaten, nachdem der das Gesuch hier gestellt hat, sogenannter Selbsteintritt ein und Deutschland wird zuständig. Und dann werden wir sie nicht mehr los. Es gibt aber eine Möglichkeit, die heißt nämlich, wenn derjenige als flüchtig ausgeschrieben wird, verlängert sich diese sechs Monatsfrist auf 18 Monate. Und mit dem neuen europäischen Asylsystem verlängert sie sich übrigens auf drei Jahre und wir müssen nicht mal mehr warten, bis der Dublin-Staat sagt, jawohl, wir sind zuständig, sondern wir können dem einfach mitteilen nach unseren Vorstellungen, seid ihr zuständig? Wir müssen die also nur noch notifizieren. Also eine deutliche Verbesserung. Deswegen ärgert es mich so, dass wir dieses Umsetzungsgesetz für die europäischen Ersügungen jetzt nicht im Bundestag mit den Stimmen der CDU und der FDP beschlossen haben. Und dann ist es bei dem Erschaffenburg-Fall genau das Gleiche. Auch da war wieder Bulgarien zuständig. Die hatten sogar erklärt, jawohl, wir übernehmen ihn. Und dann hat es, weil die Übermittlung lange gedauert hat, weil das Verfahren auch im Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge zu lange gedauert hat und weil dann die bayerischen Behörden nicht schnell gehandelt haben, wieder dieses Selbsteintrittsrecht. Und im Falle des Erschaffenburger Täters ist der ja auch auffällig gewesen. Der ist den Behörden bekannt gewesen. Da gibt es das sogenannte Psych-KG, also das psychisch kranke Gesetz, wieder ein Landesgesetz, das vorsieht, dass Leute, die psychisch auffällig werden, in Gewahrsam genommen werden, Amtsärzten vorgeführt werden können.
Und dennoch hat ja Friedrich Merz einen Punkt, wenn er sagt, dadurch, dass weiter sehr viele Menschen nach Deutschland kommen, weil es sind ja weiterhin auch Großstädte. Wie viele haben wir im Vergleich?
Bla, bla, bla. Also er nennt die alle Gesetze, alle Zuständigkeiten, selbst das psychischen Krankengesetz und so.
Ja, wunderschön, dass er das alles kennt.
Na gut, er ist Staatskanzlei, Bundeskanzleramtchef und so. Aber Friedrich Merz hat nicht trotzdem einen Punkt, dass wenn noch Leute kommen, ja genau, also klar, wenn noch Leute kommen, also wenn wir die Grenze nicht komplett zumachen. Schmidt versucht hier weiter sein Bestes, auch nochmal diesen Entschließungsantrag und diese Ankündigungspolitik zu entlarven, als das was ist.
Es geht schon um konkretes Handeln. Es geht darum, dass man diese ganzen vielen Stellschrauben, die man bis an den Anschlag drehen muss, auch tatsächlich dreht. Und da kommt man nicht mit einem Entschließungsantrag und mit so einer martialisch vorgetragenen Forderung durch, die in der Praxis nicht geht. Sie ist rechtswidrig, sie würde dazu führen.
Da gibt es unterschiedliche Ansichten, das muss ich nochmal einführen.
Aber es gibt eine herrschende Meinung, es gibt die Gerichtsurteile, es gibt eine verschwindende Mindermeinung und meine Sorge ist, wenn jetzt dieser Eindruck erweckt wird, es sei alles ganz einfach, man müsse nur den Zauberstab nehmen und sagen wir machen die Grenzen dicht. Und dann kommen am nächsten Tag doch welche, weil du 3800 Kilometer Grenze gar nicht lückenlos überwachen kannst.
Das sagt die Bundespolizei, sie kann das?
Nein, die Bundespolizei sagt nicht, sie kann die 3800 Kilometer Grenze lückenlos überwachen. Sie kann das machen, was wir jetzt ja gemacht haben. Wir haben Grenzkontrollen seit Oktober 2023. Das hat dazu geführt, dass wir jetzt über 40.000 Zurückweisungen gemacht haben. Wenn Herr Merz dann sagt, andere Staaten würden das auch machen. Ich hab's mir jetzt noch mal genau angeguckt. Das stimmt einfach nicht. Andere Staaten machen exakt das, was wir machen, nämlich verschärfte Grenzkontrollen. Auch da übrigens, die muss man alle sechs Monate in Europa beantragen bzw. notifizieren und muss immer wieder begründen, warum es nötig ist. Das haben wir gemacht.
Aber aus Ihrer Sicht, Herr Schmidt, wie viele Menschen kann Deutschland weiter jedes Jahr aufnehmen?
637.
Es ist wirklich absurd. So jetzt hören wir hier nochmal bei Wolfgang Schmidt, der versucht sein Bestes. Und während wir das hören, er macht jetzt ein größeres Argument, denken wir, okay, der verlässt jetzt diesen Posten und Carsten Linnemann wird als Chef des Bundeskanzleramts da einziehen.
Da bin ich wirklich der Meinung, dass wir auch daran nicht rütteln sollten. Wir sollten weiterhin für Menschen in Not da sein. Das ist unsere Aufgabe als Menschheit und gerade Deutschland hat da eine Verantwortung.
So, das ist glaube ich der letzte. Das ist sozusagen die aussterbende Generation. Solange noch Holocaust-Überlebende da waren, konnte man solche Leute im Kanzleramt hören. Demnächst einfach, nee, also ein totes Kind grenze zu. Und es wird ja ein ganz vehement, es sind ja alle Podcasts voll, Ronsheimer, Gordon Rypinski heute Morgen, ganz energisch, aber es ist ein Kind gestorben. Ja genau, es ist ein Kind gestorben. So und deswegen machen wir jetzt, verschließen uns von der Welt, also wo ist denn da überhaupt der inhaltliche Zusammenhang, geschweige denn, und wieso trägst du es so vor, also es ist doch...
Und in einer Weise, dass man wählen kann, jeweils zwischen tabula rasa und Vollkatastrophe oder was ist das. Also das ist ja ein hochdysfunktionales System, das man dort mit Friedrich Merz etablieren will. Es ist ja nicht so, das kann man ja in den USA gut sehen, dass dann alles funktioniert, dass man sagen kann, es ist eine fürchterlich rechte Politik, aber sie funktioniert in irgendeiner Weise, dass man sagt, das ist ein handlungsfähiger Staat. Nein, diese Leute treiben einen ja in die Katastrophe rein, weil sie ja gar nicht diese anderen Dinge mitbedenken, die da sind. Also das ist ja einfach irrsinnig zu glauben, dass es so einfach ginge. Selbst wenn man das wollen würde, was wir jetzt nicht wollen, aber so müsste man doch eigentlich darüber reden. Und ich finde das interessant, dass auch Journalisten, die ja doch ein bisschen rumkommen und die da wahrscheinlich auch den ein oder anderen Grenzübertritt haben, die ja jetzt nicht in der Eifel leben auf dem Bauernhof und sagen, die sollen man die Grenzen dicht machen, weil man selbst noch nie im Ausland war. Das sind ja Leute, die auch die ganze Zeit hin und her reisen. Die müssten doch eigentlich verstehen, dass das umsetzbar so einfach nicht ist.
Vor allem Andrea Nahles macht ja jetzt eine Pressekonferenz nach der anderen, in der sie immer wieder diese Arbeitsmarktzahlen nennt und immer wieder darauf hinweist, die einzigen, die hier Wachstum bringen, sind ausländische Arbeitskräfte. Es gehen Deutsche in Rente und wir stellen Ausländer ein, weil es sind ja keine Deutschen da. So, wenn man jetzt als Journalist eins plus eins ist zwei, wenn man dabei bleiben möchte und man stellt fest, also Remigration geht gar nicht, dann muss man für sich kurz feststellen, ah so, Remigration ist einfach von heute in die Vergangenheit gedacht. Diejenigen, die schon kamen, kommen nicht. Das was Friedrich Merz hier macht ist Demigration. Ab heute kommt keiner mehr. Ja. Das ist genau dasselbe. Das ist nur das eine Mal nach vorne und das andere Mal nach hinten gerechnet. Aber Remigration wie die AfD und Demigration wie Friedrich Merz führt einfach ökonomisch wirklich in den Abgrund. Wir haben noch keine KI-Roboter, sie hat, Elon Musk hat sie uns noch nicht vorgestellt, die Enno, der an der Kasse sitzt, ein LKW fährt oder was auch immer, den ersetzt. Und wird es auch die nächsten 20 Jahre nicht geben.
Und es wird auch keinen Bürokratieabbau geben mit FDP und CDU bei gleichzeitiger Erhöhung der Grenzmaßnahmen und der Totalüberwachung von allen.
Das sind sie zu als Bürokratie pur.
Ja.
Also das ist einfach, das ist nicht nur, wir stellen da Polizisten hin, sondern die brauchen auch eine Handlungsgrundlage. Das geht nur durch Bürokratie. Diese Befugnisse, die da neu geschaffen werden müssen und so, das ist einfach, ja, das wird nicht gut ausgehen. Die promptet einem auch nicht CPT mal schnell hin, nur weil es in juristischen Fragen gut ist. Ein letzter Clip, Schmidt versucht es mal so auf den Punkt zu bringen. Es ist aber Ronzheimers Podcast, es führt nirgendwo hin.
Das Thema ist ja kaputt offenbar.
Ja, aber das ist ein bisschen meine Schwierigkeit, dass jetzt immer dann, wenn man ins Konkrete geht, gesagt wird, ja, aber das geht alles nicht.
Aber ganz offensichtlich geht es ja nicht, weil es dreimal...
Ja, aber man drückt sich dann vor der harten Arbeit, die nämlich bedeutet, dass man jedes einzelne Gesetz angucken muss, dass man mit den Behörden darüber streiten muss, dass zwei Drittel der Ausländerbehörden nicht digitalisiert sind, dass man darüber reden muss, dass es nicht genug Haftplätze gibt. Das haben wir genau gemacht, aber nochmal, das ist die Aufgabe der Länder und das ist die Aufgabe der Kommunen.
Ja, so sie waren ja drei Jahre lang in der Regierung. Ja, als Regierung kann man was machen? Gesetze schreiben. Nur Gesetze umsetzen, das ist halt auch ein Thema. So, wenn man Gesetze hat, die man nicht umsetzt, dann ist es ein Umsetzungsproblem und wenn man dann nochmal neue Gesetze schreibt, vergrößert man nur das Umsetzungsproblem, aber löst gar nichts. Ein Gestrampel hier an diesen Themen. Und Ronzheimer, es ist natürlich eine andere Wortwahl und eine andere Emotionalität. Aber das ist im Grunde Philipp Hopf inhaltlich. Eins zu eins. Wieso machen sich die Grenzen nicht zu? Wir haben doch Aschaffenburg und Magdeburg erlebt. Ist ein Kind nicht zu viel? Und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, ich finde das sehr so interessant, dass er ja jemand ist, der diesen Friedrich-Merz-Kurs zum einen kritisiert hat, mit dieser Brandmauer, die jetzt hier eingerissen wurde. Er aber dann hier zugleich doch den einen großen Hebel sehen möchte, der umgelegt wird, damit diese Probleme sich alle in Wohlgefallen auflösen. Das geht ja nicht zusammen.
Nee, geht auch nicht zusammen und die These bleibt, Friedrich-Merz ist schon AfD-Politik. Das ist schon jenseits der Brandmauer.
Ja. Also diese Diskussion über die Brandmauer und dass sie jetzt nicht mehr da ist, also wir reißen jetzt mal diskursiv die Brandmauer ab und sagen, die brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr, sondern wir bewerten jetzt einzelne politische Positionen. Sind es AfD-Positionen oder nicht? Egal, wer sie vorträgt. Genauso haben wir erkannt, mit der klassischen Identitätspolitik kommen wir nicht weiter, weil auch die Leute, die eine marginalisierte Identität haben, durchaus bereit sind, zum Beispiel rechts zu wählen. Und da müssen wir auch sagen, dann sind die wohl auch rechts. Dann sind die nicht eigentlich aber ganz toll und haben sich dann nur verirrt, sondern die sind dann wohl auch für eine rechte Position empfänglich und halten diese für richtig.
Ja und was in der Vergangenheit war, ist egal. Es ist niemand mehr aus der 19... was weiß ich, 95er-CDU geschweige denn am Leben.
Ja.
So, diese Parlamente sind ausgetauscht und diese Menschen sind dann auch irgendwann gestorben.
Ja, also man braucht jetzt auch nicht die ganze Zeit nochmal zu twittern, wie schön war das mit Heiner Geißler und Norbert Blüm. Ja, alles gut und schön, aber das ist jetzt nicht die CDU, die wir jetzt gerade haben.
Ja, genau.
Ja, so ist es. Das ist wie bei der Fußball-Nationalmannschaft. Da kann man auch nicht sagen, Mensch, das sind ja hier die Jungs, die...
Kann man mal an die Bremer einwechseln?
Ja, und Jürgen Klinsmann, die sind halt nicht da.
Genau, die sind einfach nicht da. So, wir gehen jetzt in den Salon. Wir lesen zu dumm für die Demokratie. Und ich hänge dann das Gemeinsinn-Buch an. Denn wenn man das gelesen hat, stellt man sich andere Fragen zur CDU. Nicht die, die Karin Mioska sich stellt als Fortschritt.
Also ich bin gespannt.
Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Bist du ein Hobbit, ein Hooligan oder ein Vulkanier?
Ich glaube, ich bin sehr häufig ein Hooligan.
Wow. Okay, was heißt das?
Ja, das heißt schon, dass ich manchmal eine Fundamentalkritik übe und sage dann lass doch alles einstürzen. Das führt mich aber jetzt dann nicht dazu, dass ich sage, ich sehe in der AfD eine Partei, die mir das ermöglicht, so wie ich das möchte. Aber ich sehe schon, dass ich mich eschofieren kann. Dass ich aber dann irgendwann so eine Rationalität walten lasse, die dann mein erhitztes Gemüt wieder auf eine wohltemperierte Form bringt und dann kann ich durchaus auch Vulkanier zum Beispiel sein.
Und sind wir hier im Metier der politikwissenschaftlichen Theorie Nutzung? Mir war das vorher nicht bekannt, aber es gibt wohl eine Unterscheidung zwischen Hobbits, Hooligans und Vulkaniern entlang der Eigenschaften keine Ahnung, keine Meinung, keine Ahnung, viel Meinung und viel Meinung, aber auch viel Ahnung.
Ja, ich bin ja am Ende dann immer der Vulkanier, der aber das Hooligan-Gemüt immer noch in sich tragen will. Weißt du, ich will mich schon noch richtig aufregen.
Ich auch. Ich bin auch häufig Hooligan.
Also ich finde das Problem bei dieser Dreiteilung ist, dass man so tut, als sei der Hooligan einfach der Durchgedrehte und manchmal finde ich es aber auch amüsant, durchgedreht zu sein. Der Hobbit ist so, der alles mit sich machen lässt und der Vulkanier ist aber auch dann so rational in dem Sinne schon, der ist schon fast mit Habermaß zusammen an einem Tisch und diskutiert. Und da finde ich eigentlich gut, ich würde sagen, wenn man die Grundlagen kennt, also wenn man mal so ein paar Dinge über den Staatshaushalt, Besteuerung, Erbschaften und so weiter verstanden hat, dann muss man doch gerade auf dieser Grundlage zum Hooligan werden. Verstehst du? Also man hat nicht dann...
Ich habe auch große Sympathie für die Hooligan.
Man kommt dann nicht zu diesem Temperament, dass man, ja, dann reden wir jetzt mal ganz in Ruhe darüber. Wenngleich wir natürlich jetzt gerade gehört haben von Wolfgang Schmidt, dass man die Gesetze hat, verschiedene Befugnisse, man einiges beachten muss. Also man ja jetzt auch nicht, wenn du sagst, wir wollen keine Milliardäre, sagen kann, hier ist der eine Hebel und damit schaffen wir es nicht ab, sondern man müsste sich dann, wenn man es jetzt umsetzen wollen würde, sich in Details hineinfuchsen, um das auch tatsächlich zu bewerkstelligen.
Also diese Theorie, die diese drei Dimensionen entfächert, wir kommen gleich auf sie zu sprechen, ist natürlich ein bisschen einseitig, weil sie so als individuell ist, was bist denn du, aber man kann ja auch soziale Fragen anschließen. Die Hobbits leben alle und verstehen sich gut, weil die haben sehr große Füße, aber die treten sich nicht gegenseitig auf die Füße. Die Vulkanier kommen auch gut miteinander klar, weil sie sich untereinander sehr berechenbar gegenüberstehen und dann einfach völlig logisch ist, dass man jetzt einen Rückzieher macht und so weiter und so fort. Der Stärkere gibt nach, das Problem mit den Hooligans ist, die prügeln sich die ganze Zeit. Ja, also die kommen nicht gut miteinander klar, diese viele Hooligans sind ein Problem.
Diese Begrifflichkeit, diese Dreiteilung, die wir da jetzt gemacht haben, die geht zurück auf Jason Brennan. Der hat ein Buch geschrieben, gegen Demokratie heißt es. Das habe ich mal mit Gregor, einem Twitch-Streamer besprochen. Das wird man auch noch bei YouTube finden. Kennst du das also schon. Und in diesem Buch geht es darum auch, ob wir zu dumm für die Demokratie sind. Allerdings geht da Brennan einen anderen Weg und ich dachte auch erst, dass Schieritz diesen Weg einschlagen wird, nämlich in der Hinsicht, dass Brennan sagt, wir brauchen eigentlich so ein Demokratie-Abitur. So nennt er es nicht, so nenne ich das jetzt mal. Wir brauchen etwas, dass uns ja als Grundlage an Wissen allen dann zur Verfügung steht, das wir erkennen und darauf aufsetzten, können wir dann überhaupt Wahlentscheidungen treffen. Das heißt, es kann nicht sein, sagt er, dass alle, egal ob sie sich für Wirtschaft interessieren, überhaupt für Geopolitik oder irgendetwas, ob sie wie die Hobbits einfach nur da leben in den Tag hinein, dass diese alle wählen gehen dürfen und jede Stimme gleich viel zählt. Das ist etwas, was er kritisiert. Er ist eigentlich, sagt er dann wieder, gegen eine Expertokratie, schlägt aber dann doch eigentlich so etwas Ähnliches vor. Also will Leuten das Wahlrecht entziehen oder ihnen es zumindest nicht ermöglichen zu wählen, wenn sie eine gewisse Kompetenz nicht haben. Man muss hier sagen, es geht jetzt hier nicht um so etwas wie Intelligenztest oder sowas. Also es ist jetzt nicht so eine fast eugenische Maßnahme, die da getroffen werden soll. Das ist ja immer das Problem, dass bei diesem deutschen Wort dumm mitschwingt. Vielleicht wäre blöde sowieso da das angemessenere Wort. Jedenfalls geht es ihm darum, dass man gewisse Grundlagen wissen muss, um dann auch wählen zu dürfen. Das ist ja nicht unbedingt die Ausrichtung von Mark Schieritz Buch. Er tippt das auch mal an. Wir kommen da bestimmt auch zu. Wir hatten auch bei Veit Selk gelesen. Es gibt ja sehr viele funktionale Analphabeten in Deutschland, also viele Menschen, die auf dem Niveau eines Viertklässlers und darunter sind. Und zwar sprechen wir da von 14 bis 16 Millionen Menschen. Deshalb gibt es ja auch die Tagesschau in einfacher Sprache. Das ist übrigens nicht vorwiegend für Leute, die nach Deutschland gekommen sind und nicht so gut Deutsch können. Die werden das auch nutzen können. Aber es geht wirklich um Muttersprachler. Es geht auch nicht um diese Fragen, was wissen Leute über Wirtschaft oder so was, sondern es geht mehr um diese Frage. Also wenn ich den Titel jetzt korrekt schreiben müsste für dieses Buch, dann müsste man eigentlich fragen, sind AfD-Wähler zu dumm für die Demokratie? Das würde ich erstmal beantworten mit Ja. Aber es ist eine sehr starke Einengung, die hier stattfindet von Schiritz. Ich bin nicht mit allen Passagen glücklich, aber ich glaube, wir können jetzt ganz gut darüber streiten.
Es ist ein Buch, ich will jetzt gleich vorweg sagen, wir hatten das schon mal von einem Zeitungsredakteur, in dem Falle Kevin Roos, bei dem wir im Nachgang sagten, hat er wahrscheinlich so nach Feierabend schnell hinweggeschrieben. Ist jetzt nicht sozusagen überbordend, aber ist ja auch nicht verkehrt, mal als Hobby noch so ein Thema aufzuwerfen, dass man vielleicht nicht nur als Doppelseite in der Zeit mit Kollegen behandelt, sondern dann mal sich von der Seele schreibt. Also in deren Sicht dieses Buch fliegt so ein bisschen drüber. Wir haben ja auch schon betont, dass es nur 160 Seiten hat, was ja gut ist und ein bisschen drüber fliegen ist auch nicht verkehrt. Also es ist sozusagen kein tiefschirfendes Werk.
Es bringt uns aber an so ein Dilemma ran und ich weiß auch noch gar nicht, wie ich das für mich beantworte und deswegen finde ich das gut, dass wir darüber reden. Also das Dilemma ist folgendes. Ich habe ja mal im letzten Jahr, nee doch im letzten Jahr war es im Juni ein Buch vorgestellt von Philip Manow. Dieses Buch wird hier auch nochmal zitiert. Philip Manow ist ein sehr wichtiger Politikwissenschaftler, der sagt, naja also die Demokratie stirbt gar nicht aus. Im Gegenteil, es wird wahnsinnig viel gewählt. Die Leute wählen auch gern, sie gehen zur Wahl. Nur was tatsächlich im Schwinden begriffen ist oder zumindest gewisse Rückzugsgefechte führt, ist die liberale Demokratie. Die liberale Demokratie, also mit Verfassungsgericht etc. Also mit all dem, was wir jetzt so in Deutschland unter Demokratie verstehen würden und was wir ja dann auch quasi exportiert haben. Also wir haben die Verfassung von den Alliierten bekommen und wir exportieren quasi dieses Modell weiter und sagen, ja so soll es doch eigentlich sein. Und wenn also Verfassungsgerichte beschnitten werden, überhaupt Gerichte eingeschränkt werden, wie wir das in Polen zeitweise gesehen haben, in Ungarn sehr massiv sehen, dann ist das gegen die liberale Demokratie. Es ist aber da immer noch Demokratie. Und jetzt sagt Mark Schieritz, es geht um die Rettung der liberalen Ordnung. Das ist schon im Untertitel ganz klar und führt zu folgendem Dilemma. Man könnte ja sagen, wenn die Mehrheit in Deutschland eine rechte Koalition aus AfD und CDU haben will, dann ist das einfach so, denn der Wähler hat Recht. Und dem würde Philipp Manow im Prinzip zustimmen. Das ist dann vielleicht keine liberale Demokratie irgendwann mehr, wenn wir mal sehen, was die vorhaben. Aber das ist ja erst mal so, während jetzt jemand wie Mark Schieritz und andere sagen, nein, genau das ist diese große Gefahr, denn eine Partei wie die AfD unterwandert die liberalen Grundsätze der Demokratie. Sie wird versuchen, bei Karlsruhe mitzumischen und wird versuchen, die Gerichte politisch zu infiltrieren. Also alles, was wir in den USA mit Trump sehr gut sehen können. Und deswegen muss also die Demokratie nicht nur von der AfD, sondern quasi auch vor ihren Wählern geschützt werden. Also man muss die Demokratie vor den Wählern schützen. Und das ist ein Dilemma, dass dieses Buch austariert. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich kann dir auch gar nicht so genau sagen, was jetzt meine konkrete Antwort ist. Ich kann nämlich immer sehr gut auf die AfD bezogen sein. Ja wunderbar, macht die Schotten dicht. Da soll jetzt ja nicht die Möglichkeit bestehen, dass die da Tabula rasa machen können. Wenn ich aber dann mir ansehe, was das auch bedeuten kann, also eine Einschränkung von Meinungsfreiheit, Einschränkung von Wählerwillen, Einschränkung von anderen radikalen politischen Positionen, dann habe ich da schon wieder meine Bedenken. Aber dazu kommen wir dann.
Genau. Das ist ja das große Paradox. Wir kennen ja das ja Böcken, Förde, Diktum oder wie auch immer aus vielen Richtungen. Und genau, der Einstieg ist natürlich erwartbar gewesen, die Deplorebills-Rede von Hillary Clinton.
Ja.
Das wird ja wohl jetzt auch noch die nächsten 50 Jahre diese Debatten prägen.
Ja, aber sag nochmal, vielleicht wissen das gar nicht alle.
Also September 2016, Hillary Clinton hält wo in New York eine Rede und hat natürlich schon im Blick, also September, es ist noch bis zur Wahl, zwei Monate sind es noch oder drei. September 2016, ja zwei Monate. Und typischerweise stellt man seine eigenen Stärken vor, sie möchte aber auch mal über die Schwächen des anderen reden und sagt, wisst ihr, um es grob zu verallgemeinern, man könnte die Hälfte der Anhänger von Trump in einen Korb der bedauernswerten, der Deplorebills, wie er übersetzt, stecken, hab ich nicht recht. Dieser Nachsatz mit hab ich nicht recht. Der wird uns später wieder begegnen, denn wir wollen ja die Frage dann auch mal beantwortet haben. Hat Hillary Clinton nicht eigentlich recht? Deine Vorrede liegt ja auch schon nahe in welche Richtung man diese Frage beantworten kann. Nur es ist eben unentscheidend, ob Hillary Clinton recht hat, sondern die Frage ist, was wird am Ende gewählt? Also wie wird gewählt? Und in den Demoskopen berichten dann eben der Demokratenkampagne, die ersten Erhebungen sind da, das Thema wurde ausgeschlachtet. Relativ viele Wähler wollen jetzt für Trump stimmen, nicht weil du Unrecht hast, sondern weil sie sich von dir missachtet fühlen. Wir sind also hier auf der Ebene der Moral, der auf abstrahierten Achtungsbedingungen, auf die sich eine Gesellschaft einigt. Und wenn jemand beschimpft wird, geht das nicht gut aus in diesem Metier. Wir haben also eine Zweigleisigkeit zwischen inhaltlicher Debatte, 36 Nobelpreisträger sagen, Kamala Harris hat die richtige Kampagne und am Ende sagen die Wähler, aber sie beachtet mich nicht. Ich will nicht Nobelpreisträgerpolitik haben, sondern Politik für mich.
Ich möchte nicht als der bedauernswerte oder der entbehrliche, so kann man es ja auch übersetzen. Also ich möchte nicht als jemand betitelt werden, der eigentlich so zum Pöbel gezählt wird von der Elite.
Genau. Wir haben also hier einen historischen Bogenschlag von Mark Schiritz, der beginnt September 2016. Hillary Clinton stellt Trumps Wähler als Deplorables dar und dann heute Trump wurde damals gewählt, hat diese Präsidentschaft mit mehreren Stabschefs absolviert. Diese sagen heute über ihn, es ist ein Faschist, er ist ein Sicherheitsrisiko, wir müssen das Land vor ihm beschützen und was passiert, die Deplorables wählen ihn ein zweites Mal. Also was man will als Wahlkämpfer ist etwas anderes als das, was man bekommt, wenn man auf Fakten- und Nachrichtenbasis etwas für das Land tun möchte, weil der Wähler seinen eigenen Sinn damit reinkriegt und es hat sich eben durch diese Medienwelt, wie wir sie haben, eine neue Grundregel etabliert, der Wähler hat immer recht, er ist der absolute Souverän, er ist in der Politik ins Zentrum gerückt, ihm darf nichts zugemütet werden, zugemütet werden, Zitat, sonst wird es böse, sonst wird das Wählervolk böse, das Volk wird böse und wählt Parteien, die die Demokratie ablehnen. Und dann sagt Mark Schiritz, das ist auch Zentrum, Fundament von Olaf Scholz Wahlkampf, denn er hat ja diese Respektsphilosophie mit Michael Sendel aufgearbeitet und verstrickt sich dann selber so in elitenkritischen Anmerkungen, die er da immer macht. Aber an dem Wähler kommt man nicht mehr vorbei. Der Wähler hat immer recht, weil seine Stimmen zählen. Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie weit muss man sich inhaltlich verbiegen, selber sich für das Land verbiegen, damit nicht die falschen, die bösen oder die böse gewordenen, die auf ein böse gewordenen auf den Wahlkampf, auf das politische System böse gewordenen Wähler als Volk, dann sagen, nö, dann lehnen wir halt die Demokratie ab, wenn sie uns nur Verachtung und so weiterbringt.
Und da frage ich mich schon gleich, ob dieser Begriff, die Wähler sind zu dumm für die Demokratie, eigentlich stimmt. Denn die Wähler wissen ja offenbar sehr wohl, dass Trump so einer ist, wie er beschrieben wird. Und sie wählen ihn deshalb. Also ich habe mich die ganze Zeit beim Lesen dieses Buches gefragt und das geht weit über das Buch hinaus, ist grundsätzlich eine Debatte, die zu führen ist. Sind die Wähler zu blöd und erkennen nicht, wie die AfD wirklich tickt? Oder sagen sie, na ja, gerade weil sie so tickt, wählen wir sie. Also es ist eine sehr bewusste Entscheidung, über die nachgedacht wurde. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, das sind aber doch eigentlich die falschen Gedanken oder so etwas. Aber es ist ja erst einmal interessant, dass es ja manchmal in diesem Buch so klingt, als wüssten die Wähler noch gar nicht, wohin das sie mal führen wird, wenn sie solche Parteien unterstützen. Und ich würde sagen, nö, vielleicht finden die das ja genau gerade gut, dass das so ist. Also vielleicht gibt es eine große Sehnsucht zum Beispiel, deswegen ja auch diese Beliebtheit von Friedrich Merz, nach Law and Order, nach einer Null-Toleranz-Politik gegenüber Kriminalität, Flüchtlingen etc. Es darf ruhig repressiver werden. Das finden wir eigentlich alles gut. So viel Polizei wie möglich auf der Straße, dann fühle ich mich erst wohl in diesem Lande. Also das ist ja eine Haltung, die Menschen haben können. Und deshalb wählen sie das. Es ist ja nicht so, dass sie sagen, ja eigentlich ist das ein ganz netter sozialer Politiker. Oh, jetzt habe ich den gewählt und bin ganz überrascht, dass der so einen halben Polizeistaat haben möchte. Von daher frage ich mich, ob das so stimmt, dass die Leute so blind hineingehen in ihr Verderben oder ob sie tatsächlich das was andere als Verderben ansehen würden, wir zum Beispiel, und Marc Schieritz auch, als das Erstrebenswerte anerkennen.
Das ist natürlich jetzt eine Frage, die sich das Buch auch nicht stellt, weil er ist ja klar entschieden. Also die Frage wird von ihm beantwortet. Er hat ja am Anfang, also es ist die Frage aufgeworfen, kann es sein, dass Hillary Clinton ein kleines bisschen Recht hatte? Das ist jetzt eine Frage, die ganz konträr zu deiner zentralen Fragestellung ist. Also die Kategorie des Rechthabens noch mal hinterfragen. Wir haben ja vorhin schon festgestellt, dass nicht nur ökonomisch, sondern auch in vielen anderen Metiers gegen das eigene Interesse gewählt wird. Jetzt kann man ja hinterfragen, aber was ist denn das eigene Interesse? Dass man mit 80 Jahren bereut, 30 Kilo Übergewicht zu haben, und deswegen 10 Jahre früher zu sterben. Heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass man sich deswegen 40 Jahre vorher zu Unrecht für Alkohol sich gehen lassen, Salz, Zucker und so weiter entschieden hat. Sondern es geht ja durchaus beides. Also die Reue später heißt ja nicht, dass man sofort revidieren würde, wenn man jetzt noch mal die Chance hätte. Wir wollen ja nicht alle wie Brian Johnson leben, nur weil wir am Leben hängen. So und das sind aber ungestellte und unbeantwortete Fragen in diesem Text. Was hier mitschwingt ist einfach die Gefahr eines Holocausts. Genau. Als politische Konsequenz, wenn keiner über nichts nachdenkt und jeder ist sich selbst der nächste, dann müssen wir uns halt fragen, ob wir um das Leben eines einzelnen zweijährigen unschuldigen Kindes zu schützen, sechs Millionen andere Menschen dafür töten, damit die nicht zur Gefahr werden. Wir werden es nachher bei Karl Schmidt lesen. Also diese Ideologie, es klingt immer so albern, wenn man es so ausformuliert, aber das ist die Praxis der Politik. Da darf man jetzt keine großen Abstriche machen, nur weil man so, weil es so komisch klingt, wenn man solche Fragen stellt. Aber das ist die offene Frage dieses Buches, weshalb es umso interessanter ist, finde ich, dass man da auch mal im lockeren Ton drüber geht als Autor.
Das finde ich auch und wir sollten auch bei diesem lockeren Ton bleiben. Ich will nur gerade für die Leute, die vielleicht irritiert sind, dass du jetzt gleich mit dem Holocaust ankommst, das nochmal bekräftigen, was du sagst. Denn vielleicht haben manche Leute den Film Jut Süß gesehen. Das ist ja der Propagandafilm von Veit Haaland, der nicht nur Propaganda für eine Nazi-Ideologie allgemein macht, sondern ganz klar für ein Prochrom an Juden. Es geht ja darum, dass es dort einen Juden gibt, der Karriere macht und so weiter, und der dann eine Frau vergewaltigt. Und das wird quasi als Anlass genommen, also so wird er, es geht da so eine antisemitische Stereotypenzeichnung ist, dass der Jude, der sich verkleidet und der Karriere macht und der über die Frauen herfällt, also so ist dieses Stereotyp. Und diese Dramaturgie sorgt dann dafür, dass das ganze Volk auf der Straße steht und sagt tötet ihn. Und dann wird er erhängt. Und das ist natürlich dann allegorisch zu verstehen, wir müssen also dieser Gefahr irgendwie herwerden. Und genau das ist es, dass also quasi eine Tat die Leute dazu anschriften soll, zu sagen dann jetzt alle weg. Und deswegen ist genau diese Parallele, die du da siehst, absolut gerechtfertigt. Was also jetzt hier in diesem Text nochmal steht, ist diese Frage, wo fängt es dann an zu kippen? Jetzt hast du interessanterweise ja eben so deutlich gemacht im Teaser, also vor dem Salon, dass Friedrich Merz AfD-Politik macht. Und ich hab das ja auch nochmal unterstützt.
Da kippt's.
So und wir haben aber jetzt Marc Schieritz, der sagen würde, gut, dass CDU und Grüne miteinander reden und durchaus auch mal ein Glas Wein bei Lasche trinken, dass die sich da als liberale Demokratie abgedichten gegen die AfD. Und da, finde ich, kommen wir genau in diese schwierige Lage. Mit der AfD sind diese Sachen alle relativ leicht für uns, die wir nicht AfD-Wähler sind, zu beantworten. Bei den anderen Sachen frage ich mich ja, was wird dann jetzt hier gerade stabilisiert? Also welche herrschende Ordnung wird als die liberale Ordnung identifiziert? Ist nicht eigentlich eine liberale Ordnung schon dadurch untergraben, dass man schon so viele Anti-Migrationsgesetze auf den Weg gebracht hat? Die Frage aber nochmal, da kommen wir vielleicht gleich nochmal drauf, aber diese Frage hat Hillary Clinton ein bisschen recht. Wir alle kennen das, dass wir irgendwelche Umfragen sehen, dass wir irgendwelche Passantengespräche im Fernsehen abgebildet sehen oder wir unmittelbar mit Leuten sprechen und denken, meine Güte, so ein Scheiß, dass die auch wählen dürfen. Das kennt glaube ich jeder, kennt dieses Gefühl. Und um das nochmal deutlich zu machen, es geht hier nicht um eine Frage von ist da jemand akademisch gebildet? Hat da jemand die richtigen Titel oder so parat? Hat er einen Doktortitel? Nur dann kann er wählen. Darum geht es hier nicht. Aber wir wissen, dass es sehr viele Leute gibt, die tatsächlich von Politik keine Ahnung haben und die aber auch menschlich, zwischenmenschlich, sagen wir, hohe Defizite aufweisen. Sodass sie bereit sind, einfach rassistische Stereotype zum Beispiel zu übernehmen. So. Und bei denen fragt man sich, sollten die eigentlich wählen dürfen? Und dann gibt es ja zwei Antworten, ja oder nein. Und dann gibt es aber noch die Antwort, wenn sie wählen sollten, müsste man sie trotzdem anders präparieren. Also das wäre dann das große Bildungsprogramm. Das kann man natürlich immer in den Raum stellen, aber was soll das jetzt bringen?
Ich will es mal entschlacken, weil jetzt habe ich selber den Holocaust reingeworfen und aber auch betont, das Buch ist locker geschrieben. Bleiben wir mal bei Hobbits und Vulkaniern. Es reicht, wenn die Wahlkämpfer Vulkanier sind. Die Wähler dürfen ruhig Hobbit sein, weil es gibt ja nicht nur Politik. Es gibt ja auch noch andere Felder, in denen sind dann die Wahlkämpfer Hobbits und die Wähler sind die Vulkanier. Also irgendwer muss ein Auto bauen, irgendwer muss sich mit Essen versorgen, irgendwer muss das Kino betreiben und so weiter und so fort. Dafür braucht man alle Vulkanier. Also jeder ist Vulkanier, aber es muss nicht jeder ein Politik-Vulkanier sein. So und man muss auch nicht das mega krass durchdenken im Sinne von ich bin ein Hobbit, jemand sagt bin ich zu dumm für die Demokratie, weil ich nur ein Hobbit bin. Nein, denn es ist ja nun mal einer repräsentativen Demokratie gegen dir. Das buch auch nicht hinterher, also das geht ja um unsere Demokratie, die ist nur mal repräsentativ. So, da treten also fünf Parteien an, CDU, SPD, Grüne, FDP, Linke. Denen wird unterstellt, die machen das dann schon, die einigen sich, die klären das im Gespräch, das sind Vulkanier, die begegnen sich auf dem Flur und sagen, beide ist ja logisch, wir sind hier nicht einer Meinung, aber das ist total logisch, dass wir diese Verfahrensordnung jetzt einhalten und so weiter und so fort. Nur ist eben eine Bedrohung noch daneben mit der AfD, die einfach sagt, nee, das erkennen wir alles gar nicht an. Also dieses Verfahren ist alles scheiße, wir wollen das alles abreißen. Komplizierter ist es nicht. Und wenn es komplizierter wird, ist das ein Problem. Also wenn die, und jetzt fehlt mir sozusagen der Gegenbegriff, wenn das Publikum zu dumm ist für die Politik, dann ist die Politik vielleicht, und es ist nicht zu klug, sondern dann ist die Politik vielleicht zu kompliziert. Also irgendwas stimmt dann einfach nicht. Klar hab ich jetzt als Wähler so eine Wächterfunktion, dass ich sage, naja klar sagen die mir, ich soll mal wieder wählen, weil am Ende muss ich's entscheiden. Nur, also das ist schon, kann auch eine Zumutung sein. Wir würden niemanden zumuten zu sagen, geh ins Autohaus, such dir ein Auto aus, aber bezahle nicht einfach nur den Preis, sondern leg dich selber noch mal auf das Rollbrett, guck unten noch mal, ob es ordentlich verkabelt ist, weil am Ende bist du schuld, wenn die Bremse dann nicht funktioniert. Das ist ja absurd. Das würden wir in keinem Feld machen. Geh noch mal ins Cockpit, um zu gucken, ob die Knöpfe alle funktionieren beim Piloten. Das ist doch absurd. Warum machen wir das in der Politik? Also wir haben es mit einem Spezialproblem in der Politik zu tun, das eine Zumutung ist für das Publikum. Und Publikum heißt hier, es ist nicht die Leistungsrolle. Leute sind ausgeschlossen aus diesen Parlamenten. Wir haben einen Partizipationstheater, das uns vorgaukelt. Wir sind ganz nah dran, wenn wir Ron Sheimers Podcast hören, weil der hat eben noch mit dem und dem telefoniert und jetzt sagt er mir schon Bescheid, was Sache ist. Das ist ja bescheuert. Also wir könnten auch das in die Richtung drehen zu sagen, die Vulkanier, die aber Hobbypolitiker bleiben, Zuschauer des Publikums, wir zum Beispiel, wenn wir uns anmaßen, da in diese Praxis professionelle Rolle reinzurutschen, also wenn Journalisten wirklich glauben, sie sind Teil des politischen Systems, dann sind das eigentlich die Blöden und nicht das Publikum. Das Publikum wird dann einfach nur verirrt, weil die Leute, die ihnen versprechen, Orientierungen zu schaffen, einfach dumm sind, bescheuert. Also dann könnte man auch sagen, die Journalisten sind eigentlich die Dummen, nur das ist sozusagen eine große Kritik von mir in dem Buch, das wird ausgeblendet. Also diese Vermittlung zwischen Politik und Publikum wird ausgeblendet, weil da könnten es auch Verfahrensbescheuertheiten sein, die dazu führen, dass das Publikum gar nicht anders kann als dumm sein.
Ja, allein schon deshalb, weil man ein Spiel mit Unbekannten hat, die ich ja eben erwähnt habe in Zuge einer Koalitions mit Friedrich Merz und einer anderen Partei, kann es zu einer Mehrwertsteuer-Erhöhung kommen. Darüber hat man nicht abgestimmt dann. Also es war jetzt nicht irgendwo zu lesen, dass das kommen wird, sondern das könnte dann einfach danach kommen. Zumal ich ja jetzt verschiedene Wahlprogramme konsultieren kann, dann würde ich die lesen, dann treffe ich eine Entscheidung für diese Partei. Weiß aber, dass dieses Programm nicht umgesetzt werden kann, weil es ja auf jeden Fall eine zweier, wenn nicht sogar dreier Koalition geben muss. Da sind so viele Unbekannte drin, dass ich ja nur in so einer Stellung bleiben kann, da ich sage, ja ich beobachte das mal von außen, aber kann da wenig machen. Und da ist jetzt der Unterschied, den Shiritz einführt, er sagt, dass wir unverletzliche und unveräußerliche Menschenrechte haben. Diese Rechte werden, um es mathematisch zu formulieren, vor die Klammer gezogen. Sie sind nicht Teil eines politischen Aushandlungsverfahrens. Und das ist genau der Unterschied zur AfD. Die AfD sagt nur, wir können über alles mal diskutieren. Die Frage wäre jetzt, aber vielleicht kann man das mal aus, das konnte er ja noch nicht ins Buch reinschreiben, hat jetzt doch Friedrich Merz diese unverletzlichen, unveräußerlichen Menschenrechte, hat er die einfach in die Klammer reingesteckt und gesagt, naja, da können wir auch mal gucken. Genau. Das ist jetzt die Frage und ich würde sie mit Ja beantworten. Und dann steht man aber schon vor einem großen Dilemma, wenn man sagt, ja, wenn man jetzt sagt, die liberale Demokratie muss geschützt werden, mit wem schützt man sie denn?
Also bevor er in dieser Gegenwart ankommt, die du jetzt beschreibst, weil das ja eine sehr gegenwärtige Frage ist, wer zieht ja was vor die Klammer und verletzt damit sozusagen historische Errungenschaften, zivilisatorische Errungenschaften, die wir hatten, kommt da drauf zu sprechen, dass die Losung Mehrheit ist Wahrheit damals in Athen ausprobiert wurde vor 2000 Jahren oder mehr, würde ich sagen, mit der Fragestellung, wenn wir uns einfach alle hier versammeln und dann kommen da 6.000 Athener und machen einfach sozusagen spontanen Abstimmungen, spontanen Voting zu irgendwelchen Fragen. So, das ist der eine Strang der Geschichte, Mehrheit ist Wahrheit. Und der zweite Strang der Geschichte ist Einhegung dieser Mehrheit. Also über Gesetze, über Sitten, über Traditionen, über politisches Personal, das eine Ochsentour durchgeht, um sozusagen zu gewährleisten, dass da schon mal im kleineren Rahmen Vorwahlen, delegierten Wahlen und so weiter schon mal Personal ausgewählt wurde, das eben nicht jenseits der Klammer operiert.
Sonst hätte es nie Euro gegeben, nie die Wiedervereinigung.
Er geht das historisch durch. Welche großen Entscheidungen? Westbindung Deutschlands nach dem Krieg, Währungsunion und EU auch selbst, das hätte es so nie gegeben. Also das hätte mit Mehrheit ist Wahrheit, wäre das nicht gelungen. Sondern hier musste man dem Publikum sozusagen Beschlussvorlagen hinlegen, die sich in allem gleichen, was das angeht, nämlich dass man das überhaupt mal macht, sowas wie eine Währungsunion.
Diese Einhegung der Demokratie bedeutet dann aber auch wirklich eine Einschränkung der Freiheit. Also das, was dann als liberal verkauft wird, naja, was als liberal verkauft wird, ist dann quasi, dass ich schon einer Geschäftsordnung zustimme, die ich aber gar nicht mit aufgesetzt habe.
Ja.
Also ich muss mich ja damit sehr einverstanden erklären, dass sage ja, also man könnte es auch noch eins weiter drehen. Jeder Wahlgang, in dem ich ein Kreuz mache, egal bei welcher Partei, mal von der der einen, die alles aushebeln will, abgesehen, aber die war ja vorher noch, stand ja noch nicht zur Debatte vor, 15 Jahren, 20 Jahren, ist ja eigentlich dann nur, und ich glaube, das wird jetzt unsere Leute vom Gegenstandpunkt, die hier zuhören, freuen, ist dann eigentlich nur eine Zustimmung der herrschenden Geschäftsordnung, ja, welche Partei ich dann gerade wähle, denn es bleibt dabei, es ist eine kapitalistische Ordnung, wir haben die Bindung an die NATO, wir haben die Währung, etc. Das heißt also, die Demokratie ist also nicht ein Abstimmen über grundsätzliche Freiheiten, sondern man ist eigentlich angehalten nur innerhalb eines kleinen Rahms. Man soll es vielleicht eher so beschreiben, so begreifen, man geht in ein Restaurant und bekommt da eine Karte vorgesetzt und wählt von diesen Gerichten, die da sind. Man kann aber nicht sagen, hier gibt es ja nur Schnitzel und Pizza, ich hätte jetzt gerne Frühdünksrollen.
Aber das ist ja genau das Dilemma, auch wieder, was wir nicht nur in der Politik haben, sondern auch zum Beispiel in der Wirtschaft. Für Märkte an sich und Geld braucht man den Staat. Das kann die Wirtschaft nicht alleine machen. Sonst wäre sie einfach eine Tauschwirtschaft, in der sich der Stärkere durchsetzt und so weiter. Also dann kann man, man muss, wie Luhmann ja immer sagte, die Komplexität reduzieren, um sie aufbauen zu können. Und das kann man aber über Entscheidungen zielgerichtet machen. Aber nur weil man sich für viel Komplexität entscheidet, heißt das noch nicht, dass man auf der anderen Seite der Unterscheidung da diese Konsequenzen mitzieht. Also wenn man sich heute für einen möglichst freien Wählerwillen entscheidet, muss man halt damit rechnen, dass dann relativ viel Komplexität einfach per se wegfällt. Weil wenn man vorher nicht reduziert, kann man danach nicht aufbauen. Dann hat man nur die Gemengelage, die man halt hat.
Jetzt werden alle sagen, ja, aber es ist doch wirklich positiv, der Euro wurde eingeführt, die Wiedervereinigung kam. Und er nennt ja noch ein paar andere positive Entwicklungen. Ich könnte jetzt aber doch diese Geschichte auch ähnlich weiter erzählen und sage, gut, dass die Wähler nicht überall mitbestimmen konnten, denn sonst hätten wir eine hohe Erbschaftssteuer bekommen, wir hätten eine Vermögenssteuer, wir hätten eine vom Parlament abhängige EZB. So und dann würden jetzt alle zu uns sagen, ja genau, das wollten wir aber doch immer. Das heißt also diese Abdichtung der liberalen Demokratie, die hier vorgeschlagen wird und die angesichts einer erstarkenden AfD natürlich auch uns plausibel erscheint, bedeutet zugleich auch eine Anerkennung des Status quo, mit dem wir, gerade wir zwei hier im Podcast, so häufig nicht einverstanden sind. Das heißt meine Frage ist, inwieweit wir uns durch eine solche Position selbst in einen Zentrismus bewegen, wo wir dann sagen, ja Einhegung des Volkswillens, da war doch was. Ja richtig, das ist ja eigentlich auch das Prinzip eines Neoliberalismus, dass man sagt, damit ja nicht mehr die Bevölkerung plötzlich Konzerne anders besteuern kann oder an die Vermögen von Milliardären ran kann, schaffen wir da Ordnungen.
Ja und das ist ja das interessante an diesem Gespräch gewesen mit Wolfgang Schmidt gegen Ronsheimer. Ronsheimer möchte diese Klammer, diesen Komplexitätskorridor einreißen, während Wolfgang Schmidt ihn verschieben möchte und wir eben auch. Also es pendelt zwischen Holocaust und Vermögen und Erbschaftssteuer, die alle gleich macht, irgendwie so, ja. So ein utopisches, das wär jetzt noch nicht mein Bild, aber sagen wir mal so auf die Spitze getrieben. Also entweder hauen und stechen, wir töten uns alle gegenseitig und organisieren das industriell oder es sind einfach alle gleich, Herkunft ist egal, Tätigkeit ist egal, es haben alle dasselbe, der Bus fährt für alle und so. So, wenn man in diese Richtung, in die wir wollen geht, weiß man, man kann diesen Komplexitätskorridor nicht einreißen. Das Einreißen führt nur in die andere Richtung, weshalb die Argumentation relativ kompliziert ist und es Ronsheimer halt sehr leicht fällt. Also Richtung Holocaust alles einzureißen ist ganz einfach. Gehen wir einfach auf die Straße, erschießen uns und niemand ruft die Polizei, erledigt. Also dann ist das, ja die Dystopie ist sozusagen nur ein Telefonanruf, der nicht stattfindet entfernen. Während eine Polizei zu gründen, Regeln für sie festzulegen, Regeln so festzulegen, dass egal ist, wer die Polizeirolle konkret ausfüllt, das ist halt kompliziert. Darüber werden wir wahrscheinlich eh noch in den nächsten Monate, wenn wir dann das deutsche Wahlergebnis haben, diese Attraktivität von Hoss und Hopf. Und es ist sehr häufig so genannt worden mit, ja die einfachen Antworten sind immer so leicht und so. Ja in dem Falle ist es wirklich eine Attraktivität, einfacher, gefühlsmäßig, validierter, nicht weiter zu evaluieren da. Jeder versteht, wegen einem Kind muss man doch die Grenze zu machen, ist doch völlig klar. Das ist für sehr viele Leute sehr klar, weil dann ist die Grenze zu und der eine Mörder ist nicht da. Fertig. Folgeprobleme, andere Probleme, Komplexität darüber hinaus. Das kann man halt dann einfach ausblenden. Solange es Theorie bleibt, sobald man das als Politik umsetzt, ist man sofort beim Holocaust. Also das ist einfach dieser Weg ist wirklich wahnsinnig kurz. Das werden wir jetzt auch wieder feststellen in Amerika. Die großen Lager werden ja schon gebaut. Die ersten Flüchtlinge wurden jetzt nach Guantanamo geschickt, weil da hat man ja ein Lager und so.
Unfassbar, ja.
Also das geht ja relativ einfach. Nur wir wollen es ja in diese komplizierte Ecke verschieben.
Genau, machen wir uns mal es nicht leicht. Schiritz schreibt, in diesem Buch wird die These vertreten, dass unter dem Vorwand ihrer Demokratisierung eine Entkernung der liberalen Demokratie betrieben wird. Sie soll abgelöst werden durch eine Vulgärdemokratie, die die normativen Voraussetzungen einer funktionierenden demokratischen Willensbildung ignoriert und den Aufstieg extremistischer Parteien als Ausdruck eines von seinen institutionellen Beschränkungen befreiten ursprünglichen Volkswillens feiert. Das ist ja etwas, was wir alle kennen. Wenn AfD-Politiker auftreten, dann sagen sie, wir verkörpern die wahre Demokratie. Wenn man sich ansieht, wie im Parlament das gehandhabt wurde mit uns, das sind die eigentlichen Demokratie-Feinde. Wir bringen euch die absolute Demokratie hierher oder die reine Demokratie, die pure Demokratie. Und hiergegen wendet sich Schiritz und sagt, dass das aber häufig von den Wählern nicht verstanden wird, was eigentlich mit dieser Demokratisierung, die da gefordert wird von Rechten, gemeint ist. Er sagt beispielsweise auch, erkennen die Wähler nicht, dass Biden das größte Wirtschaftsprogramm seit Jahrzehnten in den USA aufgelegt hat und trotzdem sind die Wähler dann gegen ihn. Mit der AfD wird natürlich immer alles sehr schnell erkennbar, finde ich. Allerdings wird es dann schwierig, wenn man auf andere Parteien schaut. Also die Frage ist ja, wenn ich jetzt sage, wir brauchen eine Demokratisierung der Demokratie, wann ist es denn die Vulgärdemokratie?
Also Vulgärdemokratie finde ich einen super Grundbegriff, weil er die Demokratie einfach von allen Formalitäten befreit und sagt, unterm Strich zähl, also in der Wirtschaft unterm Strich zähl ich und in der Politik unterm Strich zählt 50 plus. Da stellt man einfach eine Frage und stimmt ab. Er nennt es ja auch eine Entkernung, also nicht nur der Kern selber geht dann verloren. Und da fragen wir uns natürlich, okay, wenn der einfachste Weg, diese Vulgärdemokratie, nicht reicht, was unterscheidet die Vulgärdemokratie von unserer liberalen Demokratie, die er so betont? Und hier kommt er genau auf die Diskussionsstränge, die wir ja schon kennen, Böckenförder und so weiter. Also die ganzen publizistischen Begleitungen, auch die grundsätzlich so stattfanden, sagen wir mal in der Nachkriegszeit bis jetzt. Du hast angesprochen, Biden hatte eine sehr erfolgreiche Politik, wurde trotzdem nicht anerkannt. Es wurde ihm sozusagen nicht als, das ist für uns gut, sondern du hast ja nur für dich und keine Ahnung für irgendwelche Milliardäre, sind nur die Aktienkurse hochgegangen. Aber mein eigener Börsenwert an der Supermarktkasse ist davon ja nicht betroffen. Also ich wurde irgendwie übersehen und so weiter.
Was ja auch stimmt für viele.
Genau, was ja total stimmt. Wir haben also dafür keine Maßstäbe, um das einzuschätzen. Deshalb er jetzt sagt, ja dafür gibt es halt auch keine Maßstäbe so, sondern er sagt einfach, ja, wir haben Institutionen. Also wir könnten uns jetzt abarbeiten an den Institutionen, die uns von Vulgärdemokratie unterscheidet. Nur, das ist nur die halbe Wahrheit. Und dann macht er diesen super interessanten Vergleich, der auch ein bisschen mutiger ist, würde ich sagen. Er sagt nämlich, Trump eins und Hitlers NSDAP. Da gibt es eine Parallele. Also im Wortlauf, die NSDAP war damals verboten worden. Man hatte das Parteivermögen konfisziert. Adolf Hitler musste ins Gefängnis. Das Verbot wurde aber 1925 aufgehoben. Unter anderem, weil konservative Kräfte in Hitler einen Verbündeten im Kampf gegen die Kommunisten sahen. Es fehlte der politische Wille für eine Verlängerung des Verbots. Genau wie in den Vereinigten Staaten, der politische Wille dafür fehlte, Trump für die Verfehlung während seiner ersten Amtszeit rechtlich zu belangen. Und dann der entscheidende Satz, nicht Institutionen handeln, sie zu haben ist schön und gut. Menschen. Es sind die Menschen, die handeln. So bei Kritik an unserem demokratischen Ablauf, den wir haben, reicht es nicht juristisch die Formalia entlangzugehen und zu überlegen, was es jetzt ein gutes und ein schlechtes Gesetz, wie auch immer. Sondern wir müssen Tagesthemen gucken, wo Politiker Politik machen und dann sagen, wie wir das finden. Deshalb unsere nicht nur wählen alle Friedrich Merz oder Olaf Scholz bzw. die Listen, die sie anführen, sondern genauso sitzen wir auch da und sagen, wir werden hier von Friedrich Merz für blöd verkauft. Es ist Friedrich Merz. Es ist nicht die Bundestagswahl, es ist nicht die Gefahr ist Friedrich Merz. Und nicht die Brandmauer oder so.
Schiritz würde aber sagen, Friedrich Merz ist nicht die Gefahr.
Ja, inhaltlich genau.
Er ist nicht jemand, der die Institutionen abbauen will.
Aber er hat dieses Buch auch nicht wissend, was letzte Woche im Bundestag passierte. Also was inhaltlich, was Merz für Gesetze vorlegt. Und sagt, das sind Gesetze der Mitte und die AfD sagt, das ist auch unser Gesetz. Also das ist sozusagen, wer weiß wie Schiritz heute das einweben würde.
Die sind zugestanden. Doch wie ist es mit Positionen, die auch an den Institutionen rütteln, gegen die könnte man sich ja mit Schiritz Buch im Anschlag auch stellen. Also beispielsweise gibt es ja diesen Fall, die Süddeutsche Zeitung hatte darüber berichtet, von einer 28-jährigen Referendarin, die jetzt keine Stelle bekommen soll als Lehrerin. Pöttinger heißt die. Und man hat dann versucht herauszufinden, was ist denn da los? Sie hat demonstriert bei dieser Geschichte gegen die IAA in München. Und diese Messe ist dann jetzt vom Kultusministerium in Bayern zu hören, war ein Problematisch und die Auftritt besonders als Sprecherin. Denn sie habe dort gesagt, diese Messe, die IAA, die Automesse sei ein Symbol für Profitmaximierung auf Kosten von Mensch, Umwelt und Klima. Fast alle würden, die uns hier zu hören, zustimmen. Das Ministerium fährt fort. Profitmaximierung ist eine der Begrifflichkeiten der kommunistischen Ideologie zuzuordnenden Weltordnung.
What?
Die kommunistische Ideologie ist mit der freiheitlich-demokratischen Grundordnung, man könnte auch sagen mit der liberalen Demokratie, nicht vereinbar. Das ist meine Gefahr, das ist nicht, was ich jetzt schieres in die Schuhe schieben will, sondern wo ich immer sage, wenn Leute mit der liberalen Demokratie argumentieren und sagen, wir müssen die jetzt wetterfest machen oder wie man sich dann ausdrückt, dann kann das natürlich zum einen bedeuten, wir denken mal ernsthaft über ein AfD-Verbotsverfahren und all das nach oder gucken wir, dass die AfD nicht auf Karlsruhe plötzlich ungeahnten Zugriff hat, kann aber auch bedeuten, naja, also so Fridays for Future, wenn die sich über Profitmaximierung und Kapitalismus äußern, das untergräbt doch unsere liberale Ordnung, müssen wir da nicht auch mal vorgehen.
Aber haben wir hier schon juristische, also rechtrichterliche...
Das geht jetzt gerade rund. Also sie hat ja schon eine Pressekonferenz dazu gegeben und es gibt ja einen weiteren Fall auch, da wurde ein Universitätsvertrag für jemanden nicht verlängert, weil ihm Ähnliches danach gesagt wurde, auch wieder ein Fall aus Bayern. Und da sieht man quasi aus der Mitte heraus eine autoritäre Wende, bei der man sich jetzt fragt, ja geht die nicht wunderbar auch einher damit, dass man sagt, ja aber die liberale Ordnung, wie auch eine Einschränkung der Meinungsfreiheit relativ gut möglich ist oder eine Einschränkung von gewissen Plattformen, immer mit der Begründung, naja wir müssen ja aufpassen, dass unsere demokratie nicht aus dem Ruder läuft. Und das bedeutet aber auch, dass wir eine Aussage, wie es darf keine Milliardäre geben, nicht dulden, Herr Schulz.
Sind wir auch schon außerhalb?
Genau, diese Frage stelle ich mir dann jetzt. Man kann natürlich sagen, naja das sind jetzt Einzelfälle oder man kann sagen, ja das ist doch jetzt nicht unser Hauptproblem. Alles richtig. Ich sehe nur immer, dass man gerade, wo man sich so sehr auf diese liberale Demokratie stützt als Argumentation, sehr gut dann auch sagen kann, naja aber das dann bitte auch nicht und das bitte auch nicht. Und ob man dann irgendwann in so einem Zentrismus gefangen ist, der dann doch ein sehr, sehr enges Korsett wieder meint.
Ja, also die Gefahr, das ist ja sozusagen zentral, nicht nur in diesem Buch. So ist das halt. Weshalb wir ja die Lösung für diese Probleme auch nicht im politischen System selber finden, denn bei der Frage brauchen wir einen Demokratieführerschein, ja wer stellt den denn aus, die Politiker selbst, also befinden die dann nicht nur über ihr Gehalt, sondern auch noch über die Wählerschaft, wäre absurd.
Und müssten wir denen nicht eigentlich auch erst mal einen Führerschein ausstellen, das wäre die Frage.
Also wir stellen ja sehr viele Führerscheine aus. Ja. Typischerweise nennen wir das dann Berufsausbildung oder wie auch immer. Und während der Berufsausbildung und allem, was dazu hinführt, haben wir eben auch eine politische Bildung. Also es gibt ja Politikunterricht in der Schule. Und zwar mit der Schule ist hier ein Ort gemeint, der sehr weit weg von der Politik organisiert ist, gerade in Deutschland. Es ist eben Ländersache und so weiter, damit es nicht zu so einer Vereinheitlichung kommt oder zu einem zentralen Zugriff oder was auch immer. Also wir haben ja durchaus Antworten, die allerdings hier im Buch auch keine Rolle spielen. Also bei der Frage zu dumm für die Demokratie bleibt Marc Schieritz ganz schön eng an der Politik kleben. Da hat einfach wir zu dumm für die Demokratie, also trotzt sich gar kein Wir, Sie, die Wähler, wer auch immer. Also irgendwer ist doch zu dumm für die Demokratie. Und damit ist ja die Publikumsrolle gemeint. Also gerade die Nicht-Politiker. Was ist denn mit der Sphäre, in der die leben? Werden die da etwa verdummt? Und dann könnte man über das Bildungssystem, über Mark Zuckerberg und so weiter und so fort, müsste man eigentlich alles mit reinholen in dieses Bild.
Sollte man, frage ich dich jetzt, wählen dürfen, wenn man der Ansicht ist, die schwäbische Hausfrau ist die beste Art Wirtschaftspolitik zu betreiben.
Ja, das sollte man unbedingt. Das ist eben der Punkt. Also ich sehe da auch, also meine Korridor-Definition ist auch sehr weit.
Du sagst also ja, das geht noch.
Ja, also wenn jemand wählt im Sinne von, ich möchte gern, dass Angela Merkel und zwar nicht als Angela Merkel, ich kenne sie, sondern als schwäbische Hausfrau regiert, dann findet schon ein Versagen statt, dem ich auch das Label Dummheit unterjubeln möchte. Nur, das muss man dann halt auch lösen, wenn man das als Problem definiert. Und nicht einfach sagen, das ist ja super interessant, ich hab es ja häufiger jetzt schon genannt, Elmar Falani hat dieses Sammelband über die Minderheiten ohne Schutz. So, die Minderheit ohne Schutz, also eine Kindheit ohne Schutzraum. Und dann hat er dieses Bild, die 2007er wählen dann zum allerersten Mal eine Europawahl. Und das ist der Moment, wo die Gesellschaft feststellt, krass, was ist denn das für eine Generation? So, und jetzt fühlt sich plötzlich die Gesellschaft ohne Schutz vor so AfD wählenden ahnungslosen Holocaust. Was soll das sein? Ist da eine Gefahr? Keine Ahnung, ich höre Haus und Hopf. So, ja, also die Frage ist, wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, da sind irgendwelche Leute zu dumm für die Demokratie, ja dann haben wir das Problem wieder so ganz hinten dann aufgegriffen. Ja, also wir stellen uns dann irgendwie, wir stellen dann irgendwie fest, okay, da ist ein 26-Jähriger bei den Olympischen Spielen angetreten und ist offenbar nicht Olympiasieger geworden. Wo liegt denn das Problem? Und dann stellt man sozusagen zu spät fest, ach so, der hat ja noch nie ein Lauftraining. Also nicht, eigentlich wollte man ja denken, okay, was war denn bei dem letzten Training? Hast du dich nicht ordentlich ernährt? Und er sagt dann, laufen? Ich weiß gar nicht, muss ich jetzt hier schnell laufen oder was? Also da sind wir jetzt sozusagen angekommen bei der Ausblendung der Ursachen für diese Probleme, die wir hier befassen.
Das heißt also, es geht nicht um einen Demokratieführerschein, denn beim Führerschein, den man macht, du hast ja keinen.
Deswegen darf ich auch nicht fahren.
Ich hab ja einen gemacht. Genau. Da kannst du jetzt nicht sagen, ich bin aber der Ansicht, man macht das so und so rechts vor links, schöne Idee, ich machs andersrum. Das geht nicht, dann ist man durchgefallen. Hier sagst du aber, haben wir im politischen Feld eine viel größere Toleranz. Wenn jemand sagt, Wirtschaftspolitik ist die schwäbische Hausfrau und außerdem sollten auch die anderen europäischen Mitgliedsstaaten keine weiteren Schulden machen dürfen, dann sagt man, ist für uns zwar blöd, wir können auch dagegen argumentieren, aber einen Wahlrechtsentzug rechtfertigt das nicht. Wahlrechtsentzug bzw. eine Einschränkung, Einhegung ist also davon nötig, wo man sagt, das geht jetzt ganz grundsätzlich gegen Institutionen. Also wenn jetzt jemand sagt, wir sollten das Bundesverfassungsgericht abschaffen, damit wir ein bisschen mehr Spielraum haben, da würdest du sagen, nee, das ist jetzt nicht mehr das.
Jetzt stell ich dir eine Rückfrage.
Ja?
Ist natürlich etwas, aber das Publikum wird das verzeihen, wenn ich das jetzt einfach so ruckepacken nehme. Wenn wir jetzt sagen, zu dumm für die Demokratie ist eine interessante Frage, nur dann ist man wahrscheinlich für vieles zu dumm und irgendwer hat auch das Problem verursacht, dass jemand zu dumm ist, aber deswegen nicht wählen geht nicht. Wenn wir jetzt sagen, und darauf können wir uns alle einigen, ein 5-Jähriger ist zu dumm für die Demokratie. Darf er dann deswegen nicht wählen?
Ja, das ist diese Frage.
Genau.
Wir haben sie nicht.
Ich beantwortet dir ja eindeutig und sage alle Wahl. Also geboren, Wahlrecht. Du hast natürlich auch eine Staatsangehörigkeit abgeburrt. Also da gibt es auch keinen Führerschein für. So Wahlrecht, abgeburrt. Wenn das dann ein Problem ist, dass jene noch gar nicht reden kann, noch gar keine Farben erkennt, noch nicht mal die Kanzlerin von dem eigenen Vater unterscheiden kann, weil das alles erst gelernt werden muss, ist das noch lange kein Grund, jemanden nicht wählen zu lassen. Das ist mein Argument dazu. Denn wir haben Problemlösungen dafür.
Nein, wir haben auch tatsächlich ja nicht die Wahlentscheidungen an die Kompetenz geknüpft.
Genau.
Sonst müsste man das ja machen. Also sonst müsste man ja auch sagen, ist dieser Mensch von 84 Jahren vollkommen zurechtungsfähig? Machen wir nicht, sondern sagen wir wird schon stimmen.
Wir nehmen den Führerschein nicht weg.
Hat dieser 18-jährige seit drei Jahren nur Haus und Hopf gehört, kann sein, geht aber auch wählen.
Also wir haben hier durchaus Defizite und Ursachen für Probleme, die man lösen kann, aber das sind keine politischen Probleme, sondern die sind woanders gelagert. Aber dieses Buch hat einen sehr engen Fokus auf die Politik und arbeitet sich entsprechend da ab, was bedeutet Demokratie. Es gibt durchaus, sagen wir mal, Studienwissen zur Frage, was ist eine Demokratie? Und er sagt, es gibt verschiedene Angebote, also eine Wahl fand formal korrekt statt, sagt Wolfgang Merkel, reicht für Demokratie. Die Existenz von Partizipationsrechten wären schon ganz nett, sagen andere, mindestens an sozioökonomischer Teilhabe, ist auch nicht ohne, sagen andere. The Economist hat einen Demokratieindex, den nach gibt es weltweit 24 vollständige Demokratien, wir gehören zum Beispiel dazu, Norwegen führt die Liste an, Amerika gehört nicht dazu. 45,4 Prozent der Menschheit leben in Staaten mit demokratischen Grundprinzipien, aber nur 7,8 Prozent, wir Europäer und so, leben in, wie sie sagen, vollständigen Demokratien.
Also wir sind hier in der absoluten Minderheit.
Ja, es ist eine große Minderheit, diese Diskussion über den Korridor, wie wir sie führen, ist eine Luxus-Diskussion. Für viele andere, die meisten Länder stellt sich die Frage gar nicht. Und dann steigt da ein, kann man ja kurz halten, Rousseau, der nochmal den gemeinsamen Volkswillen als idealtypische Volonté-General unterschieden hat von einem individuellen Willen und von einem aufsummierten Gesamtwillen. Also schon in den ersten Überlegungen zur modernen Demokratie gibt es einen Unterschied zwischen Gesamtwille, also Mehrheit und Wahrheit, politischer Volkswille sozusagen, Wählerwille. Das ist kompliziert und außerdem haben wir auch schon die Frage beantwortet, wer gehört zum Volk? Ich finde ja noch nicht vollständig. Wir haben die Frauen reingenommen, kommunalrechtlich dürfen sogar EU-Ausländer mitwählen, Kinder aber immer noch nicht. Als 17-Jähriger schreibst du ein Abitur in Mathematik, würde niemand bestehen, ad hoc. Niemand, außer irgendein Mathe-Professor, der das im Alltag macht, würde ein Mathe-Abitur bestehen. Den Kindern verlangen wir das ab und dann sagen wir, hier ist dein Abitur, aber fürs Wählen bist du unmündig.
Aber du könntest schon mal sich bei der Bundeswehr melden.
Genau, du kannst das Land sterben, kannst schon Auto fahren, kannst alles machen, aber nicht wählen. Ich reite immer wieder auf mein Lieblingsthema.
Und diese Volontär-General ist ja noch mal interessant, weil das ja auch ein Punkt ist für Karl Schmidt. Der interpretiert ja so Grosso als identitäre Demokratie-Theorie, indem er sagt, Volontär-General kann auch von einem einzigen Menschen vertreten werden. Und das ist also diese Unterscheidung, die wir jetzt hier machen, also den Gesamtwillen, also man wählt, man guckt, wo sind die Mehrheiten und zählt alle Stimmen zusammen. Und dann gibt es aber diesen gemeinsamen Volkswillen, der kann allerdings auch von kleineren Gruppen vertreten werden. Das klingt jetzt bei Karl Schmidt dann gleich auf Hitler bezogen ganz schlimm. Aber man kann zum Beispiel auch sagen, dass Leute im Widerstand in Frankreich, als die Nazis Frankreich besetzt haben, gab es ja eine Regierung, die mit den Nazis paktiert hat in Frankreich. Und zugleich gab es einen großen Widerstand von linken und auch konservativen Kräften, die für sich annektiert haben, wir sind das Volk. Also hier ist der eigentliche gemeinsame Volksbilde. Mag sein, dass in Umfragen sogar dieses Paktieren gotiert würde. Aber wir sind das wahre Frankreich, wenn man so möchte. Und da sieht man also auch wieder, wer kann das also für sich annektieren. Es ist jedenfalls dann nicht nur an die Anzahl der Zustimmenden geknüpft.
Das ist das eine Problem nach innen, nach außen haben wir heute das Problem, er kommt ja aufs Asylrecht zu sprechen. Das ist natürlich, wer konnte es ahnen, das ist in dieser Woche vor dem Wahlkampf so interessant, also so wichtig ist darüber zu reden. Aber selbst wenn man die Frage geklärt hat, wer darf denn hier und wie viel reichen für Zustimmung und so weiter, hast du am Ende das Problem, dass die deutschen Grenzen und die Frage wer wird hier entschieden, erzählt es auf. Das Grundgesetz kommt nur recht selten zur Geltung. Es ist die Genfer Flüchtlingskonvention, die Europäische Menschenrechtskonvention und die Grundrechtecharta der EU plus natürlich UN-Rahm-Gesetzgebung, sag ich mal und so weiter und so fort. Also gibt es überhaupt eine Handhabe, selbst wenn man Mehrheit ist, Wahrheit irgendwann mal entschieden hat, weil hier bestimmt ja Mehrheiten, die vor Jahrzehnten mal entschieden haben, dass es jetzt was gilt. War jetzt die Woche wieder interessant, dass Merz meinte, wenn wir einen Notstand ausrufen, kann deutsches Recht, europäisches Recht wieder übertrumpfen, weil ansonsten geht das ja gar nicht. Also man hat gar keine Handhabe. Nur dieser Notstand muss eben angemeldet werden. Und selbst über die Bewilligung der Notstandsituation entscheidet am Ende wieder die EU. Also wie man es dreht und wendet, Friedrich Merz kann gar nicht. Selbst wenn er wollte. Also er müsste wirklich aus krassen juristischen formalen, sagen wir mal, Klammer Komplexitätskorridoren erst mal aussteigen, um zu machen, was er hier verspricht. Das ist in die eine Richtung. Und dann kommt auf Olaf Scholz zu sprechen. Diese Respektphilosophie, ich will es noch kurz nennen, weil wir ja immer wieder, weil er hier so ein lustiges Zitat hat, also wir kennen ja diese Argumentation von Michael Sendel. Am Ende greift auch in Deutschland dieser Provinzbooster, wie man den in Amerika kennt. Also was das Volk sagt, stimmt und vor allem, wenn es aus den Länder rein kommt, abseits der urbanen Zentren, die ja nur alle links-grünen Vogue verseucht sind. Und dann hat Olaf Scholz hier irgendwann mal gesagt, man könne ja wohl nicht, oder es wäre unverantwortlich, etwas auf Basis von irgendwelchen mathematischen Modellen zu entscheiden. Fragen wir uns natürlich, wie wäre das als Corona-Kanzler gewesen, wenn er dann gleich mit der Provinz einhergegangen wäre, um zu sagen, ne, also wenn du dein freistehendes Haus im Dorf X, Y hast, darfst du natürlich Leben und walten, wie du willst.
Okay, die Pointe ist schön und trotzdem falsch. Denn, ich will es hier vorlesen, Scholz ist bekannt dafür von Experten nicht besonders viel zu halten. Ja. Okay, mag sein. Sandles Ding ist ja vor allem eines, dass er die Meritokratie kritisiert. Nämlich, wenn man sagt, wir setzen Chancengleichheit absolut, dann kann man natürlich dafür sorgen, dass Leute es schaffen nach oben und vielleicht auch aus Verhältnissen, wo man es nicht gedacht hätte, dass sie es schaffen, aber es produziert ein System von lauter Verlierern, die es dann alle nicht nach oben geschafft haben, was ja in der Wettbewerbslogik liegt. Und deswegen sind sie selbst schuld und deswegen werden sie dann verachtet oder verachten sich selbst bzw. versuchen sie dann sich zu radikalisieren. Und deswegen setzt Scholz dem den Respekt entgegen und sagt, nein, wir müssen weg von dieser Meritokratie, wir brauchen da eine Respektpolitik.
Die bedeutet, egal wo du bist, du bist wichtig in dieser Gesellschaft. Und das finde ich erst einmal richtig. Jetzt kann man darüber streiten, ob Scholz das jetzt so umgesetzt hat, diese Politik, aber lass uns mal dahingestellt.
Ja, warte, warte, bevor du deine Pointe machst. Scholz ist ja nicht gegen Experten. Er ist nur gegen die anderen Experten, weil wie er sagt.
Ja, und jetzt schreibt er aber Schiritz, aus seiner Sicht gibt es vor allem einen Experten, ihn selbst. Als eine Gruppe von Wirtschaftswissenschaften nach dem russischen Angriff auf die Ukraine eine Untersuchung veröffentlichte, aus der hervorgeht, dass es für die deutsche Wirtschaft verkraftbar sei, wenn Gaslieferungen aus Russland eingestellt würden, entgegnete Scholz. Es sei unverantwortlich, so etwas auf der Basis von irgendwelchen mathematischen Modellen zu behaupten. Es kann man natürlich sagen, da hätte der Kanzler sich präziser ausdrucken können oder das genügt nicht akademischen Standards. Allerdings sind ja diese Berechnungen, die da gemacht wurden, federführend von Rudi Bachmann, ja durchaus kritisiert worden von anderen wissenschaftlichen Kapazitäten. Und auch ich, der jetzt diese Berechnungen nicht gemacht habe, aber der jetzt diese Debatte doch sehr gründlich damals verfolgt hat, würde sagen, dieses Papier, das Rudi Bachmann mit anderen vorgelegt hat, war eines, wo der Wunsch der Vater das Gedanken war. Und deswegen halte ich es für absolut katastrophal, hätte man tatsächlich dieses Papier, also diese Expertenmeinung, in die Politik übertragen und umgesetzt. Insofern hat ja Scholz meines Erachtens vollkommen korrekt gehandelt.
Ja, allerdings in dem Falle war das dann Habeck, weil der hat ja dann Karamioski erklärt, nein, wir können nicht einfach die Mengen, die auf dem Papier stehen, wie Rudi Bachmann gegeneinander aufrechnen und sagen, es wird schon reichen, sondern wir müssen die Kesselwagen zählen, die wir haben, um das zu transportieren. So, also der Einschlag ist dann schon da. Nur die kleine Pointe erlaube ich mir jetzt hier, weil Christian Dorsten letztens im Interview der Woche für eine Stunde beim Deutschlandfunk zu Gast war, wo er drauf zu sprechen kam, wie ist das jetzt mit den Schulen gewesen und so weiter und so fort. Und dann betont er eben noch mal, das Virus hat überall die gleiche Form von Ansteckung gehabt. Die Schule ist nur ein Bereich gewesen, der zum einen politisch sehr leicht handhabbar ist, weil da weiß man genau, pro Raum 20 Kinder, wenn man dann drei Räume schließt, hat man 60 Kinder Kontakt-Sperre und so weiter. Plus wir haben ein besonderes Fokus durch die Wissenschaft, weil die Schulstudie besonders einfach operationalisierbar war. Bei der Frage Arbeitsmarkt-Studie, ja was Arbeitsmarkt? Arbeiten die da in einem Loft-Großraum oder ist das im Keller irgendwie oder wie auch immer. Also muss man sich genau anschauen, was man hat. Was eben bedeutet, wenn jetzt diese Kritik, die du an diesem Zitat und so weiter, also Scholz hat hier durchaus recht. Man kann nicht einfach auf dem Papier durchrechnen. Die Corona-Politik war so ein auf dem Papier durchrechnen. Also könnte man jetzt genauso sagen, wenn Scholz damals, also er hätte genauso sagen müssen, ne wir können das jetzt nicht einfach wegen irgendwelchen mathematischen Modellen die Schulen schließen. Das ist sozusagen nur als Kleideponte.
Aber du bist ja durchaus auch ein Kritiker von Schulschulwesen.
Ja, ich finde auch durchaus, dass man sich damals hätte mutig hinstellen können und sagen können, sorry, aber diese Kritik ist so offensichtlich, dass sie hier einfach die Schule als Standardcontainer sehen, bei der sie sagen 1000 Schüler, kein Unterricht, 1000 mal keine Kontakte oder eben hochgerechnet. Und alles andere ist uns wurscht. Genau. Und dann sagen alle, ja das sind wunderbarste mathematische Modelle oder sagen, ne das sind einfach nur einfache Lösungen. Die mathematischen Modelle kann man genauso gut auf den Commerzbankzentrale anwenden oder wie auch immer und die nach Hause schicken. Naja, Populismus sind wir ja beim Thema, erschlägt oben auf den Populismus. Wir haben also populistische Parteien, die vor allem deswegen attraktiv sind, weil sie ein zentrales Merkmal betonen. Du hast es ja häufiger gesagt. Sie sagen dem Publikum, die Politik könne noch was machen. Ja. Was super interessant ist, weil das ist ja genau was wir bei Ronsheimer eben gehört haben. Herr Schmidt, kommen Sie nicht hier mit den ganzen Regeln und so weiter, sondern und so weiter.
Zu viele Details.
Genau, das sind zu viele Details, können wir nicht einfach mal was machen. So, wenn man jetzt aber einfach mal was macht, er ist ja Wirtschaftsredakteur, Marc Schieritz, das Institut für Weltwirtschaft in Kiel hat sich 60 Länder in den 120 vergangenen Jahren angeschaut und hat festgestellt, Populisten richten in aller Regel erheblichen wirtschaftlichen Schaden an. Das ist Zitat der Wirtschaftswissenschaftler.
Wundert uns nicht.
Genau, wundert uns nicht, weil Grenze zu heißt eben ein Todesfall weniger, bei dem wir sagen, es gibt zehn andere Lösungsmöglichkeiten, die diesen Todesfall verhindern und die Grenze spielt da keine Rolle und ja, man kann aber auch die Grenze zu machen, nur Folgeschäden sind eben enorm. Die Studie zeigt, nach 15 Jahren liegt das reale Protoinlandsprodukt in populistisch regierten Ländern zehn Prozent unter dem Niveau mit vergleichbaren Staaten, wo die Wähler anders entschieden haben. Diesen Satz hat er leider nicht so gemacht. Populisten schotten nämlich als erstes die eigene Wirtschaft ab, durch Zölle und Einschränkungen des grenzüberschreitenden Kapitalverkehrs oder der Freizügigkeit und das sehen wir wirklich jedes Mal. Trump kommt, Muslim-Band, Grenzen zu, Zölle hoch. Man fragt sich so, ja genau, aber ist das nicht total dumm? Wir sehen März, Grenze zu, bei Betonung, also ich hab Trump gesehen, vieles unterstütze ich nicht, aber dieses Primat der Wirtschaft und das man jetzt wieder sagt, America first, also Zölle, Grenze zu, das ist gut.
Das hören wir mit ihm noch in eben.
Explizit, also man geht genau diesen Blödheits- oder wie wir sagen müssen, Dummheits-Drehbuch rein und geht immer wieder genau in diese Falle rein. Man macht einen kurzen Brotfeuer und dann stellt man 30 Jahre später fest, aha Mist, war doch irgendwie, hat uns doch zurückgehalten. Na ja, wirklich dramatisch. Populismus der AfD wird natürlich besonders betont. Austritt aus der Währungsunion, Austritt aus der Europäischen Union, selbst das Zurückführen von irgendwelchen internationalen Zusammenhängen, die man ist, wird hier beziffert. Das Institut der deutschen Wirtschaft in diesem Falle rechnet 690 Milliarden Euro Schaden innerhalb von fünf Jahren aus.
Ja, sieben Sondervermögen.
Es ist wirklich absurd. Und wie kann man jetzt Entscheidungen gut treffen? Wir brauchen Entscheidungsregeln, die Präferenzen abbilden und am Ende trotz Abstraktion und Summierung zu etwas führen. Und das ist wohl wahnsinnig schwer. Wir haben hier Wirtschaftsnobelpreis prämierte Doktorarbeiten, die uns sagen, die Aggregation, und das ist jetzt ein Zitat aus dieser Doktorarbeit, die Aggregation individueller Präferenzen in eine logische und fehlerfrei ableitbare gesamtgesellschaftliche Präferenzordnung ist nicht ohne Weiteres möglich. Oder beziehungsweise er zitiert hier Claudia Landwehr, die über diese Doktorarbeit schreibt. Also es gibt keinen Weg. Wir können nicht einzelne, es gibt keinen Wählerwillen, der in einer Beziehung steht zu einem individuellen Präferenz. Ich habe ja immer wieder Luma zitiert, mit man geht wählen und wählt motivlos. Man ist emotional bei der Sache. Man hat vielleicht auch gerade was gelesen, aber man geht doch relativ motivlos in so eine Wahl.
Aus der Laune heraus wird irgendwas angekreunt.
Man ist in so einer gewissen Stimmung. Das Wetter ist schlecht, ich wähl AfD. Es regnet und ich hab meinen Schirm vergessen. Und der Bus ist auch nicht gekommen, jetzt aber, zeig ich's Scholz. Also das sind so die Zusammenhänge, wie man's macht.
Und da haben wir dann zugleich diesen Land- und Stadtkonflikt, auf den konnte er ja auch zu sprechen. Er erwähnt Thüringen, da heißt es, in absoluten Zahlen haben in Thüringen etwa 400.000 Menschen die AfD gewählt. Das entspricht in etwa der Einwohnerzahl von Berlin Mitte. Es sind aber nicht sehr viele Sondersendungen über die Sorgen und Nöte der Menschen in Berlin Mitte erschienen. Genau wie es wenige Sondersendungen dazu gab, dass die SPD im März 2022 im Saarland eine absolute Mehrheit der Sitze geholt hat oder die AfD im Mai des selben Jahres in Nordrhein-Westfalen nur knapp den Einzug in das Parlament geschafft hat. Es ist also womöglich etwa verweigen, aus einer Wahlentscheidung in einem ostdeutschen Bundesland Aussagen für die Republik insgesamt abzuleiten. Wir kennen diese Diskussionen. Thüringen geht uns voraus. Thüringen ist Deutschland. Er geht dann darauf ein, dass nur 15 Prozent der Bevölkerung in wirklichen Dörfern leben. Die anderen leben sehr wohl in städtischer Umgebung, im städtischen Raum.
Das wird wirklich hart übersehen. Ich hab ja dieses, also Urbanisierung ist ja sowieso die größte demografische Migrationsbewegung, die wir haben. Nur Leute, die in Kronberg leben und für uns so auf dem Land, die laufen fünf Minuten zur S-Bahn, fahren 25 Minuten und sind in der Oper Frankfurt. Also das Einzugsgebiet für die Zeil als Einkaufsstraße in einer Stadt, die 770.000 Einwohner hat oder so, ist fünf Millionen Menschen. Weil die ganze Dorfbevölkerung natürlich in einem urbanen Kontext lebt. Also das Problem, dass das nicht so ist, hat vielleicht so ein bisschen keine Ahnung, wenn man sich dann Sachsen, Dresden, also wer weit von Dresden und Leipzig weg wohnt, lebt dann wirklich mal in der Provinz, wo man so zwei Stunden zum Krankenhaus mit dem Auto fahren muss. Aber alles andere ist wirklich sehr urban.
Das heißt also, die Provinz wird dann quasi zu wichtig genommen. Ich würde es vielleicht anders sagen. Man hat so eine mediale Urbanität, die über stark abgebildet ist. Also das Leben eines Menschen in einem eher dürflichen Raum mit einem Durchschnittslohn und dem Leben eines Menschen mit einem Durchschnittslohn in einer größeren Stadt unterscheidet sich nicht so fundamental von den Möglichkeiten, die man hat zu einkaufen, essen zu gehen und sonst was zu tun. Aber was uns glaube ich sehr stark in den Medien gezeigt wird, ist ein medialer Hotspot, der ist vor allem Berlin, ein bisschen Hamburg, ein bisschen München ja. Und dort wird uns natürlich eine Lebensweise präsentiert und diese für absolut erklärt, die natürlich mit den meisten Lebensweisen nichts zu tun hat. Und deswegen ist eigentlich dann der, sagen wir mal in Anführungszeichen, normale Koblenzer und normale Eifler und normale Frankfurter, die sind sich näher, dann doch in viel Hinsicht, als Leute, die zum Beispiel im Medienbetrieb den Ton angeben. Und ich glaube, diese Kluft müsste man stärker herausarbeiten, wenn man jetzt darauf abzielt.
Jetzt haben wir hier eine Problemlage, das wir eben schon festgestellt haben. Der Wählerwille führt manchmal die Irre. Plus, wir können keinen richtigen Bogen schlagen, aus dem Einzelnen zum Gesamtwählerwille. Plus, der Einzelne, ob jetzt Provinz oder nicht, hat ja selber auch noch eine, wie soll man sagen, gewisse Hürden zu überspringen, um überhaupt für sich klar zu werden, was will ich hier eigentlich. Also ein Motiv für sich herzustellen. Und jetzt stellen wir dem Hörer ein Rätsel, das uns Marc Schiritz auch gestellt hat, an dem ich auch gescheitert bin. Ich gebe es zu.
Ja, ich auch.
Der Ball und der Schläger.
Ja, macht mal.
Also wir müssen jetzt ein mathematisches Rätsel lösen. Und wenn man es weiß, ist es so einfach, dass man sich denkt, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Aber ich gehöre zu den 80, mehr als 80 Prozent, die auch erst mal eine falsche Antwort gaben. Ball und Schläger kosten zusammen ein Euro und zehn Cent. Der Schläger kostet ein Euro mehr als der Ball. Was kostet der Ball? So, jetzt kann man darüber nachdenken. Ich hab auch meine Kids gefragt. Die eine ist wie ich dran gescheitert und die andere hat es richtig gerechnet. Und sie hat uns dann vorgerechnet, wie sie das gerechnet hatten. Wir konnten das nicht nachvollziehen, aber es hat sie irgendwie zur richtigen Lösung geführt. Also die Antwort ist nicht, dass der Ball zehn Cent kostet. Weil dann würde ja der Schläger ein Euro zehn kosten und alles zusammen eins zwanzig. Die richtige Antwort ist also, der Schläger kostet ein Euro fünf und der Ball kostet fünf Cent. So, okay, damit haben wir dieses eigene Problem erst mal gelöst. Also die mathematischen Tatsachen sind unhintergehbar. Ja, wir haben es hier nicht mit einem super komplizierten Problem zu tun, das noch mal in höherer Algebrate, was auch immer, sondern es sind fünf Cent und ein Euro fünf. Und diese Fragestellung, diese Rechenaufgabe, kommt von Shane Frederick, die damit auch nicht jetzt rechnen will mit den Leuten, sondern sie möchte, dass die 80 Prozent, die eine falsche Antwort gegeben haben, sie interessiert sich dafür, wie die damit umgehen, wenn man sie konfrontiert, dass das Ergebnis falsch ist.
Und wir haben ja einen Clip gehört hier von Mario Basler im letzten Podcast, der auch eine kleine Rechenaufgabe gestellt bekommt und dann wird eingewendet, naja, aber es gibt ja Punkt vor Strich.
Was?
Punkt vor Strich? Das interessiert mich nicht. Seit wann haben wir denn so was?
Genau. So, und jetzt stellt sich raus. Die Studienteilnehmer erhielten nun den Hinweis, dass 10 Cent nicht die richtige Lösung sei. Dennoch blieben immer noch rund 20 Prozent der Befragten bei der Antwort 10 Cent. Die Erfolgsquote verbesserte sich auch nicht, als das Ergebnis, wie gesagt 5 Cent, als Lösungsvorschlag angegeben wurde. Ein signifikanter Anteil der Probanden war also nicht bereit, ein intuitiv gefälltes Urteil zu hinterfragen, selbst wenn sie darauf hingewiesen wurden, dass dies falsch ist.
Und da sind wir in der Sphäre der Mathematik, wo es noch ganz klar belegbar ist.
Das ist ganz eindeutig. Wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir können die Grenzen nicht zumachen, weil wir die 70 Milliarden Gigatonnen Material und Produkte gerne hier im Supermarkt haben. Also wir haben gerne etwas zu kaufen, wenn wir in den Supermarkt gehen, weil wir die Errungenschaft nicht selber jagen zu müssen, gerne weiter nutzen möchten. Und dann stehen signifikante Teile und mit signifikant, weiß ich, ist nicht viel gemeint, sondern einfach nur die sind unbeirrbar.
Das werden mehr als 20 Prozent sein.
Genau, das zum einen und die unbeirrbar. Das meint Signifikanter, die sind unbeirrbar. Die sagen, nein, die Grenze muss trotzdem zu, weil ein Junge gestorben ist in Aschaffenburg. Ja. So und das ist die Herausforderung, mit der wir dann umgehen müssen.
Du hattest irgendwann mal eine Studie aus Japan zitiert, da wurde gefragt, wollen sie von, ich glaube, Vietnamesen?
Lieber sterben oder von Ausländern gepflegt werden? Und dann sagen die Ex-Pozitiven, lieber sterben. So, also jetzt die Frage, sind wir zu dumm für die Demokratie? Schiritz kommt auf Penny Cook zu sprechen, die an dieser Forschung auch eine Rolle spielt. Die Schlussfolgerung von Penny Cook. Viele Menschen sind nicht, es sind schlicht zu faul, zu borniert, zu sehr von sich selbst überzeugt, um politische Botschaften kritisch einzuordnen. Jetzt sagt er, man könnte auch sagen, zu dumm. Klammer auf. Wobei damit eben gerade nicht ein möglicher Mangel an formaler Bildung gemeint ist. Klammer zu. Ich würde sagen schon ein bisschen.
Aber ja, es wird wahrscheinlich bei manchen Zusammenhänge geben, aber ich glaube gerade da diese Starrsinnigkeit, die jetzt einfach sagt, nee, das machen wir nicht so. Das haben wir nie gemacht oder so. Dass das etwas ist, was ja sehr, sehr ausgeweitet ist. Also diese Renitenz, die da drin steckt. Und das kann man ja schon in solchen YouTube-Formaten, in denen die ganze Zeit für die AfD votiert wird, sehen. Also das sind ja durchaus studierte Leute darunter, die aber wirklich sich so verkeilt haben, dass sie... Also man kann auch blöde werden. Das ist, glaube ich, etwas, was... Also es kann so eine Selbstradikalisierung stattfinden, in einer Weise, dass man nicht mehr die Mathematik berücksichtigen will und sie dann für immer ausschließt. Also man kann das doch sehr gut sehen. Ulf Poschert ist ja jemand, der immer so eine FDP-Linie irgendwie gefahren hat, und zwar schon vor 20 Jahren. Der hat dann damals noch so ein bisschen über Kunst und sowas geschrieben, kannte sich da einigermaßen der Pop-Kultur aus. Und dann hat er sich über Twitter radikalisiert, beziehungsweise Twitter hat seinen Kopf gehackt. Der kann jetzt nur noch in diesen Arten denken, wie so ein Twitter-Diskurs ist. Wie Elon Musk auch. Wie bei Elon Musk. Also Elon Musk ist der Opfer seiner eigenen Plattform. Und bei Ulf Poschert können wir das in ähnlicher Weise beobachten. Und da ist dann einfach nicht mehr ein anderes Denken möglich. Das könnte man dem vorrechnen und vorlegen und machen und tun. Und dann würde er immer noch sagen, nee.
Ja, bei Philipp Hopf stellt sich auch die Frage, der ist ja Teilhaber von diesem Analyseunternehmen für Marktbewegung im finanzialen Bereich. Also nicht Marktbewegung im Äpfel und Birnverkaufen, sondern nur da, wo verbriefte Werte verhandelt werden. Und die spezialisieren sich ja auf, steht der Expezit da, technische Analyse. Technische Analyse bedeutet, man beobachtet allein die Marktbewegungen und wertet die mathematisch aus und kümmert sich gerade mit Absicht nicht um die Wirklichkeit als Marktumfeld. Sondern man generiert das Wissen aus den Bewegungen der verbrieften Werte allein. Da könnte man dann so Linien eingezogen und sagen, die Linie wurde noch nie durchbrochen. Also geht man so in diese Richtung. Und das hat sehr viel mit Wahrheitsfindung durch Ausblendung von Wirklichkeit zu tun. Es wird einfach eine eigene Wirklichkeit geschaffen und zwar so als ganz bewusst definierter Bereich. Das hat durchaus viel Sinn, so was zu machen, aber nicht in der Politik. Also da geht das einfach nicht.
Nun wissen wir ja, dass in der massmedialen Welt auch Wirklichkeiten geschaffen werden. Nur das kann nur da Wirklichkeit geschaffen werden. Ja, das bedeutet aber doch, dass wir uns das vielleicht ein bisschen zu einfach machen, wenn wir die ganze Zeit auf die AfD abzielen. Also da sind wir uns alle immer sofort einig und da ist es auch am transparentesten. Aber ich finde zum Beispiel, wenn Schieritz anführt, dass Habermas ja so eine Gewährleistung eines inklusiven Meinungs- und Willensbildungsprozesses ist und dass wir gerade jetzt sehen an solchen Geschichten wie in Ohio, essen die Migranten die Haustiere, wohin das führen kann, wenn das eben nicht mehr gewährleistet ist, dann bringt er aber als Beispiel auch Rumänien und den Einfluss von TikTok, wo wir schon von Martin Sonneborn gehört haben, naja so einfach ist das eigentlich nicht, wie das da gesagt wird, haben wir es da nicht eher mit Zensurbeschreibung zu tun. Beziehungsweise, warum wird hier auch wieder in diesem Text so sehr abgezielt auf die sozialen Medien und all das, wo wir noch im letzten Podcast zum Beispiel einen Clip von einem Zeit-Podcast vorgespielt haben, in dem so getan wurde, als sei das also völlig verrückt, was die Linke fordert bzw. was die Linke sagt. Die Linke sagt, wenn deine Mieten steigen, profitiert dein Vermieter. So in etwa ist der Satz. Und bei der Zeit macht sich eine Redakteurin darüber lustig. Da muss ich sagen, ja, aber das ist ja genauso blöde wie alles, was uns jetzt über Radwege in Peru sonst wo erzählt wird.
Absolut. Weshalb ja die große Kritik an diesem Buch hier ist, dass ein Journalist mal wieder den Journalismus ausblendet.
Ja, interessant.
Denn der Brückenschlag zwischen Publikum und Politik ist nun mal der Medienbetrieb. Also wenn wir Dummheit verorten, können wir es der Quelle unterstellen, je nachdem wie das dann gemeint ist, die Politik oder das Publikum oder halt dem Medialen und das ist ja der Name, Medium des Medialen Betriebs. Ich optiere natürlich sehr dafür, hier diesen blinden Fleck mal ganz deutlich zu betonen, wie du es jetzt gemacht hast.
Auch wenn gesagt wird, dass die Gesellschaft sich nicht mehr einigen kann, was eigentlich die Fakten sind und dann ist die Schlussfolgerung, dass dadurch das System und seine Legitimation erodieren. Konnte man sich denn sonst darauf einigen? Also gab es eine Einigung in der Bevölkerung darauf, dass wir unbedingt diesen Afghanistan-Krieg mitkämpfen müssen? Und wenn ja, war das sinnvoll. Wir kennen aus den Corona-Jahren diese Debatten, als man sagte Schnelltests sind nicht die Lösung. Plötzlich waren Schnelltests die Lösung.
Wir fliegt. Nein, doch nicht.
Wir wissen, die Ukraine muss diesen Krieg gewinnen. Inzwischen hört man diesen Satz nirgends mehr.
Hast du Emma Thewesens Spruch gehört?
Nein.
Emma Thewesens ließ sich bei Illner zuschalten und sagte dann, es wird ja zum Glück nicht so sein, dass morgen dort der Frieden ausbricht.
Ja.
Und das ist natürlich klar auf der einen Seite, der hätte sagen können, dass dort morgen ein Diktat Frieden ausbricht und die Ukraine unterjocht werden wie auch immer. Aber es steckt trotzdem einige Wahrheit darin, welche groben Strategien da gefahren wurden und zwar unter Ausblendung des Publikums, dass sich nämlich mehrheitlich natürlich da in Frieden wünscht. Und genau der wurde ihnen dann begrifflich als ein Glücksfall, zum Glück kommt es nicht dazu, ausgeredet.
Und da wäre ich dann doch mal gegen eine Einhegung der Demokratie und lieber dafür, dass man mitspricht. Und das ist dieses große Problem, das ich sehe und vielleicht müssen da noch ein paar Bücher zugeschrieben werden, wie man das eigentlich hinbekommt, wenn man sagt, es gibt gewisse Institutionen, wenn diese unterminiert werden, dann wird es richtig gefährlich. Dann droht uns der Faschismus direkt vor der Tür zu stehen.
Also Friedlich und Frieden, körperliche Unversehrtheit sind genau diese Themen, die wir jetzt diskutiert haben die letzten Jahre. Und jetzt wundert man sich, dass die Leute zu dumm sind für die Demokratie. Ja. Das ist ein mediales Versagen gewesen. Schiritz geht allerdings einen anderen Weg. Er erklärt uns noch mal das wilde Tier von Hegel, die Diskurs Hölle von Schumpeter.
Der Wähler wird wieder zum Primitiven, sagt Schumpeter. Wer den politischen Diskurs also betritt, der ist bereit, das Schlimmste in sich zu wecken, zum Vorschein zu bringen.
Die Demokratie kippt sowieso immer früher oder später in die Tyrannei, sagte Platon schon damals. Ich hätte mir auch mehr so einen medialen Diskurs gewünscht jetzt als noch mal diese Geschichte, der die Demokratie hat es schon immer schwer in ihrer Selbstbeschreibung. Ja, so ist es hier. Und dann hat er einen großen Blog, Wirtschaft, wählen gegen die eigenen Interessen, Wirtschaftsthemen haben es schwer, vor allem, das natürlich wichtig, das betonen wir deswegen auch noch mal, dabei ist Wirtschaft ein mehrdimensionaler Begriff, sagt er und nicht identisch mit der eigenen finanziellen Situation. Das ist Medienkritik. Das ist Dunja Hayali, die uns die ganze Zeit vorgaukelt und explizit und genau so sagt, jeder der einen Haushalt führt weiß ja wie es ist. Und dann Olaf Scholz hat es schwer. Wir wählen gegen unsere eigenen Interessen, weil uns die Medien genau das vormachen, weil sie uns das als Handlungs- und Denkorientierung an die Hand gegeben haben. Das finde ich sehr löblich, dass er die abstrakten Gerechtigkeitsvorstellungen, die wir haben, runterbricht auf Besteuerung von Erbschaften und Transferleistungen.
Richtig.
Und wir sagen uns selber alle, wir haben ja was zu vererben und sind nicht auf den Staat angewiesen und deswegen müssen auch alle Milliardäre in Ruhe gelassen werden und niemand darf irgendwie vom Staat unterstützt werden. Genau, das passiert eben dann, wenn Dunja Hayali es heute schon reportiert. Und zwar nur, weil Dunja Hayali das so macht. In der Schule lernt man das auch nicht so. Selbst in Universitäten wird ja heute so ein bisschen abgewichen von der alten Lehre. Nur bei Dunja Hayali nicht. Das ist immer noch der Start.
Ich könnte eher ihr sagen, da unterminieren die Institutionen der liberalen Demokratie eigentlich ihre Grundlagen. Denn eigentlich müssten die Institutionen der liberalen Demokratie, sowohl dazu gehöre ich Gerichte, Medien, Politiker, also Parteien, Stiftungen, darauf hinweisen, dass eine entsprechende Besteuerung von Erbschaften unabdingbar ist, um überhaupt eine demokratische Ordnung im liberalen Sinne zu gewährleisten, um nicht eine Prologaschie oder wie man das heute nennt entstehen zu lassen. Also eine Oligarchie der Bros. Und da ist also der Punkt eigentlich, wo man sagen muss, inwieweit muss man eigentlich den Ist-Zustand von liberalen Institutionen kritisieren, im Namen der liberalen Demokratie?
Ja, ich finde auch, wir müssen die liberale Demokratie gegen den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk verteidigen. Das Arter auch ab und zu mal was sendet, ja aber...
Ja, wir verteidigen ja quasi auch den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk gegen den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk. Also wir wollen ja nicht sagen, dass wir nur noch RTL haben wollen, sondern wir sagen ja, warum macht ihr es nicht eigentlich so und so und so und so?
Ja, absolut, absolut, absolut. Großer, großer, großer blinder Fleck leider in diesem Buch. Na ja, es ist wie es ist. Die Hobbits, die Hooligans, die Vulkanier kommen jetzt hier in meinem Textverlauf vor. Ja, bei mir auch. Wir haben es natürlich schon genannt, das ist, ich finde es ganz illustrativ, es ist eine Idee von Brennan, wie heißt er mit Vornamen? Jason Brennan.
Ja, das ist leider kein gutes Buch, das sage ich gleich. Diese Idee, die er da hat, weil er auch, also das ist interessant, er schreibt in diesem Buch in einem Kapitel sehr intensiv auch über Wirtschaft dieser Brennan und sagt, wie ungebildet die Leute da sind. Der Witz ist nur, Brennan spricht sich die ganze Zeit dafür aus, dass die Staatsschulden nicht so hoch sein dürfen und all das. Also er ist eigentlich total in diesem Austeritätsparadig mal gefangen, ist also da selber blöde, könnte man sagen und will aber den anderen Leuten sagen, ihr seid eigentlich zu dumm für die Demokratie. Das ist natürlich ein Problem, zumal auch nochmal diese Sache mit der formalen Bildung, wer sehr wichtig ist zu sagen, denn gerade mit Bezug auf die Migrationsfrage können wir auch sehen, dass es da ja nicht so ist, wo die formale Bildung hoch ist, unbedingt eine unglaubliche Migrationsfreundlichkeit vorherrscht.
Weshalb er ja auch sagt und das also Grundbesitz zu haben, kann einen ja gerade über den Grund- und Bodenverteidigungsnationalismus dazu führen, dass man dann trotz guter Bildung, die einen dazu führte, dass man im Blick hat, wie man seine Versicherungspolisen so abschließt, dass man sehr viel von seinem Grund und Boden hat und so, dass man dann besonders sensibilisiert ist gegen, da ist gerade jemand die Straße runtergefahren, das Kennzeichen kenne ich nicht. So und das ist aber noch, also Rassismus ist das eine. Wir haben es ja aber grundsätzlich mit, wir mögen uns halt einfach nicht als Menschen. Das kann man auch machen, genau so was.
Wir denken an die Windräder. Ich würde sagen, fast alle Windradgegner, die da irgendwelche Petitionen unterschreiben, wenn man sie mal ins Gebet nehmen würde, würden sie alle den Sinn und Zweck von Windrädern anerkennen. Sie würden nur sagen, ja, aber nicht in meinem Vorgarten.
Weshalb der Brennen ja auch ein bisschen von der Dummheit abrückt. Also es kommen durchaus Rationalitäten ins Spiel. Er sagt aber, so zitiert ihn Schiritz, die meisten Menschen sind nicht dumm, sie interessieren sich nicht, einfach nicht für Politik. Und da würde ich sagen, ja, das ist die Kenngröße, mit der wir jetzt arbeiten müssen. Es ist eine arbeitsteilige Gesellschaft. Wenn sich alle für Politik interessieren und alle nur noch als Teil des politischen Sehens, dann ist ja auch nicht geholfen.
Also sind wir alle sitzen nur noch zusammen und diskutieren.
Deswegen nennt man es ja Publikumsrolle, weil jemand Zuschauer ist. So und man darf durchaus ahnungslos von Politik sein. Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass deswegen andere das Recht haben, einen bescheuerten Beschlussvorlagen vorzulegen. Genauso wie niemand uns die Suppe vergiften darf, nur weil wir sie nicht selber gekocht haben, sondern für 30 Euro im Restaurant bestellt. Sie sind ja nicht selber in die Küche gekommen, um zu kontrollieren, dass wir sie nicht versalzen. Was können wir denn dafür, dass sie ihre Suppe nicht schmeckt? Also so geht das ja alles einfach gar nicht. Gut, also die Hobbits, die Hooligans, die Vulkanier. Vulkanier sind informiert und an empirisch abgestützten Urteilen interessiert. Na gut. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das Buch darüber hinaus auch nicht sehr cool ist.
Ist wirklich nicht besonders. Er sagt dann in dem sechsten Kapitel Grenzen der Demokratie, dass Menschen nun mal keine Engel sind und man eben deshalb sie einigen muss. Ich frage mich aber dann eigentlich, haben wir das nicht die ganze Zeit? Also wir haben natürlich jetzt noch keine AfD-Verbot oder so, aber es gibt ja schon auch eine regelrechte Übergriffigkeit des Staates, die an den Tag gelegt wird. Oder man kann ja auch fragen, ist jetzt so was wie eine Wiedereinführung der Wehrpflicht nicht ein ganz deutliches Zeichen dafür, dass also meine Freiheit als Individuum sehr stark eingehegt wird, auch an Stellen, wo ich es gar nicht möchte. Dann kommt er auf die Zentralbanken zu sprechen und sagt, in den meisten Industrienationen sind zum Beispiel die Notenbanken unabhängig. In Deutschland ist diese Unabhängigkeit sogar im Grundgesetz festgehalten. Damit ist ein zentraler Bereich der Wirtschaftspolitik, der direkten parlamentarischen Kontrolle und der demokratischen Willensbildung entzogen. Die Höhe des Zinsniveaus ist von entscheidender Bedeutung für die Finanzlage des Staates, von Unternehmen und von Haushalten. Dennoch regulieren Fachleute und nicht gewählte Politiker die Geldversorgung der Wirtschaft. Ja ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht? Was ist mit der stabilen Wirtschaftsordnung gemeint? Die Linke schlägt beispielsweise in ihrem Programm vor, diese Unabhängigkeit stärker zu begrenzen und mehr das Parlament auch bei EZB-Entscheidungen mitsprechen zu lassen. Wir wissen ja auch, dass diese Schuldenregel eine willkürliche Setzung ist, die man dann irgendwann akzeptiert hat. Also was ich damit sagen will, man kann relativ leicht mit dieser Argumentation, wir müssen die liberale Ordnung schützen, auch sehr viel, nennen wir es prokursive Politik, unterbinden.
Ja, aber zugestandermaßen schließt er das Kapitel ja als sozusagen aktuelle Illustration an die Argumentation, dass wir grundsätzlich so eine Art Gewaltenteilung brauchen.
Ja.
Also Montesquieu wird natürlich noch mal genannt, die verschiedenen Pole. Es war wohl ein zentraler Grundgedanke damals, auch schon den Despotismus zu verhindern, die Macht aufzuteilen und die Unabhängigkeit von Notenbanken oder dass wir einen europäischen Gerichtshof haben und einen internationalen Gerichtshof, Tschiedsgerichtshof, Handelsfragen hat ja alles mit diesem aufteilen von Macht zu tun, also einhegen durch, entdemokratisieren.
Bedeutet aber dann in vielen Fällen, dass wir dann keinen Zugriff haben, wo es eigentlich notwendig wäre oder wo wir das als notwendig auffassen würden. Man kann ja dann, wie er das tut, Konrad Adenauers NATO-Politik loben. Er lobt aber auch die Entspannungspolitik von Willy Brandt. Es wird aber auch durchaus positiv kutiert, dass Schröder sich trotzdem durchgesetzt hat mit seiner Agenda 2010. Und dann würde ich sagen, wem hat das jetzt gerade gedient? Also zumindest nicht der arbeitenden Bevölkerung. Mach ich mich, wenn ich mich also für diese liberale Ordnung ausspreche, nicht sehr gemein mit einem Ausbeutungsregime?
Ja, also sobald man dieses Buch, sag mal mal, man würde es jetzt um 100 Seiten ergänzen wie Harari, Empirie, dann wird es alles ganz schwierig. Ja, also diese Argumentation uns nicht aufrechterhalten.
Denn so hat man manchmal den Eindruck, das will ich Ihnen nicht unterstellen, aber man kann das daraus ableiten, sich so seine Zettelchen rausreißen, dass hier ein Blankoscheck ausgestellt werden soll für Politiker, solange sie liberal demokratisch sind, macht ruhig mal, ihr werdet es schon wissen. Denn die werden ja bis ins Ende nicht.
Genau, genau, genau. Ja, ja, man hat dann gegen Ende noch ein Kapitel, dass ich in dieser Klarheit so jetzt, typischerweise ist das eins, wenn man es so liest, so denkt, ah ja gut, dass er es auch nochmal nennt, irgendwas heil gegen irgendwie und so. Aber in dem Falle ist es doch ein bisschen neu gewesen für mich, nämlich die Geschichtsschreibung, wie Hitlers damals gelang, die Demokratie zu überwinden.
Sehr gut.
Also wir haben ja als Legende, dass eine Machtergreifung stattfand. Und er fragt jetzt, war es nicht mehr eine Machtüberlassung? Also wenn wir es jetzt nicht von Hitler aus betrachten und wie er bevor die Welt unterjochte, erst mal sich die Demokratie unternage riss, wenn wir es jetzt von Seiten des Systems aus betrachten, wie kam es denn dazu, dass das überhaupt gelangt? Und er hat ja am Anfang schon gesagt, Menschen, nicht die Institutionen, sondern die Menschen sind es. Deswegen der besondere Fokus auf März kann er es denn und so. Und wir kommen zu klaren Urteilen und sagen, nein, das ist schon AfD. So und hier ist das eben auch in der Geschichtsschreibung. Wenn man die Faktenlage kennt, deckt sie sich nicht mit den Erzählungen, die wir haben, nämlich dass die Weimarer Demokratie angeblich so konstitutionell wehrlos war. Die Vorstellung einer den Nationalsozialisten institutionell ausgelieferten Republik gehören zu den diversen Selbstentlastenden, mit denen die Eliten der ersten Nachkriegsjahrzehnte sich selbst und die öffentliche Meinung davon zu überzeugen suchten, dass für das Vorausgegangene andere und anderes als sie selbst verantwortlich waren. Also jetzt ist nicht nur Politik wird von Politikern gemacht, sondern auch Demokratie wird von Wählern gemacht. Also es kommen jetzt sozusagen alle in den Fokus. Das ist sehr, sehr gut. Denn die Nationalsozialisten haben, steht hier, demzufolge die Macht nicht ergriffen, man hat sie ihnen gewissermaßen in die Hände gelegt und er nennt die Namen. Der bayerische Ministerpräsident Heinrich Heldt spielte eine wichtige Rolle. Hitler konnte Heldt im Jahr 1925 davon überzeugen, dass er sich künftig an Recht und Gesetz halten wolle und sich für die Bekämpfung des Marxismus einsetzen werde. Daraufhin sagt Heldt öffentlich, die Bestie ist gezähmt, jetzt kann man die Fesseln lockern, verkündet Heldt daraufhin. Acht Jahre später wurde Heldt von der Bestie abgesetzt. Also Demokratie wird gemacht am Ende und Medien werden auch gemacht, Wahlentscheidungen werden auch gemacht. Niemand ist hier aus der Verantwortung, kann einfach sagen, ja dieses Gefüge da und so, das Böckenförde-Diktum zählt am Ende. Niemand kann hier sich drauf berufen. Aber die Brandmauer, nein, März und dann was er ins Gesetz geschrieben hat, in den Gesetzentwurf, das ist entscheidend. Nicht die Brandmauer, die ist da schon institutionell sozusagen Geschichte.
Und man kann sich, ich will es jetzt nicht übertreiben, aber man kann sich schon Aktualisierungen dieser Bestienzähmung, dieser vermeintlichen Zähmung vorstellen, wenn Friedrich März dann irgendwann verkünden würde, ja wir haben uns mit der AfD unterhalten und sie haben uns zugesichert, dass für sie auch der Kampf gegen den Antisemitismus in linken Kreisen so wichtig ist. Wir haben ja schon vor Jahren diese Resolution gemacht, also 2023, die hat die AfD unterzeichnet und wir wollen jetzt gemeinsam auch stärker gegen den Antisemitismus kämpfen und daran kann ja dann alles gemeint sein, wie wir wissen, dass dann irgendwann israelkritische Juden nicht mehr so mitmachen dürfen oder so. Das ist dann auch plötzlich ein Kampf gegen Antisemitismus und da kann man also das sehr schnell ausbreiten und sagen, naja, wir kämpfen jetzt doch gerade gemeinsam gegen einen ganz anderen Feind.
Genau und da müssen wir uns dran erinnern an Arne Semsrott.
Ja.
Wenn die Wahl durch ist und Merz Kanzler, dann ist Merz Kanzler. Und wenn er dann Vorschläge macht, ist es die eine Sache, ja findet er dafür denn eine Mehrheit im Parlament oder wird einer der Koalitionspartner doch noch ein Rückzieher machen? Okay, aber er ist eben auch der letzte Weisungsbefugte für das Innenministerium. Und relativ viele Gesetze, die man einfach nur umsetzen kann, sind halt da.
Budget ist dann da, Gesetze sind da.
Ich will das auch sagen, also ich finde da das Buch von Semsrott, das wir besprochen haben, ist ja etwa so ein halbes Jahr her. Viel aufschlussreicher jetzt nochmal, wenn es wirklich darum geht, wie kann man eigentlich eine liberale Demokratie schützen?
Ja, gegen Ende hat er wichtige Anmerkungen, was jetzt, wie ich finde, wenn man vorher ausführlicher bei Medien gesprochen hätte, ein bisschen expliziter zuschreiben kann. Und das leitet er ein mit einem Hinweis darauf, dass Forscher der Universität Glasgow, Oslo, Aarhus herausgefunden haben bei Unfragen in 32 Ländern. 53 Prozent der befragten Amerikaner würden die Gewaltenteilung aufheben, wenn dafür der Wohlstand steigen und die Kriminalitätsrate sinken würde. Was bedeutet in einer medialen Zeit, in der Twitter wie ein Staatsfunk funktioniert, kann man den Leuten auch einfach sagen, ihr Wohlstand steigt und die Kriminalitätsrate geht runter, egal ob es stimmt oder nicht. Und dann einpreisen, dass sie dafür den einen oder anderen Zwischenruf eines Verwaltungsbeamten nicht länger tun. Also das ist sozusagen diese Arne-Sems-Rott-Gefahr, die dann da besteht.
48% würden sogar auf Wahlen verzichten. In Großbritannien sind es 50 bzw. 43%, die auch zu solchen Schritten bereit wären. Das heißt aber auch, wir haben ja eine Politik gehabt und werden sie auch günstig haben, die den Wohlstand mindert. Und wir sollen jetzt ja sehr schnell uns zufrieden geben, das ist ja eben oft das Versprechen aller liberaldemokratischen Politiker, dass man aber wählen darf. Also man kann wählen, wer die Wohlstandsminderung vornimmt. Ja und das ist das große Problem, das sind ja erschreckende Zahlen, dass man sagt oh Gott das Willen. Die Hälfte, scherz ich nicht mehr, um Demokratie ist bereit die über Bord zu werfen. Die andere Wahrheit ist natürlich auch, dass man sagen kann, ja kennen wir viele Parteien, die den Wohlstand gerade mähern würden, wenn sie an der Macht wären. Und da wird es auch sehr schwierig. Also wir können natürlich jetzt sagen, oh die sind ja alle so egoistisch, die blicken nur auf ihr Portemonnaie. Aber die Tatsache ist ja auch, dass tatsächlich diese Wohlstandsminderung, die stattfindet, ein Problem darstellt. Zeigt sich in zu hohen Mieten und so weiter. Wenn dann die Politik aber sagt, also die liberal-demokratische Politik, wir haben relativ wenig da anzubieten.
Genau.
Dann kann man natürlich sagen, naja was nutzt mir das dann noch, wenn ich das frei gewählt hab, wenn ich ja noch weniger Geld bald habe. Völlig klar, dass die autoritären Parteien, die zur Auktion stehen, in Deutschland oder in anderen Ländern, nicht mehr Wohlstand bringen. Das ist eindeutig bewiesen, es sei denn, man ist irgendwie superreich und hat ein paar Partikularinteressen, die bedient werden. Aber deswegen ist also dieses Ergebnis vielleicht gar nicht so schockierend, dachte ich wieder, weil die Parteien, die da sind, die etablierten sind, so wenig anzubieten haben. Ja.
Und deswegen ist es so schade, dass dieses Buch trotz Kürze erst am Ende richtig gut wird. Mit dem Schluss, also dem expliziten Schluss und kurz davor, denn er stellt hier eine Idee in den Raum. Zitat Mark Schiritz. Es gibt ein Ritual, das nach fast allen Wahlen aufgeführt wird. Die unterlegenen Politiker bedanken sich bei den Wählern und Versprechen, aus dem Wahlergebnis zu lernen und Konsequenzen zu ziehen. Vielleicht wäre es angesichts der Stimmenzuwächse für die Feinde der liberalen Demokratie jetzt Zeit einmal den Wählern zu sagen, was sie gerade angerichtet haben. Denn es gibt neben der Tyrannei einer Mehrheit, die die Demokratie immer gefährdet hat und die wir seit Platon kennen, wenn man das wendet, aber bei dem Problem bleibt natürlich auch eine Tyrannei der Minderheit. Die AfD macht einen Sprung von 17 auf 18 oder von 20 auf 21 Prozent und diese kleine eine Prozent tyrannisiert den ganzen Medienbetrieb und führt dazu, dass Wolfgang Schmidt und die reale Komplexität einer globalen, sich in Migrationsströmen wiederfindenden Welt kriegt er nicht besprochen, weil das eine Prozent, das jetzt gesagt hat von gestern auf heute, ich wähle jetzt die AfD, dominiert Paul Ronzheimers redaktionelle Arbeit im Podcast, dominiert Karim Mioskas redaktionelle Arbeit, dominiert die Tagesschau Redaktion, was auch immer. Und wie gesagt, das sind jetzt erst mal nur 21 Prozent, mit 28 Prozent kriegt man schon vom Präsidenten den Regierungsauftrag, das mit der Kanzlerschaft mal zu versuchen. Wir sind hier weit weg von 50 Prozent, was demokratische Mehrheit bedeutet. Also Tyrannei der Minderheit ist ein wichtiges Bild. Und nun schreibt Matschiris aber und das passt eben nicht zum restlichen Buches, denn die Medien spielen da keine große Rolle. Er schreibt, denn dabei spielt die Öffentlichkeit eine zentrale Rolle. Sie ist der maßgebliche Ort für die Aushandlung gesellschaftlicher Konflikte. Nur gesellschaftliche Konflikte, ich sehe keine gesellschaftlichen Konflikte, ich sehe nur die Anlegungen und die Bedürfnissen der ein Prozent. Die von gestern auf heute sagen, ich will jetzt auch ab.
Das ist die Realität der Massenmedien.
Bei der man sich wundert, warum musste sie so entstehen? Und deswegen finde ich auch, hat er da einen Fehlschluss. Er kommt ja auf Colin Crouch am Ende auch zu sprechen. Crouch hat diesen Begriff Postdemokratie in den 90er Jahren geprägt. Schieres schreibt, damit war gemeint, dass die Wähler im Zeitalter der Globalisierung immer mehr an Einfluss verlieren und Experten und mächtige Interessengruppen zunehmend die politische Agenda bestimmen würden. Das Gegenteil ist passiert. Die Wähler bestimmen die Agenda und die Experten verlieren an Einfluss. Ist das wirklich wahr? Ich würde sagen nein. Es gibt diese Realität der Massenmedien, die dazu führt, dass wir jetzt seit Wochen nur einen Wahlkampf haben, der sich um Migration dreht, obwohl wir in Umfragen gesehen haben, dass Menschen auf Platz eins und zwei meist andere Probleme nennen. Überwiegend wird dann angesprochen, Löhne, Inflation, Mieten und Klima auch sogar, obwohl das schon weit verdrängt wurde jetzt medial. Und wir sehen, dass eine Mehrheit der Bevölkerung für eine Vermögensbesteuerung ist. Gegen Lieferung schwerer Waffen werden trotzdem wird alles geliefert. Für mehr Wohnraum, für niedrigeren Mieten kommt trotzdem nicht. Für eine Einhegung der Börsengeschäfte kommt trotzdem nicht. Also ich sehe das tatsächlich nicht. Ich sehe, dass Stimmungen gemacht werden und dann sagt man ja aber, die Bevölkerung will ja jetzt eine harte Migrationspolitik. Aber sonst doch auf allen anderen relevanten Feldern der Politik wird doch irgendeine Agenda durchgedrückt, bei der man doch nicht jetzt dastehen kann wie Schiritz und sagen kann, man muss auch mal gegen das Volk regieren. Da würde ich sagen, ja das wird ja die ganze Zeit in dem Sinne gemacht. Auch wenn ich jetzt nicht von so einem homogenen Volksbegriff ausgehe oder wenn er sagt, ja es gibt auch eine Sehnsucht mal nach klaren Ansagen und es kann auch unbequem sein. Ich würde sagen, es ist ja wahnsinnig unbequem. Also wovon reden wir denn da? Und dass die Migration jetzt zu dem großen Thema wurde, ist ja ein medial gemachtes, was man daran ja so schön sehen kann, dass 2015 die Migration auch das dominante Thema in den Medien war, weil die Medien sich dazu entschieden ist zu machen. Und damals gab es ja auch dann noch eine politische Realität, die das auch gerechtfertigt hat, nämlich es kamen eine Million Migranten dann durch Merkels Politik nach Deutschland. Man hat aber damals, und daran kann man es ja besonders gut sehen, wie einflussreich diese Realität der Massenmedien ist, eine öffentliche Stimmung pro Migration gefahren, was dazu führte, dass tatsächlich nicht nur medial, sondern auch real eine Willkommenskultur vorhanden war, die man nun bis dann irgendwann das kippte und man dann auch medial wieder in eine andere Richtung gegangen ist. Und deswegen halte ich also diese postdemokratische Diagnose von Colin Crouch nach wie vor richtig. Sie wird nur vermischt dann noch mit einem Populismus, der glaube ich ganz einfach auf den Punkt zu bringen ist, der von einem nationalen Wir ausgeht, das sich abgrenzt von den anderen.
Genau, das ist sozusagen die eine innerliche Pointe, die sich so ein bisschen nicht ganz mit dem Buch deckt. Zumindest hätte man sich eine andere Argumentation vorher gewünscht, nämlich, ah ja, es war schon immer schief. Nur jetzt haben diejenigen, die sagen, die Politik ist irgendwie dysfunktional für mich, es macht gar keinen Unterschied ob ich wähle. Jetzt haben die halt ein Angebot, wo kommt das denn her? Ja, aber das Phänomen ist nicht neu. Es war nur die Unzufriedenheit hatte andere Wege gesucht. Und das finde ich aber besonders interessant, dass wir jetzt mit Friedrich Merz jemanden haben, der bei seinem Parteitag auf der Bühne steht und sagt, lassen sie mich versichern, wir machen die Grenzen zu und es wird niemals mit uns eine Vermögens- oder Änderung der Erbschaftssteuer geben. Also es ist wirklich in allen drei Punkten genau gegen diese Interessen von Leuten, die schon immer sagten, das ist irgendwie dysfunktional. Also ich habe nur 1000 Euro im Monat übrig und jetzt sitzt auch noch ein wunderen Flüchtling neben mir, der das ganze Geld geschenkt bekommt, also das 1 plus 1 ergibt auch für diese Leute 2. So und jetzt macht er einen Punkt, der eben wieder diese Medialesphäre nochmal betrifft und die auch in dem Buch so nicht greifbar widerspiegelt. Wenn man doch feststellt, am Ende beim Schreiben, dass man auf so eine Poarte hinausläuft, muss man sich die Zeit nochmal nehmen und fragen, warum habe ich das Gefühl, das passt nicht zu meinem eigenen Text? Wo habe ich hier selbst die Lücken? So, und der Satz hier lautet, nachdem die großen Populisten einmal durchgegangen sind, was Berlusconi, Johnson, also Boris Johnson und auch Trump aber gemeinsam haben. Und jetzt Doppelpunkt. Sie hören ihren Wählern nicht zu. Sie vertreten ihre Lügen und Halbverheiten mit einer Leidenschaft, die offenbar viele Menschen überzeugt. Diese Leidenschaft geht vielen etablierten Politikern ab. Ja. So wenig wie wir hinter die formalen demokratischen Prinzipien gehen können, können wir auch hinter gegen, also hinter diesen völlig absurden Satz, den ich schon häufiger gesagt habe gehen, es muss auch Spaß machen. Es muss Spaß machen. So und wenn es keinen Spaß macht, ist es offenbar scheiße. Warum soll man sich damit befassen? Junge Menschen kommen aus der Schule, leiden darunter, was sie in der Schule, still sitzen, der ganze Scheiß an der Tafel wird in langsam geschrieben und es ist alles, man will alle drei Sekunden ein neues Video und so weiter. Diese Menschen leiden und die gucken dann die Podcasts, die ihnen Spaß machen. Wir können das nachher bei Bloomberg, in dieser Auswertung. Man hört gerne einen Podcast, in dem über die eigenen Themen gesprochen werden. Die Handball-WM, die Pokémon-Karten, Fußball, was auch immer. Und ja, jeder siebte Gast ist dann mal ein Politiker und was? Ah, der bringt Spaß mit, der macht Spaß.
JD Vans und Donald Trump sind so nicht unterhaltsam mit diesem Podcast.
Genau, genau. Wo ist das Problem? Warum sehe ich bei Karim Jorska nur irgendwelche Politiker, die sich jeden Satz dreimal im Kopf und Scholz braucht irgendwie sieben Sekunden, um zu überlegen, damit er niemanden auf die Füße tritt und so. Hau doch einfach raus. Und wenn die einfache Wahrheit, die man raushaut ist, ich weiß echt nicht, was der volkswirtschaftliche Vorteil von Milliardären ist, dann ist es halt so. Dann kann man halt gegen diesen Satz erst mal nicht zurück. So und das ist jetzt einer, der mir gefällt. Es gibt auch sehr viele Sätze, die sehr viel Spaß machen, auszudrücken, die mir nicht gefallen. Und die akzeptiere ich dann trotzdem sehr viel lieber, als wenn Olaf Scholz noch mal über drei Ecken eine Nichtverneinung und dann und soll man selber wissen, ja, dann brauche ich Robin Alexander, der mir das heute viel mehr erklärt in seinem Podcast, statt selber eine Meinung und eine Kolumnenhaftige, sondern nee, wir werden eigentlich immer kleinteilig erklären und so. Das ist doch alles totaler Quatsch.
Das heißt doch für uns, auch wenn wir jetzt unseriös klingen, dass wir zur Rettung der liberalen Demokratie eigentlich eine gute Launeoffensive brauchen. Absolut.
Olaf Scholz Büttenrede gestern war vielleicht das Wichtigste die vergangenen Wochen. Er hat versucht, eine Büttenrede zu halten. Wir können jetzt entscheiden, ist das jemand, den wir, selbst wenn es ihm misslingt, kann es ja darin wieder ein Witz liegen. Ja. Finden wir es unterhaltsam. Ich fand es sehr unterhaltsam, weil es war so trocken vorgetragen, dass man sich denkt, ein Politiker der nicht mal das schafft, bringt schon wieder so viel Humor mit, dass ich ihm glaube, wenn Friedrich Merz ihm unterstellt, da war so eine Sitzung in Europa und du hast gesagt, nee ich sag jetzt hier nichts, dann kam der andere, ich sag doch mal was, du sagst doch auch nichts. Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder wir finden das super amüsant, weil wir uns genau vorstellen können, dass das so abläuft, er und Sorkin würde uns The Rest Wing genauso schreiben, wir würden das sehen und sagen, es tut mir sehr leid, dass die da sitzen müssen und abwarten müssen bis sie und dann wollen sie doch nichts sagen und so. Oder wir stellen uns wie Friedrich Merz im Bundestag sagen, es ist eine Schande, wie sie uns in Europa vertreten, es beschämt uns Deutsche alle und so weiter. Da denke ich mir, ne, Friedrich, das beschämt nicht, dass du so ein Popanz daraus machst. Es muss jetzt wieder Spaß machen. Ich will jetzt nicht hier Tyranny des März und so weiter haben. In der Hinsicht eigentlich alles super klar. Warum hat sich das Buch da so verirrt? Also warum kriege ich jetzt noch eine Montesquieu-Geschichte, obwohl es mir doch eigentlich in der Poarte passen. Leidenschaft, bitte einfach sagen, was man denkt. Und die Leute mit ihren eigenen Interessen nicht aus dem Blick verlieren. Wo ist das Problem?
Ich glaube, dass das Buch da einen wichtigen Beitrag leistet, wo es diese plumpe Auffassung oder wie er es nennt, vulgär Demokratie kritisiert und sagt, wenn gewählt wird formal, dann muss das doch reichen und dann ist das der Wählerwille und das ist alles schon richtig. Das ist Demokratie, das ist ja etwas, was wir jetzt auch von Harald Schmidt beispielsweise, immer wenn er angesprochen wurde, auf die AfD gehört haben. So einfach kann man es sich tatsächlich nicht machen. Aber ich warne auch davon, ich finde da hat das Buch den ein oder anderen blinden Fleck, dass man jetzt Einhegungen des Wählers und der Meinungsfreiheit und der sonstigen Pluralität so sehr vornimmt, dass man zwar immer sich auf die Seite der liberalen Demokratie damit stellt, man aber eigentlich damit das Liberale dieser liberalen Demokratie sehr, sehr stark beschneidet. Also in diesem Zentrismus, der hier gewählt wird, irgendwie in der Mitte, da finden wir uns wieder in der Akzeptanz dieser Institutionen. In dieser Mitte steckt auch ganz schön viel Exklusion und das sollte man nicht übersehen.
So ist es.
Der Wähler hat immer recht, egal wie er entscheidet. Wenn die AfD gewählt wird, dann ist es eben so. Können wir uns damit zufrieden geben oder muss die liberale Demokratie noch einmal anders geschützt werden? Muss sie vor dem Wähler beschützt werden? Das fragt der Zeitjournalist Marc Schieritz in seinem Buch Zu dumm für die Demokratie. Er hat einige Antworten parat, aber wir haben im Salon auch sehr viele Fragen an dieses Buch.
Ja zum Beispiel zu dumm für die Demokratie, selten war ja ein Titel so anregend. Wer denn? Jetzt hast du schon auf die Wähler abgestellt. Dieses Buch ist nicht sehr dick. Jetzt kann man drüber erzählen. Könnte man auch die Politiker zu dumm für die Demokratie oder die Journalisten zu dumm für die Demokratie. Wir haben also Fragen, die das Buch beantwortet, Fragen, die das Buch nicht stellt, die wir aber dafür stellen und beantworten.
Wir möchten, bevor wir jetzt zu unseren Empfehlungen kommen, den Termin für den Sommersalon bekannt geben. Dieser Sommersalon wird wieder im Großen Saal stattfinden. 800 Leute passen rein. Es wird aber diesmal etwas anders sein. Wir machen also erst Salonprogramm und werden dazwischen oder am Ende, mal sehen, wie wir das dramaturgisch aufbauen, Publikumsfragen beantworten. Diese Publikumsfragen werden, wir orientieren uns da an dem Erfolgsformat INAs Nacht, auf Bierdecke geschrieben. Dadurch können die Fragen nicht so lang sein. Wir können also viele Fragen beantworten.
Wenn die dann zu uns geworfen werden.
Na, wir müssen dann sehen, wie wir das machen. Vielleicht muss auch manches vorsortiert werden.
Werfen und nur die, die die Bühne erreichen, werden auch gelesen.
Vielleicht denken uns was schöneres aus. Jedenfalls werden wir also auch Publikumsfragen beantworten, aber jetzt nicht stundenlang, sondern wir wollen aber auch ein bisschen Interaktion haben und sonst gibt es großes Salonshow-Programm. Ich hoffe Stefan wird da noch steppen und singen. Da werden wir ihn noch überreden. Schreibt mal in die Kommentare, dass ihr das alle sehen wollt. Jedenfalls den Termin wollen wir jetzt bekannt geben. Das ist der 23. August und man kommt aber jetzt anders an Karten. Man schreibt jetzt nicht Mustafa eine E-Mail dafür, das ist für die anderen Live-Sanons, für den Sommersonon. Kann man direkt im Saalplan buchen? Stefan, wie geht das?
Ihr geht auf die Show Notes zu diesem Podcast. Da ist ein Link, der führt euch auf die übliche Reservix-Seite, wo man einfach dem, weiß man eher wie man Karten kauft. Also in dem Fall keine E-Mails schicken oder so, sondern da sucht man sich seinen Platz aus. Das sind ja nummerierte Plätze und bucht dann.
Dann kommen wir jetzt zur ersten Empfehlung. Die Schriftstellerin Simon Gommery hat ein Buch geschrieben, das den Titel trägt Das Geschenk des Colipris. Sie hat auch bereits ein Buch, das ich allerdings nicht gelesen habe, über Oktopusse geschrieben. Und welche wunderbare Tiere das sind. Colipris sind auch hochinteressante Tiere. Und zwar sind sie, wie alle sich denken können, ja sehr klein. Sie schreibt, Es gibt hunderte von Colipriaten. Ihr Lebensraum beschränkt sich auf Nord- und Südamerika sowie die Karibik. Unter den Colipris findet man die kleinste Vogelart überhaupt. Der Hummelcolipri, der nur noch auf Kuba vorkommt, misst samt Schnabel und Schwanzfeder nur 6 cm und wiegt ausgewachsen zwischen 1,6 und 2 Gramm. Der Riesencolipri lebt an der Westküste Südamerikas, ist mit etwa 22 cm Länge der größte Vertreter der Familie und kann bis zu 24 Gramm wiegen.
Schwergewicht.
Ja, das ist also...
Wie viel Prozent an Tagesdosis ist das?
Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig zu lesen, wenn mir das nicht so klar war. Ich will das aber erst rahmen. Es ist so, dass sie Kontakt hat mit einer Frau, die sich sehr für den Tierschutz einsetzt und vor allem für die Aufzucht von Colipris. Und sie bekommt von dieser Brenda heißt die eine Nachricht. Sie soll doch bitte nach Kalifornien kommen. Sie habe zwei Colipri-Jungen, bei denen unklar ist, ob die überleben können. Die sind sehr schwach und sie müssen irgendwie versuchen, diese beiden Tierchen aufzupeppeln, dass sie überleben. Das ist sehr kompliziert. Colipris müssen, wenn sie jung sind, Fruchtfliegen bekommen. Man muss also erst einmal Fruchtfliegen einsammeln gehen und man muss sie, Achtung, im 20-Minuten-Takt füttern. Man darf ihnen nur ganz wenig geben, aber so viel, dass sie nicht verhungern. Wenn man ihnen zu viel gibt, dann drohen sie zu platzen. Wenn man ihnen zu wenig gibt, drohen sie zu verhungern. Diese Colipris können aber auch befallen werden, zum Beispiel von Milben. Das passiert dann da. Wie bekommt man diese Milben wieder los? Denn wenn man da so ein bisschen an die Fähnungen geht, man zerdrückt die Vögel. Wir haben jetzt gerade gehört, das sind ein paar Gramm.
Ein Gramm.
Ja, also es ist so unglaublich. Und sie schildert diese Tage wochenlange Arbeit, um diese beiden Jungtiere aufzupeppeln, bis sie dann irgendwann Flüge werden. Allein das zu lesen ist schon beeindruckend, was Menschen machen für den Tierschutz. Aber man erfährt auch dabei so viel über diese ganz besonderen Vögel. Sie schreibt, ihre Zartheit ist der Preis, den die Colibris für ihre unvergleichlichen Flugfähigkeiten zahlen. Sie sind die einzigen Vögel, die schweben, rückwärts und sogar kopfüber fliegen können. Sie sind zwar klein, aber unglaublich schnell. Um ein Weibchen zu beeindrucken, kann sich ein menschlicher Alenkolibri mit 100 Stundenkilometern aus der Luft stürzen. Aus einer Höhe von 15 Metern erreicht er eine Geschwindigkeit von über 18 Metern pro Sekunde. Und wenn er sich aus dem Sturzflug abfängt, wirkt das neunfache der Schwerkraft auf ihn ein. Im Verhältnis zur Körperlänge ist der Alenkolibri der schnellste Vogel der Welt. Mit einer Sturzfluggeschwindigkeit von 385 Körperlängen pro Sekunde übertrifft der Kolibri den Wanderfalken. Die Flügel der Kolibris schlagen mit einer Geschwindigkeit, durch die sie für das menschliche Auge verschwimmen, nämlich 60 Mal pro Sekunde. Dann haben sie natürlich auch viele Feinde. Falken, Krähen, Waschbeeren, sogar Libellen machen sich manchmal an Kolibrisen.
Libellen?
Ja, Barsche springen aus Teilchen, um sie mit einem Haps zu verschlingen. Feuerameisen und Wespen töten die Jungen im Nest mit ihrem Biss oder Stich. Erwachsene Exemplare werden von Disteln aufgespießt, von plötzlichen Frosteinbrüchen erwischt. Nun ist es so, dass aber auch die Kolibris selbst sehr, sehr gemein sind. Also man hat hier kein Buch, das jetzt einfach sagt, diese schöne Natur, wir verklären sie, Frau Lenz, sondern hier wird auch gezeigt, was für ein Hauen und Stechen da vor sich geht. Mit Nadelspitzen-Schnäbeln kämpfen die Männchen um Nahrung und potenzielle Partnerinnen, doch die unterlegenen Rivalen sterben nicht an ihren Verletzungen. Sie verhungern, weil die Sieger sie von den Nektarquellen verjagen. Das heißt die Kolipries und das ist dann auch das Problem bei den Jungen, wie kann man die irgendwie schützen? Man muss ja irgendwann sie auch loslassen und zugleich sind da direkt andere Kolipries, die nicht wollen, dass sie da auch an irgendwelche Blüten gehen. Ja und dadurch wirklich viele Kolipries verhungern durch diese Rivalität. Das wird also in aller Klarheit hier auch benannt. Milben habe ich schon gesagt, sind ein ganz großes Problem. Es sind unglaubliche Zahlen, die man dort lesen kann. Das Herz eines Kolipries macht 2,5 Prozent des gesamten Körpergewichts aus. Die Flugmuskeln 35 Prozent des Körpergewichts. Kolipries haben einen sehr reigen Herzschlag, 500 Herzschläge in der Minute. Sie können bis zu eine Stunde in der Luft schweben. Sie können sehr weit fliegen, von Mexiko bis nach Alaska.
Echt?
Ja, also ich bin so fasziniert, dass es so etwas gibt. Also ich würde jetzt unbedingt gern mal Kolipries sehen. Ich hab noch nie live einen Kolipries gesehen. Ich bin sehr fasziniert von diesem Buch auch, weil es ja ohne zu sehr zu romantisieren, doch irgendwie diesen Hoffnungsschimmer macht, dass es vielleicht doch auch ein sinnvolles Leben ist, sich um andere zu kümmern. Und sind es vielleicht auch Kolipries. Es ist wirklich ein sehr lehrreiches Buch, der sich sowieso ein bisschen für Natur interessiert. Wird hier einige Kuriositäten, aber auch wirkliche Erkenntnisse erfahren. Und es ist eine sehr hoffnungsmachende Geschichte. Denngleich man auch hier natürlich an den Sisyphos denken muss, dann ja, man kümmert sich, peppelt sie auf und so weiter. Und dann werden sie natürlich dieser so brutalen Natur ausgesetzt, wo sich am Ende jeder am nächsten ist. Also auch hier findet zwar streckenweise so eine Vermenschlichung fast statt. Sie überlegen dann auch, ist das eigentlich richtig, wenn wir als Menschen unseren Kolibris, die wir aufziehen, Namen geben. Aber dann geht es doch nicht so weit, dass man das verkitscht, sondern man führt es dann dahin zurück, wo es hingehört, in die Natur, diesen ganzen Diskurs. Und dort gibt es eben all das, was wir als menschliche Errungenschaften ansehen, Moralgerechtigkeit und so etwas. Das gibt es dort nicht. Aber es ist ein sehr schönes Buch. Das Geschenk des Kolibris bei Diogenes erschienen von Simon Gommery.
Sehr gut. Hat denn der Kolibri auch einen lateinischen Namen, der in diesem Buch genannt wird? Wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
Dann schließe ich direkt daran an mit einem lateinischen Namen, der dem Kolibri fremd bleibt und dem Oktopus auch, nämlich Sensus communis, das heißt also Gemeinsinn.
Und dieses Buch der beiden Assmanns, das zum Teil eben auch Postumens erschienen ist, also sozusagen als letztes großes Buch des Ehepaares gelten kann, behandelt diesen Gemeinsinn und es ist wirklich fasziniert. Viele Namen, die da drin genannt werden von Autoren, kennt man schon und es ist trotzdem eingewoben in eine nochmal Neubetrachtung, Erörterung von irgendwas. Also es ist wirklich ein Grundbegriff besetzendes Standard, soziale Standards, webendes und sehr weiterhelfendes Buch, das vor allem für Praktiker da ist. Also wer jetzt von Trump erschrocken ist und gegen März was tun möchte, muss dieses Buch lesen, um zu wissen, worum geht es überhaupt. Wollen wir uns jetzt wirklich verstricken in was ist eine Aufforderung an die Regierung, die als wie auch immer Beschluss und so weiter, das kann man ja alles machen. Das sind sozusagen die Erklärsachen für Robin Alexander. Wir wollen jetzt die richtigen Sachen wissen. Und wir erfahren zum Beispiel die ganzen Grundlagen, also historische Wurzeln von Gemeinsinn bei Aristoteles, Cicero, Kant, Gedanken eines sechsten Sinns, eines gemeinsamen Verstandes und daraus abgeleitet sozialer Verantwortung. Damit sind dann eingerahmt Erörterungen aller modernen Herausforderungen, die wir so haben in unserer stark diversifizierten Gesellschaft, die wir natürlich trotzdem als Gesellschaft lebendig halten wollen. Und da sieht man schon Gemeinsinn und Gesellschaft, also die Brückenschläge wird alles erklärt. Wir haben Beispiele und Kontexte, also wir haben die Corona-Pandemie, wir haben die politischen Debatten zur AfD, Populismus allgemein, was ist Identitätspolitik, historische Extreme, auf die kommen wir jetzt zu sprechen. Karl Schmidt natürlich, das NS-Regime, also da wo Zivilisation bricht. Was ist damit eigentlich gemeint? Und ich will mal aus diesem ganzen super Sammelbecken von allem ein Bogen spannen aus drei Textstücken, die finde ich, weil wir jetzt auch Diskussion geführt haben, zusammengehören und es beginnt bei Karl Schmidt. Also Karl Schmidt ist der große Zivilisationsbrecher, zumindest der publizistische Begleiter. Er macht diese Kampfansage, wer Menschheit sagt, will lügen oder betrügen und darin steckt diese Überzeugung, dass Menschen ausschließlich als Teil von Kollektiven innerhalb klar begrenzter geografischer Räume existieren und denken. Wenn also ein, um es gleich mal zu aktualisieren, Afghane kommt und hier in Deutschland einen Menschen tötet, dann ist das ein Vergehen gegen die Gesellschaft selbst. Also wir sind hier sehr hart in so einem Karl Schmidtchen-Denken, wenn wir Friedrich Merz da folgen. Wir haben niemals einen Konsens zwischen Freund und Feind, weil Freund und Feind sind ja die beiden Bedingungsgrenzziehung, die sich gegenseitig brauchen oder der Freund braucht den Feind, um zu erklären, wer sind hier eigentlich meine weiteren Freunde. Deswegen auch dieses, was ist ein Arier? Die Frage von damals. Naja, allein die Tatsache, dass er kein Nicht-Arier ist. Also die Grenzziehung ist super simpel.
Ja, für Karl Schmidt ist das ja die Voraussetzung des Politischen, das ist die Freund- und Feind-Unterscheidung. Und die Aßmanns schreiben quasi seit eh und je gegen Karl Schmidt an. Das ist interessant, dass sie das jetzt hier in diesem Buch noch einmal aufgreifen.
Ich bin ja zum Beispiel nicht so der allergrößte Leser dieser Literatur von damals, deswegen ist das für mich schon relativ neu, vor allem in dieser Deutlichkeit. Karl Schmidt versteht das deutsche Recht als Ordnung, das jüdische Recht als Regel. Große Unterschiede, also die einen definieren eine soziale Ordnung, die anderen Handlungsregeln. Die Parallelität zu heute ist eben ein Flüchtling kommt, greift jemanden an, wir alle fühlen uns angegriffen, in unserer Ordnung gestört. Hier muss jetzt nicht einfach nur kleine Anpassungen, sondern die Ordnung selbst muss wieder hergestellt werden, Grenze zu. Also dieses große Denken, da sieht man schon, okay, wir sind ja auf einem ganz falschen Trip. Aber wenn man das in diesem Kontext hier liest. Diese individuelle Bestrafung, hier fand ein Mord statt, findet also kollektive Konsequenzen in einer konsequenten Migrationspolitik. Das ist wirklich sehr dramatisch. Und wie weit man es treiben kann, schreiben Sie auch. Ich lese mal vor, wie die Asmanzer schreiben. Zum Irritierendsten und Abstoßensten an Schmitz denken gehört, dass für ihn die Bedrohung durch die Juden nach Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs noch nicht verschwunden war, auch nach 1945. Empfand er sich als Opfer eines providenziellen Feindes, der nicht aufhörte zu siegen. Denn wieder waren es für ihn die Juden, die nicht nur bei den Nürnberger Prozessen auf der Siegerseite triumfierten, sondern nach dem Holocaust der ganzen Welt ihre Moral aufzwangen. Während wir uns also ganz die ganze Zeit fragen, wo beginnt es? Wo war die Brandmauer? Was passiert hier gerade im Kleinen, wie auch immer? Was ist da nach der Wahl? Kann man ja auch mal darüber reden, wie weit lässt es sich treiben? Also selbst ein Holocaust ist dann kein Ende, sondern das ist nur ein Vorgeschiss in der Geschichte und schon wieder besiegt der Jude gegen uns und wir müssen uns verteidigen. Also in diesem Kontext muss man mal diese Anfänge betrachten. Das ist vielleicht nicht ganz verkehrt. Der Kampf, um den es geht, ist eine apokalyptische Schlacht um die Entscheidung, wer am Schluss den Endsieg davon trägt. Die deutschen Helden oder die jüdischen Händler? Das Alte oder das Neue Testament? Also deutlicher kann man, finde ich, gerade gar keine Kritik am gegenwärtigen politischen Diskurs schreiben als sowas. Gut, also wir haben jetzt Karl Schmidt im Hinterkopf, abgebucht in dieser Deutlichkeit und vehemenz. Nun Emanuel Kant, wir kennen natürlich alle, es geht hier um den kategorischen Imperativ. Mit seinem kategorischen Imperativ verfolgt Kant ein ganz anderes Ziel als die Mana der goldenen Regel. Wir fragen uns, ist nicht der kategorische Imperativ einfach nur eine schönere, klügere, kompliziertere Ausformulierung der goldenen Regel? Also die goldenen Regel lautet, was du nicht willst, was man dir tut, das fügt auch keinem anderen zu. Jetzt sagt Kant, mein Imperativ lautet, handle nur nach derjenigen Maxime, durch die du zugleich wollen kannst, dass sie ein allgemeines Gesetz werde. Sehr viel Konjunktiv, sehr viel Verallgemeinerung, sehr viel, wo ist denn eigentlich der andere, dem ich etwas zufüge oder der mir etwas zufügt, ah, der findet da schon gar nicht mehr statt. Das ist ja interessant. Also darum geht's hier. Der Unterschied hängt, Zitat, mit einer seiner Betonung der Autonomie und seiner Idee von Universalismus zusammen. Der zweite Vorschlag für eine Formulierung dieses Imperatives bei Kant lautet, handle so, dass du die Menschheit sowohl in deiner Person als in der Person eines jeden anderen jederzeit zugleich als Zweck niemals bloß als Mittel brauchst oder brauchest. Also wir haben den Anderen, der kommt noch irgendwie vor, aber nicht als Objekt, sondern als abgeleitetes Subjekt aus Menschheit, die auch ich bin. Ich bin der Anderen. Wird dann ganz viel diskutiert, es kommt auch Luhmann vor, Alter, der Ego und so weiter und so fort. So der kategorische Imperativ mag abstrakt klingen. Das ist er aber nicht, denn der richtet, denn er richtet sich an ein konkretes Gegenüber, dass dieser Punkt ist entscheidend als Repräsentant der Menschheit erkannt wird. Die Menschheit ist also keine vorrangige, vorgängige Einheit, sondern konstituiert sich erst im Prozess der Verallgemeinerung in dieser Form praktischer Anerkennung und Teilhabe in einer gemeinsamen Spezies. Wir haben uns das eben schon bei Max Schiritz, das ja auch diskutiert, sind es die Institutionen oder ist es der Mensch, der sie ausführt? Und dann haben wir Max Schiritz, der sagt, nee es ist der Mensch und dann kriegen wir trotzdem hundert Seiten lang die Institutionen und von was Montesquieu zur Gewaltenteilung sagt und so. Um dann am Ende wieder zu hören, es ist sogar die Leidenschaft des Menschen. Also diese, bei Max Schiritz sieht man sozusagen unausdiskutiert, hier geht es genau darum. So und jetzt haben wir also einen kategorischen Imperativ, der sozusagen als, ist jetzt komisch zu sagen Reaktion, aber sozusagen in widerspenstiger Geistigkeit zu diesem Karl Schmidtchen steht. Obwohl Karl Schmidt ja später und so, aber ist egal. Also wir haben hier zwei Denkangebote. Und jetzt haben wir ja Umri Böhm als einer von vielen, die hier diskutiert werden, der auch in diesem Buch vorkommt, also bei uns im Salon und hier im Buch. So und dieses Buch bei ihm heißt ja Radikaler Universalismus, Doppelpunkt, Jenseits von Identität.
Ja.
Wir haben also hier ein Universalismus, der nicht nur den anderen wie Balkant aus dem Bild nimmt, sondern auch noch mich. Niemand hat meine Identität. Also wir sind hier sozusagen im Gegenentwurf zu Karl Schmidt. Und jetzt haben wir ja Karl Schmidt schon gesagt, der hat sozusagen die Teufels-Itheologie mitgebracht, zur politischen Praxis. Ist das nicht also gut, wenn Ulrich Böhm jetzt einfach sagt, ne, kommt gar keine Identität mehr, nur noch Menschheit. Also der kategorische Imperativ ist Menschheit. Wir sind alle Menschen, ja, so irgendwie. So und jetzt diskutieren die das und das ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant. Nicht nur Ulrich Böhm, sondern auch Susan Neumann, also links ist nicht Vogue, wir haben es ja auch diskutiert, da wird ja auch dieser Binarität abgesprochen. Es gibt also bei ihr nur noch den Universalismus oder den Tribalismus.
So und jetzt heißt es hier Reinhard Kozelek hat ja damals von Zwangsalternativen gesprochen, die sehen wir hier auch. Also Universalismus und Identitätspolitik, Universalismus und Tribalismus ist hier eine Zwangsalternative im Denken, die wir bei Freund-Feind ablehnen und bei was ich dir antue und du mir auch. Kant hat sich sehr viel Mühe gegeben zu sagen, nee nicht der andere, sondern die Menschheit. So und jetzt kehrt aber genau diese strenge Unterscheidung zwischen dem einen oder dem anderen wieder, ohne dass wir einfach sagen können, nee die Tribalisten denken, die merzen wir aus. Wir müssen sie überzeugen irgendwie und wir stellen aber fest, das ist vielleicht eine überlebensgroße Aufgabe, jetzt irgendwelchen AfD-Wählern ihren Tribalismus auszutreiben. Vielleicht gibt es noch einen anderen Weg, der sich dann eben auch gegen Henri Böhm usw. richtet.
Was ja auch bei Habermas zu beobachten ist, dass er ja auch eine Binarität konstruiert hat, eine neue, nicht die von Karl Schmidt, aber eigentlich ist strukturell sein Denken, wenn er sagt, die gehören zum Diskurs dazu und die anderen gehören nicht dazu, schmiedianisch geprägt.
Ja.
Also aus der Binarität rauszukommen.
Genau.
Ich halte das für fast nicht möglich.
Ja, gut. Und deswegen gehen wir diese Argumentation mal durch. Also ich hab's jetzt mal so noch bisschen katalogisiert. Wir haben also unterschiedende Zwangsalternativen, Freund, Feind, wir, die, alter Ego, wie auch immer. Dann haben wir Gleichsetzende, was man dir tut, was anderen du antust. So, also man bleibt immer noch bei einer Zwangsunterscheidung, ich und der andere. Aber man versucht jetzt auf Handlungsbasis so praktische Tipps zu geben mit, nee, behandel dich mal gut, so wie du auch behandelt werden willst. Dann haben wir so definierende, arisch, nicht arisch. Oder eben moralische Unterscheidung, die offene Gesellschaft und die Gesinnungsgesellschaft, der Universalismus und der Identitätstribalismus. Jetzt schreiben die, man stellt nur zwei Dinge auf eine Weise als positiv und negativ einander gegenüber, die sicherstellt, dass sich beide Seiten gegenseitig ausschließen, sodass die absolute Geltung der einen Seite durch die radikale Abwertung der anderen Seite sichergestellt ist. Das Problem der Identitätspolitik beginnt damit, dass ihre radikalen Ausprägungen einer Logik des Entweder-oder folgen. Die Gegner der Identität sind sich mit den Bekennern von Identität in diesem Punkt einig, dass sich die Perspektiven von Partikularisten und Universalisten notwendig ausschließen müssen. Ist das aber wirklich der Fall? Es könnte ja sein, dass ein klarer Unterschied zwischen Universalismus und Identität besteht, aber kein intrinsischer Widerspruch. Die Identitäten an sich sind kein Problem, solange gewährleistet bleibt, dass man sich nicht für nur eine entscheiden muss oder auf nur eine festgelegt wird. Also das Problem ist natürlich, dass jemand ein Rassist ist und sagt, aber die Afghanen. Wenn ich dann daneben stehe und sage, na ja, die Nazis, dann hab ich ja genau das wieder aktualisiert, nur mit anderen Vorzeichen, um mich sozusagen im Widerspruch zu definieren. Und dann sag ich einfach, ich bin einfach ein Nicht-Area, so. Also wir verfangen uns da immer wieder. Kulturelle Pluralisierung ist kein Schaden für die Gesellschaft, sondern eröffnet neue Möglichkeiten der Kooperation, Beziehung und Solidarität. Und dann folgt im Buch ein großes Plädoyer für kulturellen Respekt, der Unterschiede betont, statt nur negiert und was Aktives ist. Also keine Toleranz, auch nicht als Plädoyer, jetzt sei doch mal tolerant, sondern nein, wir sind hier kulturell, wir spielen einen kulturellen Respekt aus. Was eben bedeutet, die Lehren, die ich jetzt mit ausziehe, alle Ausländer sind potenzielle Mörder, das ist ein Satz, den wir nicht teilen. Alle Fußballer sind dumm, würden wir auch nicht sagen. Alle Opernbesucher sind Edepität, würden wir auch nicht sagen. Alle Minderjährigen sind unmütig, mein nicht weder Thema. Alle FDPler sind egoistische Idioten, würden wir, dürfen wir jetzt auch nicht mehr sagen. Alle CDUler verraten ihre christlichen Werte, dürfen wir auch nicht so sagen. Alle Milliardäre sind asozial, darf man auch nicht mehr sagen. So, also wenn wir jetzt auf eine Praxis runterbrechen, was Böhm, Schmidt, wer auch immer kannt, diskutiert hat, dann haben wir bei der Zuschreibung von Merkmalen, die wir immer hoch dramatisieren auf Identitäten, dann verlieren wir aus dem Blick, dass diese Goffmännische, Luhmannsche Logik, nein, die Person an sich gibt es nicht. Sie wird in der Kommunikation hergestellt. Wir haben eine Fremdbeschreibung und eine Selbstbeschreibung. Und wenn wir feststellen, dass sich das nicht deckt, dann müssen wir das als Herausforderung sehen. Wenn also ein AfD-Wähler sagt, ich bin AfD-Wähler geworden, weil damals als es hieß, ich finde es nicht gut, dass meinem Kind die Turnhalle weggenommen wird, dann hieß es gleich, ich bin der Nazi. Dann ist das genau diesen Tribalismus, den wir aktualisieren, wenn wir ihm vorwerfen, ein Nazi zu sein, obwohl dieser Tribalismus gar nicht greift. Irgendwo steckt auch bei ihm ein universalistisches Gedankengut drin, dass man halt peu à peu aktualisieren muss, betonen muss. Große Aufgabe für die Medien, das zu finden, den kürzesten Weg zu gehen und so weiter. Für uns fällt es jetzt relativ leicht zu sagen, Friedrich Merz macht hier AfD-Politik, weil er sich das eine Thema rausgesucht hat, das er zu dem als aktuelles Thema in den Bundestag reingebracht hat, bei dem er ununterscheidbar ist mit der AfD. Und dann sagt Philipp Hopfen in seinem Podcast, aber wie irre ist das denn? Das ist doch die AfD-Politik, die du versuchst zu kopieren und jetzt machst du es sogar und sagst dann, aber nicht mit denen. Und diese Logik versteht keiner. Und umso mehr man jetzt Ross und Hopf hört, auch widerspenstig, umso mehr wird man von solchen Gemeinsinnlogiken, als, ja stimmt, wir müssen diesen kleinen Extraschritt gehen und sie machen es uns wirklich wahnsinnig einfach, weil sie auch Kahnemann, langsames Denken, kurzes Denken, also hier greifen wirklich einfache Heuristiken. Es ist nicht so, dass wir hier mega rausgefordert werden und Schmidt und Kant noch mal lesen müssen oder so, sondern manchmal sind es die einfachsten Logiken, die die kompliziertesten Probleme lösen. Eine Person ist immer mehr als das, was wir gerade feststellen, was sie uns zeigt. Und einfaches Denken, schnelles Denken. Einen kurzen Moment mehr nachgedacht und wir kommen zu anderen Schlüssen. Ich finde es sehr interessant, wie wir gerade Berichterstattung darüber kriegen, dass das, was Friedrich Merz angerichtet hat, tatsächlich einfach eine Kurzschlussreaktion war.
Ja.
Es gab keinen Bereich, weder seine Fraktion noch in irgendwelchen Privatwohnungen, wo er mal kurz reflektiert hat, was da stattfindet, sondern hat er im Fernsehen gesehen. Donald Trump hat eine große Ansage als am Tag 1 bin ich Diktator. Also hat er am Tag 1 mache ich das und dann hat er es nicht ausgehalten, wollte auf die Demokratie nicht warten, es war ihm zu langsam. Zack, also macht er das noch vor der Wahl. Eine Mehrheit hat er aber nicht, weil noch sehr nicht zum Kanzler gewährt werden. Der hat nur eine Mehrheit in der AfD gefunden. So, 1 plus 1 ist 2. Es ist einfach komplett bescheuertes Denken gewesen. Und dieses Buch zeigt uns nicht nur, wo die inhaltlichen sozusagen Ankerpunkte sind, an die man anarbeitet, sondern auch diese methodischen, diese praxisnahen, wie geht man damit um. Also wir haben hier, ich lese nur mal die Überschriften aus dem Praxiskapitel. Das heißt Helden und Heldinnen des Gemeinsinns. Japanische Fußballfans in Katar, versehrte Städte, Zweitzeugen und Stolpersteine, ein Denkmal für Flucht und Migration in Kassel, Tafeln in Deutschland, miteinander reden in Ostritz, also irgendein kleines Dorf, Menschenrechtsstädte, ein Menschenrecht auf Zukunft, Black Quantum Futurism und Althengstädt und Ostelsheim. Also wir haben es hier nicht mit hochtrabender Philosophie oder so, sondern wir haben es hier mit Praxiseinschlägen zu tun und wirklich sehr vielen Themen, die darüber hinaus, wenn man jetzt diese Orte nicht besucht, wir kriegen noch mal eine Erörterung des Streits und diesen Kipppunkt zwischen Streit auf der Suche nach guten Argumentationen und Konsens oder eben diese neue Klasse unversöhnlicher Streits. Wir kriegen ein Verhältnis von Rechtssystem und moralischer Kultur. Da kommt dann sehr viel Eva Illouz auch vor. Gefühle und die Zivilgesellschaft sowieso. Zum Thema Empathie will ich nochmal kurz vortragen. Ein Satz, der sozusagen Eva Illouz noch mal ein bisschen rettet, auch wenn sie jetzt sich natürlich auf andere Bücher beziehen als ihr aktuellstes. Denn die Literatur ist ein ausgedehntes Archiv für die Verbindung von Wissen und Emotionen, indem sie immer neue Kontexte für die Gewährung oder Verweigerung von Empathie schafft. Komplexe Erzählungen ermöglichen Identifikation und Empathie und stoßen damit das Interesse an den Lebensgeschichten anderer an. Dass sich also Eva Elous gesagt hat, okay, ich bin eine Soziologin, mache politische Soziologie und begebe mich jetzt ins Feld der Literatur, um etwas aufzudecken, was ansonsten schwierig, jedenfalls nicht in den Handbüchern der Geschichte zum politischen Denken abbildbar war, sondern man versucht nachzufühlen. Also du sagst jetzt Methodenkritik, okay, sie hat sozusagen falsch gelesen oder wie auch immer. Aber diesen Einschlag über die Literatur zu machen, also Jan Aßmann hätte wahrscheinlich sehr viel Spaß an diesem Buch gehabt, schon allein wegen Unschärfen. Man kann ja da auch anders fühlen. Sie hat das falsch interpretiert oder wie auch immer. Also dass da überhaupt ein Diskursraum eröffnet wird über unsere Geschichte des politischen Fühlens anhand der Literatur, die zeitgenössisch als Artefakt, Denk- und Fühlmal sozusagen Wegmeilensteine markieren. Das ist nicht ganz verkehrt. Der Liebesbegriff der Bibel, Liebe deinen Nächsten, Liebe Gott, gründe keine Familie. Das sind ja alles so krasse Fragen, die man alle mal diskutieren muss. Die werden hier diskutiert. Solidarität und Exklusion, radikale Ausschlusslogik und kultureller Respekt. Also es ist wirklich ein ganz, ganz, ganz wichtiges und hervorragendes Buch, das ich sehr gerne in dem Falle jetzt gehört habe. Aber ich werde es mir bestellen und als Schmöckerware auch vor Ort haben, weil hier kann man punktuell oder ganzheitlich an die Sache rangehen. Das ist wirklich eine große Empfehlung. Vor allem für praktische Wahlkämpfer. Und es ist noch ewig Zeit bis zur Bundestagswahl. Man schafft dieses Buch noch vorher zu lesen. Wenn man es jetzt kauft und liest, hat man in der Woche vor der Wahl noch die richtigen Fundamente parat, um richtig reinzuhauen.
Na das ist doch mein Versprechen. Ja. Wir kommen zur Ukraine. Bevor ich jetzt diesen Text von Peter Kurovtaev, der ist unabhängiger Journalist und Floodomir Ischenko, der ist wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter am Institut für Osteuropa-Studien der Freien Universität Berlin vorstelle, der bei Al-Jazeera erschienen ist, möchte ich dich fragen, was schätzt du, denn die Antwort findet man nicht in diesem Text, das hab ich anders nachgesehen, was schätzt du, wie viele deutsche Staatsbürger in der Ukraine kämpfen? Denn es gab ja den einen oder anderen Bericht und wir wissen, es ist nicht verboten als deutscher Staatsbürger, sich der Armee dort anzuschließen. Man kann da nicht mit irgendwelchen privat halb privaten Gruppen umlaufen, aber es ist nicht so restriktiv gehandhabt wie in der Schweiz. Das heißt also, wer jetzt sagt, ich muss da kämpfen, kann das schon tun. Was schätzt du, wie viel sind's?
2000.
Ja, könnte man denken, es gibt die genaue Zahlen nicht. Man hat beim MDR nachgefragt, also der MDR hat nachgefragt, wollte genaue Zahlen. Man hat beim Auswärtigen Ausschuss, beim Verteidigungsausschuss und so weiter Erkundigungen eingeholt. Man kann es nicht ganz genau sagen, man weiß aber definitiv, die Zahl ist zweistellig.
Das heißt... 2000 oder zweistellig?
Nein.
Nur zweistellig?
Also manche sagen es seien 18, manche sagen es seien 37, andere glauben es sind 90.
Weil es gab ganz viel getönt im Internet, dass man jetzt wohl mal und so...
Mit anderen Worten so gut wie niemand.
Naja.
Also zweistellig ist die Zahl. So und jetzt wissen wir also, es gibt ganz viele Menschen in Deutschland, die sagen, die sollen weiter kämpfen und die wollen auch weiter kämpfen. Wenn man sie fragt, würdest du denn auch kämpfen? Na ja, also jetzt gerade ist auch schlecht. Jetzt haben die beiden Autoren hier einen langen Artikel vorgelegt, der sich die Frage stellt, warum hat die Ukraine eigentlich Schwierigkeiten, Bürger für den Kampf zu mobilisieren. Es ist ja so, dass momentan Männer noch nicht rekrutiert werden, die unter 25 sind. Also da gibt es noch immer diese Probleme. Das Mobilisierungsgesetz ist da noch nicht so weit fortgeschritten, beziehungsweise es gibt hohen Druck der Amerikaner, das zu tun, dass auch die ganz Jungen ran müssen. Und man hat auch das natürlich schon herabgesetzt, das Alter, man hat auch die medizinischen Anforderungen abgesenkt. So ist es nun auch erlaubt, dass Männer, die HIV oder Tuberkulose haben, kämpfen. Und es gibt also einige ukrainische Beamte, die sagen, wir müssten das Alter sehr stark senken. Zelensky verweigert sich dem momentan, und es wird hier ganz klar ausgesprochen, wenn in einem langwierigen Konflikt massenhaft junge Männer geopfert werden, droht der Ukraine eine noch düstere Zukunft, in der der demografische Rückgang ihre Fähigkeit zum Wirtschaftlichen, sozialen und politischen Wiederaufbau untergräbt. Das heißt, man weiß natürlich, dass sehr viele nicht wiederkommen werden, die also wirklich Munition sind. Und deswegen ist man da etwas vorsichtig. So viel dazu, dass man da heroische Kämpfe führen kann, denn man wird wahrscheinlich sterben. Es ist so, dass sie sich jetzt fragen, naja, was ist denn eigentlich da los? Wer will denn kämpfen? Und da sprechen sie vom postsovietischen Gesellschaftsvertrag. Der besagte eigentlich für Ukraine, der Staat wird ihnen nicht helfen, aber im Gegenzug wird der Staat ihnen auch nicht schaden. Das war eigentlich das, worauf man sich verständigt hatte. Eigentlich so ein laissez faire Liberalismus. Wir passen auch ein bisschen auf das Eigentum auf, aber sonst ist Ruhe. Und jetzt aber plötzlich will man Gemeinsinn haben, will die Vaterlandstreue und so was. Und hat aber die ganze Zeit den Leuten gesagt, was habt ihr zu erwarten? Im Jahr 2021 vor dem Krieg, also belegte die Ukraine den achten Platz in der Rangliste der Länder mit den meisten internationalen Migranten. Mehr als 600.000 Ukrainer verließen das Land allein in diesem Jahr. Also es gab schon eine ganz große Abwanderung vor dem Krieg. Und das, weil die Lebensstandards nicht besonders toll waren. Wenn man das ja heute anspricht, kann man da Probleme bekommen. Aber diese Lebensstandards sind schlecht. Da kann man doch nicht sagen, ja die haben alle eine große Heimatliebe oder so. Nein, es ist auch völlig nachvollziehbar, dass die gehen. Das soll nämlich gerade auch von den Autoren hier nicht als Vorwurf formuliert sein. Was fand eigentlich hier statt? Der Staat hat angesichts der schwindenden Kriegsbegeisterung wenig unternommen, um seine Beziehung zu den Bürgern zu stärken. Stattdessen haben Regierungsbeamte die Bevölkerung mit Botschaften über Eigenständigkeit bombardiert. Im September 2023 forderte die Ministerin für Sozialpolitik die Bürger auf, nicht von Sozialleistungen abhängig zu bleiben, da dies sie zu Kindern mache. Sie schlug einen neuen Gesellschaftsvertrag vor, in dem die Bürger Kürzungen bei den Sozialausgaben akzeptieren und als Freischwimmer, so heißt das dann, unabhängig leben. Im September 2024 kündigte die Regierung an, dass sie den Mindestlohn und die Sozialversicherungsbeiträge im Jahr 2025 trotz einer Inflation von 12 Prozent nicht erhöhen werde. Also du kannst dich entscheiden, wirst du an der Front erschossen oder wirst du kapitalistisch ausgebeutet oder beides zusammen. Ich verstehe nicht, warum dieser Krieg im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes vollständig zu meinem Krieg werden sollte, wird hier ein Mann in der Ukraine zitiert. In einer Umfrage vom April 2024 haben nur 10 Prozent der Befragten angegeben, dass die meisten ihrer Verwandten bereit wären mobilisiert zu werden. Eine Umfrage im Juni ergab, dass nur 32 Prozent das neue Mobilisierungsgesetz vollständig oder teilweise unterstützen. 52 Prozent lehnen dieses Gesetz ab. Es gab eine weitere Umfrage. Nur 29 Prozent in der Ukraine halten es für beschämend, wenn man Wehrdienstverweigerer ist. Das heißt, die anderen finden das schon sehr vernünftig, das zu sein. Nur etwa ein Drittel der Bevölkerung befürwortet die Beibehaltung oder Verschärfung der Wehrpflicht. Das heißt, wir sind hier an einer eigenartigen Marke angekommen. Die Autoren sagen, wenn man sie fragt, wollen sie den Sieg der Ukraine und auch den totalen Sieg, dann sagen sie ja. Wenn sie gefragt werden, ob sie bereit wären ihr Leben dafür zu opfern, dann sagen sie eher nicht. Es sind wahnsinnige Zahlen. Bis zum Stichtag, also wir reden jetzt vom 17. Juli 24, hatten nur vier Millionen Männer bei den Einberufungsbehörden sich gemeldet. Sechs Millionen nicht. Die hätten das tun müssen durch das neue Mobilisierungsgesetz. Und von denjenigen, die ihre Daten eingegeben haben, gaben verschiedene Beamten an, dass 50 bis 70 oder 80 Prozent medizinische oder andere Gründe hatten, die es ihnen erlaubten, die Einberufung legal zu umgehen.
Also 60 Prozent melden sich gar nicht. Und von denen, die sich melden, sagen 70 Prozent, eigentlich will ich gar nicht. Ich will nur Bescheid sagen, dass ich nicht kann.
Ich bin krank und kann nicht richtig sehen und so weiter. Die Mobilisierungsbehörden heißt es, sie haben bisher Ermittlungen gegen 500.000 Männer wegen Wehrdienstentziehung eingeleitet.
Ja, daran sieht man, das wird noch eine harte Nuss für Hoss und Hopf. Denn sie sind ja erst in Stufe 1. In Stufe 3 werden die dann, wenn du dein Land liebst, wirst du es verteidigen.
Also das, was uns die ganze Zeit medial und von Politikern Ursula von der Leyen, die mutigen Ukrainer vorgegaukelt wird, ist wirklich etwas, was nicht mit der Realität sich deckt. Es wird ja ein Fall eines medizinischen Beamten genannt, der also da für sorgt zu gucken, wer ist dann krank und wer kann nicht und so. Bei der, da gab es einen kleinen Korruptionsfall, bei dem hat man im Schlafzimmer in Bar 6 Millionen Dollar gefunden. Weniger als zwei Wochen später berichteten ukrainische Medien, dass fast alle Staatsanwälte in der Region, in der dieser Mediziner tätig war, als behindert registriert wurden. Also sie konnten dann natürlich nicht kämpfen. Sie schildern hier verzweifelte Fluchtversuche über die Grenze von Ukrainern, die zum Teil Ertrinken, Entflüssen, die aber auch erschossen werden. Es sind vor allem Dorfbewohner, die quasi zwangsrekrutiert werden. Also da gibt es wenig andere Worte für. Sie schreiben hier Armeeeoffiziere beschweren sich oft über die schlechte Qualität dieser bussifizierten Truppen, wobei sich der Begriff auf die Kleinbusse bezieht, in die Männer im wehrfähigen Alter von der Straße gezerrt werden. Interessant ist dann Folgendes und das ist genau unser Diskurs. Wir haben ja immer so beobachtet unsere Maulhelden aus Twitter und Podcasts. Während die arme Landbevölkerung gezwungen wird, an der Front zu kämpfen, gibt es eine wohlhabende städtische Minderheit, die in Kiew und Lviv ein relativ geschütztes, komfortables Leben führt. Diese, in Anführungszeichen Kriegerelite, bestehende aus Aktivisten, Intellektuellen, Journalisten und Mitarbeitern von Nicht-Regierungsorganisationen, hält an der patriotischen Erzählung fest, dass die Ukraine bis zum Sieg kämpfen muss. Dennoch scheinen viele Mitglieder dieser Elite zu zögern, sich dem Kampf an vorderster Front anzuschließen. Es gab eine Reihe hochrangiger patriotischer Journalisten und Aktivisten, die zu einer Massenmobilisierung aufriefen, während sie selbst aus medizinischen oder anderen Gründen eine Befreiung anstrebten. Im Juni wurden den Mitarbeitern von 133 NGOs und Unternehmen, die ausländische Gelder erhalten, offiziell eine Befreiung von der Mobilisierung gewährt. Viele dieser Organisationen sind nicht an der Aufrechterhaltung einer kritischen Infrastruktur beteiligt. Also das ist wirklich ganz, ganz erstaunlich, wie man das geschafft hat. Und die blicken dann auf Dorfbewohner oder so, die sich nicht rekrutieren lassen wollen, dann als als die lethargischen, die faulen. Und wie können wir die überhaupt noch brauchen für unseren Kampf? Also da gibt es dann auch entsprechende Äußerungen. Die sind doch wie Vieh und diese ganzen Rentner und all das. Es ist wirklich dramatisch. Der Text endet mit folgenden Worten. Wir sprachen mit einem ukrainischen Mann in den 50ern, der seine Stadt in der Region Kharkiv nicht verlassen hat, selbst als die Front nur wenige Kilometer von ihr entfernt war und regelmäßig von den Russen beschossen wurde. Er hätte in einen sicheren Teil der Ukraine fliehen können, tat es aber nicht und blieb um zu helfen, indem er humanitäre Hilfe an seine Nachbarn verteilte. Er ist kein Feigling, er ist ein Patriot, aber wie er sagte, er ist nicht bereit für den Staat zu sterben, den wir jetzt haben. Nicht für diese Ukraine, die uns jetzt aufgezwungen wird. Das ist mein Land, aber das ist nicht mein Staat.
Also wenn es um Leben und Tod geht, hört ja Politik auf. Das ist ja der Unterschied zwischen Droh, Macht und Gewalt.
Ja.
Und dass wir in Deutschland immer noch nicht Wahlen haben wollen, dass man, wenn jemand mit einer Panikattacke vor einem steht, keine politische Diskussion führt, sondern ihm einfach helfen, wird noch für sehr lange eine Neuigkeit bleiben, so dass man das anders machen muss.
Ja, ich befürchte.
Es ist wirklich dramatisch. Auch dramatisch. Bloomberg hat jetzt die große Auswertung gemacht zu Wo fand der Wahlkampf statt? Ja, hab ich gelesen. Ich hab ja bei mir auf der Seite auch schon so einen kleinen Poantentext. Also mir geht es um diese Poantente. Ich werde sie gleich von meiner Seite vorlesen mit einem schlagkräftigen Zitat aus dem Originaltext. Dennoch kurz zu den Zahlen. Also es geht um 2000 YouTube-Videos der neun großen Kanäle, also Jorgen und Abwärts, um 1300 Stunden Videomaterial. Also 1300 Stunden, die direkt bei den Wählern ankamen. 1300 Stunden, also würden wir jetzt sagen neun Kanäle, was ist schon dabei? Neun YouTuber. 1300 Stunden, das ist schon ganz schön viel Angebot in der Hosentasche dafür, dass die Tagesschau in 15 Minuten geht.
Ja.
Pro Tag, ja.
Und alle Videos, die ausgewertet wurden, wurden mindestens mehr als eine Million mal geklickt.
Genau, man nimmt, genau, man hat in die Auswertung nicht alle Videos von den neun großen Kanälen, sondern nur die interessanten, also die eine gewisse Reichweiten-Schwelle überschritten haben. Nahezu 50 Prozent der US-Bevölkerung über zwölf Jahre ist monatlich dabei, einen Podcast zu hören. Über 90 Prozent der 18- bis 49-jährigen Erwachsenen nutzen YouTube. 75 Prozent der Teenager täglich. Also die Einflussschneise medial ist YouTube. YouTube hat mittlerweile auch Spotify und Apple als Podcast-Player überholt. Das ist wirklich die dominante Stelle. Das Gespräch von Trump, drei Stunden mit Joe Rogan, hat mehr als 50 Millionen Aufrufe erzielt. Trump hat mit seinen neuen Besuchen in diesen Podcasts 100 Millionen Aufrufe gehabt.
Und da reden wir jetzt ja nur von YouTube. Da ist ja noch nicht die Podcast-Auswertung.
Genau, das ist es. Nur YouTube, da kommt noch Spotify, Apple oben drauf und die mediale Berichterstattung drum herum, die da stattfand. Also das ist einfach eine…
Reactions, Clips ohne Ende.
Das ist absolute Dominanz. Also das ist einfach ein Aufmerksamkeitsspiel auf die Spitze getrieben. Allerdings, erstes großes Thema, das hier wird klarer genannt, wir haben es schon häufiger genannt, ist für die Zukunft wirklich entscheidend. 80 Prozent dieses Publikums sind männlich. Diese Jungs treffen auf eine Frauenwelt, in der sie erstmal nicht anschlussfähig sind, obwohl sie glauben, ich sag doch nur ganz normales Zeug.
Hat doch Joe Rogan auch was sagen zu tun.
Genau, da fällt man aus allen Wolken, Gesicht gegenseitig, wenn man dann plötzlich. Es gingen um insgesamt 903 Gastauftritte, die in diesen Videos stattfanden. Nur 106 davon von Frauen. Also nicht nur das Publikum, auch auf der Angebotsseite 12 Prozent sind Frauen. Wir haben es also hier mit einem nicht nur Medienwandel, sondern an sich schon mal mit einem medialen Ereignis zu tun, das wirklich bemerkenswert ist. Plus bei den Gästen ist noch zu sagen, 152 Personen tauchten in mehr als oder in mindestens zwei Podcasts auf. Erfolgreichster ist natürlich Donald Trump. An dritter Stelle liegt Tucker Carlson. Dann kommt Eden Musk und so weiter. An zweiter Stelle liegt Andrew Tate, der ein Auftrittsverbot hat bei YouTube, aber nur was eigene Kanäle angeht. Er kann natürlich als Gast woanders auftreten. Der zweiterfolgreichste ist eigentlich ein gesperrter Typ. Also so viel zu Plattformregulierung und so weiter. Es nützt gar nichts.
Der wegen Menschenhandel und so weiter verfolgt wird.
Es bringt nur noch mehr Attraktivität. Es ist vielleicht sogar kontraproduktiv. Der Text beginnt damit die Tatsache, dass Joe Rogan nur wenige Meter entfernt im Kapitol stand, während Größen wie Gouverneur von Florida Rontesentis nicht mal im Raum einen Platz zugewiesen bekommen haben. Sagt schon einiges über dieses neue Kräfteverhältnis. YouTube ist es also, bei YouTube zu sein, macht den großen Unterschied, inhaltlich. Wahlen und Wählen fand in 37 Prozent dieser Top-Videos das tragende Thema. Der Wahlbetrug von 2020 durfte wieder thematisiert werden. YouTube hatte seine Regeln entsprechend geändert. Krieg und Geopolitik 33 Prozent. Also man redet über die nächste Wahl und dann kommt sofort Krieg und Frieden. Während Gaza in Schutt und Asche gelegt wird und sich alle fragen, kann Biden da mal irgendwas sagen? Also das ist so die Gemengelange. Transgender-Themen, wir wissen, sehr viele gibt es eigentlich nicht. Es ist so ein bisschen wie, wie viel kämpfen da? Drei, so. 30 Prozent der Themensetzung. Also man redet die ganze Zeit über ein Thema, das es eigentlich faktisch so nicht gibt.
Ganz offensiv, immer in Verbindung dann gern mit Kindern. Dass man sagt, wie schützen wir unsere Kinder davor?
Genau. Und dann kommt Migration und dann erst Wirtschaft und Inflation. Also diese Legende, es sind die Eierpreise. Die Eierpreise sind jetzt noch mal gestiegen und die Zustimmung für Trump bleibt konstant hoch. Vielleicht sind es doch mehr, es geht hier um unsere Demokratie, wir verteidigen sie. Selbst 6. Januar und so, Stefan Lambi hat jetzt dieses Buch, wie sein Corsang, da mitstürmt und erst bei der Familienfeier mit Stefan Lambi im Gespräch, ah ne, also wir haben damals die Demokratie verteidigt. Wie das und so, ja. Und dann begibt sich Stefan Lambi erst mal auf diese Reise und die geht da mal diese Orte ab, wo man so denkt. Also die Wirtschaft und Inflation, stupid, ne, vielleicht sollte man jetzt mal umdenken.
Vielleicht ist dieses Gemeinsamthema und dieses Karl-Schmitzsche-Denken und so weiter, vielleicht ist es jetzt das, stupid, beziehungsweise lass es uns anders sagen, weil dann würden wir jetzt wieder, wir machen hier lauter Folgen und erzählen, wie wichtig das von Isabella Weber ist und jetzt sagen wir mal so, ich bin nicht ein Demokrat, aber vielleicht ist das doch nicht, doch ich glaube das es das ist, nur man muss es jetzt anders sehen. Wenn man sich, und das meinte ich in der regulären Folge, als sie sagt die Parteien sind so plank, wenn man sich die Wahlprogramme ansieht und auch weiß, wie Koalitionen dann sich bilden werden, dann ist wirtschaftspolitisch, es sei denn man ist sehr reich und hofft auf ein paar Erleichterungen, so gut wie nichts zu erwarten. Das heißt, die meisten Menschen werden wissen, dass eine Politik, die in diesem Rahmen die ganze Zeit agiert und eigentlich nur Standortpolitik machen will, eigentlich kaum Möglichkeiten sieht, etwas zu verbessern und sich dann auch mit den Kräften, die da noch sinnlich anlegen will. Also wissen die meisten Leute, dass sie da eh so gut wie nichts zu erwarten haben. Und dann sagen sie, aber Moment, Transgender-Toiletten könnte man verbieten, wen wähle ich da? Wenn ich dies und das noch will, was mache ich da? Und das ist genau das Problem. Deswegen ist also diese Diagnose von Isabella Weber richtig, wo man dann schauen muss, wie kommt man dann eigentlich zu einer handlungsfähigen Wirtschaftspolitik, die nicht dann am Ende doch wieder nur eine Standortpolitik ist, mit vielleicht einem kleinen grünen Vorzeichen oder sowas. Das wäre also wichtig, aber sonst ist natürlich genau das geboten. Guck dir das CDU-Programm an. Klägt die CDU irgendwas Sinnvolles für Familie und so weiter vor? Nee. Was könnten wir anbieten? Alle Grenzen dicht machen. Ah ja, genau.
Also es könnte durchaus sein, dass man das Thema Wirtschaft und Inflation von Platz fünf wieder auf Platz eins kriegt, wenn man dort als Publikum genauso viel Handlungsmöglichkeit sieht wie beim Thema Grenze zu.
Ja, ganz richtig.
Aber dann darf man halt nicht um den heißen Brei drum rum reden, sondern dann muss man auch an die Milliardäre ran. Genau, dann muss man einfach ran. So, Mark Zuckerberg wird hier zitiert. Es gibt diesen umfassenden Generationenwechsel bei den Menschen, denen zugehört wird. Was bedeutet, es gibt keinen Generationenabriss beim Thema Politik und Medien. Ja, die Leute fahren Slalom um deine Nachrichten, Elmar Thewesen. Aber sie interessieren sich wahnsinnig für Politik. Denn wenn Politik in diesem Podcast-Thema ist, schalten die Leute mehr ein. Allerdings haben diese Podcasts hohe Attraktivität, weil sie nicht nur über Politik reden. Die Gemengelage ist gar nicht so schwierig, aber gerade Joe Rogan, Kampfsport, gute Ernährung, irgendwas mit Medizin, keine Ahnung, Big Pharma und dann auch ein politisches Thema konkret auf die Wahlen bezogen. Die Leute sind sowieso schon fasziniert von den Alltagsthemen, weil da mal jemand normal mit ihnen redet, statt irgendwie ein Wikipedia-Artikel gerade zu schreiben oder ihnen Studienlagen vorzulegen. Und dann plötzlich reden die über Politik. So, Politik wird uns von allen Journalisten als ganz ganz wichtig betont. Also sagen die sich, wenn das ganz wichtig ist, schalte ich ein. Aber halt nicht da, wo die ganz ganz wichtigen Journalisten sitzen, sondern da wo man einfach mal locker vorm Hocker sagt, ich mag auch keine Ausländer, ich verstehe das gar nicht, warum die hier sind, sind wir nicht genug Amerikaner und so weiter und fort. Da wird einfach lockerflockig darüber hinweggesprochen. Was bedeutet, wir haben es hier wirklich mit erheblichen Folgen für den institutionellen Journalismus zu tun. Er ist, bei der Politik sehen wir jetzt, wie Elon Musk einfach alles abbaut. So wird auch der Journalismus gerade abgebaut oder hat sich selber abgebaut, wie auch immer. Und ich will mal aus dem Originaltext von Bloomberg übersetzt von GPT auf Deutsch vorlesen. Der einfachste Weg heutzutage Zuschauer zu gewinnen ist, sich Feinde zu machen, sagt Mike Mailek. Das ist ein Co-Moderator des Podcasts Impulsive. Dafür hören wir schon am Namen des Slogan Paul und so. Oder der andere. Also einer von den beiden Brüdern. Wir sind jetzt sozusagen im Inneren des neuen Inneren Mainstreams. Dann sagt er im Juli 2023, also die haben damals schon Bescheid gewusst, wie es geht. Ich stehe allein gegen den Rest der Welt. Ich bin der kleine Mann, der für das Richtige eintritt gegen die Konzerne, gegen die Gier der Regierung, gegen Chuck Schumer. Wenn Sie einen weißen Ritter suchen, dann schauen Sie zu mir. I'm your fucking guy. Das ist die neue Handlungsmaxime der zentralen Ansprechpartner für politische Themen der Jugendlichen und so weiter. Und da nützt es gar nichts gegen Pamphlete im öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk. Wir haben die Prampel nochmal überarbeitet. Jetzt muss Publikum zurückerwonnen werden und nicht durch Spielereien. Mein eigener Schluss aus diesem, ich zitiere jetzt mein eigener Text, meine eigene Prante. Hierin liegt ein Auftrag, aber ein, aber ein Hinweis, hier liegt kein Auftrag, also ich will ihn jetzt nicht so, Klaus Kleber muss nicht so oder seine Nachfolger, aber hierin liegt kein Auftrag, aber ein Hinweis an den Journalismus. Wenn man sich nicht getäuscht hat, sondern seinen eigenen Worten glaubt, dass das mit Trump keine gute Sache ist, muss man ihn und sein System, also die Regierung zum Feind erklären. Ja. Und es führt keinen Weg dran vorbei. Geht es noch irgendwelche Spaten-Diskussionen mit, oder Trump hat doch mal ein bisschen recht und so weiter, und ja ja wir sollten jetzt wirklich 3,5 Prozent irgendwas. No, wir haben es jetzt hier wirklich mit Trump zu tun.
Und das passiert ja interessanterweise nicht bislang.
Es ist schlimm, es ist wirklich nicht zu erzahlen.
Trump steht da und sagt, ich will auch Zölle gegen die EU.
Die Leute diskutieren jetzt, ob das mit Gaza eine gute Idee ist, machen Scherze, Gaza Lago und so.
Ja, es ist einfach. Ja ja und mit den Zöllen ist das wirklich interessant. Der sagt das und die europäische Antwort von Journalisten wie Politikern ist, ja mit China, da müssen wir wirklich mit den USA gemeinsam dagegen arbeiten. Da würde ich sagen nein. Ihr müsstet jetzt eigentlich an einen Punkt kommen, wo er sagt, wir müssen sehen, dass wir uns mit anderen ins Benehmen setzen, damit wir noch eine sinnvolle Handelspolitik machen können. Und damit wir dann sehen, dass Trump mit seiner Zollpolitik auf Dauer großen Schaden anrichtet und davon abrücken muss, während man sich jetzt versucht noch daran anzuschmiegen und lässt sich selbst auch noch Zölle aufbrummen.
Ja die Leute diskutieren jetzt das USAID, also 50 Milliarden für Entwicklungshilfe, dass das ja viele Hungersnöte auslösen wird. Und ich denke mir so, Leute ihr habt diskutiert, dass wir haben mal kurz kein Gas hier zu Mord und Totschlag und irgendwelchen, nee der Wirtschaftsminister, ich glaub ihm kein Wort mehr. Das kann ja wohl nicht sein, ich wähl jetzt AfD. Das geht nicht, dass wir hier auf zwei Prozent Wohlstand verzichten müssen. Es wird hier in Deutschland zu Hungersnöten kommen. Es wird große Mitleidenschaften in Europa geben. Also wenn so ein Zeug krieg erst mal aus, also das muss jetzt richtig, Trump ist jetzt unser Feind. Ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Aber man muss dann die Zensuren erkennen, alte Zöpfe abschneiden und in der Redaktion vielleicht mal mit ein paar jungen Leuten, vielleicht so ein paar mehr Praktikanten mal reinholen, um sich mal kurz den Kopf waschen zu lassen. Ja.
Und nebenbei Literatur lesen. Zum Beispiel den fabelhaften Erzählungsband Die Lage von Mesut Bayraktar erschienen im Autumnus Verlag. Autumnus kannte ich vorher gar nicht, haben jedenfalls diesen wunderbaren Band herausgegeben. Bayraktar ist ein Schriftsteller, der sich auf Ausbeutungsverhältnisse in seinen Erzählungen konzentriert. Das klingt jetzt aber sehr abstrakt. Er geht aber hinein ins volle Leben. Er zeigt uns mit seinen Erzählungen, zu welchen Bedingungen Menschen in Deutschland leben und arbeiten und welche Träume, Hoffnungen und Sehnsüchte sie haben. Da ist eine junge Studentin, die sich ihr Studium dadurch finanziert, dass sie am Abend Freier empfängt. Da ist eine Frau mit Migrationsgeschichte. Sie ist im kurdisch besiedelten Gebiet im Irak aufgewachsen, ist dann nach Deutschland gekommen. Die Ehe ist furchtbar mit dem Mann. Sie versucht sich mit einer Freundin aus dieser Welt hinaus zu begeben. Sie wird als Stripperin jobben und bekommt dann aber vom Amt gesagt, ja dann können wir sie nicht arbeitslos melden. Sie sind ja offenbar beschäftigt. Und man sieht, wie kalt eigentlich diese Gesetze sind, wo Menschen sich sehen, eigentlich ein besseres Leben zu haben. Es ist die Geschichte drin von Kai und Alex, zwei Brüder. Der eine strebt eine akademische Laufbahn an, der andere arbeitet in einem Betrieb und ist also ein Werktätiger, könnte man sagen. Der Bruder Kai kommt dann nach Hause. Alex ist noch einmal bei den Eltern zu Besuch und folgendes Gespräch findet dann statt. Der Bruder begann mit dem Vater über die Firma zu sprechen. In Alexs Ohren klangen diese Gespräche nicht selten so, als gehöre die Firma Kai und seinen Eltern, weil sie mit großer Anteilnahme über jedes Detail die Vorgänge und Aussichten im Betrieb sprachen. Insbesondere seit Kai kurz nach dem Beginn von Alexs Studium zum Teamleiter befördert wurde. Wenn das so weitergeht, wird die Firma bald schließen und das nur, weil die Leute faul sind und ihren Arbeitsplatz nicht schätzen. Die Zeiten sind sowieso mies. Über kurz oder lang muss die Firma Einsparungen machen. Da führt kein Weg dran vorbei. Das scheuchte Axel auf, der bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt auf den Fernseher gestartet hatte. Der Bruder fuhr fort, mir sind zehn Männer unterstellt. Der Abteilungsleiter verlangt von mir, dass ich bis zum Ende des Monats zwei Namen nenne. Das ist doch eine Schweinerei, wandte der Vater ein, dass sie dich mit reinziehen. Ja schon, ich bin nun einmal Teamleiter und das gehört auch zu meinem Job. Und was ist mit dem Betriebsrat oder der Gewerkschaft? Kai Lachter, der Betriebsrat, den kannst du vergessen. Die gucken nur, dass sie gemütlich auf ihrem Arsch sitzen und was die Gewerkschaft betrifft, die kann man erst recht in die Tonne kloppen. Die Sparpläne sind denen schon seit Langem bekannt und bis heute habe ich sie nicht einmal am Betriebstor gesehen. Und so geht das dann weiter, die Diskussion zwischen dem Vater und irgendwann mischt sich der Bruder ein, der ja Marx gelesen hat, der doch besser Bescheid weiß, der sagt, Faulheit ist jedenfalls nicht das Problem. Kai Lachter, du denkst, alles steht in deinen Büchern, oder? Bestimmt nicht alles, aber bevor du so urteilst, solltest du vielleicht mal in Büchern lesen und dann gibt es eine Auseinandersetzung zwischen den Brüdern, ein schlimmer Krach. Und natürlich hat Axel recht, aber Kai hat in gewisser Weise auch auf einer emotionalen Seite recht. Und von diesen Zerwürfnissen, die aber die Ausbeutungsverhältnisse selbst schaffen zwischen diesem Brüderpaar, erzählt diese wunderbare Geschichte. Es gibt eine Erzählung von einem Werktätigen, der morgens aus dem Haus geht und seine Frau weiß auch, dass heute ein wichtiger Tag ist, wo entschieden wird, wie wird es wohl weitergehen mit dem Betrieb? Wer muss gehen und wer darf bleiben, wird eher dazugehören. Und man sieht, wie natürlich mitunter zwischen den Kollegen eine Solidarität aufflammt, aber man auch hofft, nicht dazu zu gehören zu denen, die gehen müssen. Und mit welcher Präzision diese Erzählungen, diese Ausbeutungsverhältnisse schildern und auch zugleich analysieren, ohne dass das jetzt ein marxistischer Lesekreis wird, sondern wirklich auch eine literarische Erfahrung. Das ist ein besonderes Können, das dieser Schriftsteller an den Tag legt. Und es liegt auch daran, dass er sich immer wieder trotz dieser sehr harten und sehr schroffen Dialoge einer ungeheuer poetischen Sprache bedienen kann, auch einer sehr lustvollen Sprache. So beginnt eine Geschichte, die heißt Möwen auf der Brücke. Diese Nächte waren nichts als Zauber. In ihnen drehte sich das Rad der Zeit nicht, auch hielt die Zeit nicht an. Vielmehr fand das Fließen des Jetzt weiterhin statt. Aber das Namenlose war, dass das Fließen des Jetzt aus einem allbekannten Rahmen fiel und sich selbst überschritt. Es wurde zeitlos. Wir fassten gemeinsam die Weltgesamtheit im verdichtetem Moment ihrer Flüchtigkeit in ihrem kleinen Zimmer unter einer Dachschräge zusammen. Diese Nächte waren das Suchen nach dem Selbst in uns. Für einen Augenblick siegten wir lediglich für einen Augenblick über die Unmöglichkeit der menschlichen Begegnung. Dabei sollte ich ihr nur kurz etwas bringen und dann erzählt er eine Liebesgeschichte, von der man so hofft, dass sie gelingen möge. Also es sind wirklich ganz hervorragende Erzählungen. Ich habe das selten gehabt, dass so einzelne Erzählungen, einzelne Klassengegensätze, wie schon gesagt Ausbeutungssituationen so prägnant schildern und dabei aber auch so eine poetische Kraft haben, weil uns hier die Literatur auch zeigt, es gibt die Ökonomie und es gibt die entsprechenden Theorien dazu und das Leben ist aber auch so viel mehr und das ist nämlich der Sinn der Literatur, genau das zu zeigen. Also die Literatur muss da weiterschreiben, wo ein Karl Marx auch den Stift hingelegt hat, weil das dann nicht mehr sein Aufgabenbereich war. Insofern große Empfehlung, die Lage von Mesud bei Rakta.
Das rutscht jetzt rein in den Katalog und in das Archiv und die Enkelgeneration der Assmanns und der Eva Elous wird dann nachlesen, die damals gefühlt wurde, als Merz sagte, die Grenze muss jetzt zu.
Ja und die Gefühle sind nämlich auch ergreifend und groß und dieser Autor traut sich auch zu, pathetisch zu sein. Es ist hier nicht so, dass er denkt, naja ich schildere quasi kleine Leben, die in zwei Zimmerwohnungen stattfinden, deswegen müssen die Gefühle auch klein sein. Keineswegs die Gefühle können genauso groß sein, wie in dem Roman, dem Königsroman des 19. Jahrhunderts.
Deep Research Dossier über Wolfgang M. Schmidt. Ich habe also gepromptet einfach, so ein neues Angebot von GPT Dossiers zu erstellen.
Es klingt jetzt aber auch so ein bisschen, als würden mir jetzt so eine Akte nach jahrelanger Bespitzelung vorgelegt werden.
Naja, wir hatten ja dieses Gesetz recht auch vergessen durch dieses spanische Urteil von Google, weil Google ja Profile bildet. Das ist jetzt hier Profile im Quadrat.
Ja, ich hab regelrecht Angst.
Ja, also wir gehen einfach durch, was über dich im Internet bekannt ist und präsentieren auch so ein bisschen wie GPT, denn die Leute sind schon so ein bisschen beeindruckt. Also ich bin drauf gekommen, als Casey Newton so ein Text überschrieb, der auch eigentlich eher so kritisch und dann meinte aber in dem Fall, ja, das war ganz interessant. Also ich habe einfach gebrommt, ich brauche ein Dossier über meinen Podcastpartner Wolfgang M. Schmidt, suche im Internet, also geht die Webseite so durch, zeigt dann auch immer, wo er gerade so ist. Man hat also hier so einen Text, den habe ich jetzt unverändert übernommen. Also du siehst hier links, in dem klar wird, wo...
Ach, da wird direkt auf den Presseclub, in dem ich mal war, verlinkt.
Genau und du hast auch Fettungen in dem Text, die hat auch GPT gemacht, also Hervorhebung, sodass wir gleich ein bisschen durchfliegen können durch den Text, die jetzt nicht von mir sind. Und interessant ist, dass dann GPT, um dir zu zeigen, dass er die Aufgabenstellung verstanden hat, noch mal vier Rückfragen stellt, dann beantwortest du die noch mal und dann geht er sozusagen auf die Reise. Also ich werde ein detailliertes Dossier über Wolfgang M. Schmid erstellen, dass ich auf die Entwicklung seiner Denkweise und Themenschwerpunkte konzentriert. Dabei liegt der Fokus besonders auf seinem YouTube-Kanal, den er allerdings nicht lesen kann, also nur über den Kanal.
Ach so.
Das ist, da müsste man jetzt die Transkripte selbst zur Verfügung stellen. Gemini macht das ein bisschen anders bei Google, also da kann man sehr detailliert in YouTube-Videos suchen, auch Archivwassern.
Das wäre ja doch sehr erheblich.
Ja, das kommt jetzt.
Ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt jedes Video von mir mit die anderen rezipiert wird.
Genau. Ist aber noch auf Google beschränkt. Und so richtig propagieren tun sie es auch noch nicht, dass es so geht. Nun gut, also Wolfgang M. Schmidt Jr. ist oder hat sich in den letzten Jahren einen Ruf als scharfsinniger Kritiker an der Schnittstelle von Film, Gesellschaft und Politik erarbeitet. Ein Rufarbeit, genau.
Und bekannt wurde er vor allem durch seinen YouTube-Kanal die Film-Analyse seit 2011. Dort trittst du als kritischer Intellektueller auf mit Wohlstand für alle. Und die neun zwanziger hast du Podcasts, in denen du das Zeitgeschehen feststellst und Wirtschafts- und Kapitalismus-Themen behandelst. Du bist also jetzt positioniert mit den Kernthemen von Filmkritik, Kapitalismus-Kritik, Pop-Kultur. Ja, die Film-Analyse ist natürlich das zentrale Ding. Du inszenierst dich bewusst als Filmkritiker Alten Schule, der Film ganz ernst nimmt. Wird dir ja vorgehoben.
Ich vermute, dass das ein Artikel aus der Süddeutschen Zeitung, oder?
Hier steht filmkritik.de, aber je nachdem, wie das da im Internet so rumgeht. Was sagt dieser Film über unsere Gesellschaft aus? Ist eine Leitfrage, welche ideologischen Botschaften und propagandistischen Potenziale stecken in Blockbustern, Komödien oder auch Arthouse-Filmen? So, wir springen hier so ein bisschen. Schmidt scheut sich nicht, Theorien der Frankfurter Schule oder anderer großer Denker heranzuziehen.
Das steht ja sogar als Beschreibungstext auf meinem YouTube-Kanal.
Um Kopfkultur zu dechiffrieren. Also wir haben jetzt hier nichts mit Tiefstehenden, aber es ist sozusagen, es geht jetzt auch um die Treffsicherheit der Sachen, die es noch sieht. Wir kennen dich natürlich, aber jetzt für Unbekannte wäre das jetzt auch erstmal nicht verkehrt und man kriegt einen guten Überblick. So erinnert er beispielsweise daran, dass schon Siegfried Krakauer in den 1940er-Filmen als Film, in den 1940er-Jahren Filme als Spiegel der Massenpsychologie betrachtete. In diesem Sinne versteht Schmidt seine Filmanalyse als intellektuelle Pflichtübung. Populäre Phänomene verdienen es, mit derselben Tiefe analysiert zu werden wie klassische Hochkultur.
Und das wird auch in diesem Duktus verfasst.
Ich lese genau, also das war ein Wortwörtlich. Ja, ist das ganz gut. So, dann kommen so Entwicklung der Themenschwerpunkte vom Kino zum Kapitalismus-Kritiker. Mit der Zeit namens Schmidt verstärkt aktuelle Phänomene der Popkultur ins Visier, auch jenseits des klassischen Kinos. Ein Beispiel ist seine Beschäftigung mit der Influencer-Kultur. Da schwenkt also jetzt rum auf diese Thematisierung. 2023 erschien sogar ein 720-seitiges Kompendium, die Filmanalyse, Kino anders gedacht, das 120 seiner besten Analysen aus 12 Jahren versammelt. Ein Zeichen, wie viel Material und Substanz sich über die Zeit angesammelt hat. Also wirklich ganz gut. Ich überspringe so ein paar Schmid in etablierten Medien vom YouTube Studio in den Presseclub. So eine Zwischenüberschrift, die er gemacht hat.
Selbstständig so eine Zwischenüberschrift. Also das bedeutet ja die KI...
Ich hab nur das Gelbe gemacht, der Rest ist von...
Ah okay, das bedeutet ja... Weil das ist ja wirklich jetzt interessant, weil die KI eine klare Bewertung vornimmt, die ja sehr so einer öffentlichen Meinung auch klar zu Pass kommt, dass man sagt, also der Presseclub ist wichtiger, als wenn ich jetzt in fünf kleinen Filmpodcasts aufgetreten bin. Und dass das jetzt noch mal so mit einer Zwischenüberschrift hervorgehoben wird, ist ja doch erstaunlich, dass also diese KI eine Wirklichkeit des Presseclubs kennen muss, um zu sagen, okay, das ist aber wirklich jetzt so der Fernseholympo.
Genau, also es vollzieht unsere latenten Sinnstrukturen, wen wir was wichtig und so und nach. Also A, der Presseclub wird genannt, die Rheinische Post, TATS, Co, ist Wohlstand für alle, Experte für Wirtschaftspolitik, Sternstunde Philosophie kommt hier auch zum Thema Ich poste, also bin ich, Texte in der Neuen Zürcher Zeitung und Neues Deutschland, also sehr ausführlich, ich geh jetzt nur die Fettungen durch. Digitaler Wandel durchaus, Chancen, Herr Schmitz sieht selbst im digitalen Wandel durchaus Chancen, YouTube bot ihm eine Bühne, auf der intellecte Inhalte möglich sind, auch wenn sie kein Millionenpublikum erreichen. Das ist ja durchaus ein wichtiges Thema. Resonanz beim Publikum zwischen Begeisterung und Widerspruch. Was? Wolfgang M. Schmitz, klare Standpunkte und pointierte Analysen rufen starke Resonanz hervor im positiven wie im negativen Sinne, viele Fans schätzen ihn als ikonischsten Filmkritiker unserer Zeit, das ist ein Zitat, der filmischen Unterhaltung und gesellschaftlichen Theorie gekonnt verbindet. So, dann kommen so ein paar Stimmen. Solche Stimmen zeigen, dass Schmitz bei vielen als erfrischender kritischer Denker gilt, der den Zeitgeist hinterfragt. Seine Kombination aus Bissigkeit und Witz in der Analyse, etwa wenn er Marvel-Helden mit eitel selbstbewussten Politikern vergleicht, stößt auf Zustimmung, weil sie neue Denkanstöße liefert und dabei unterhält. Manche seiner treffenden Bonbons oder Vergleiche, Klammer auf, wie eben jener Marvel-Vergleich mit einem Wahlkämpfer, Klammer zu, verbreiten sich in sozialen Medien und tragen zu Schmitz Kultstatus in bestimmten Kreisen bei. Kontroversen sind Schmitz nicht fremd, einige halten ihm einen elitären oder herablassenden Ton vor.
Okay.
Tatsächlich wird Schmitz in traditionellen Fotos auch als zorniger, stolzer Verteidiger von Kulturwerten beschrieben.
Ich glaube, das war irgendwas in der Süddeutschen Untertitel.
Das ist Analyse und Kritik steht hier.
Ah, keine Ahnung.
Geh bitte, Wolfgang M. Schmitz, Junior AK, Analyse und Kritik. Also die wissen mehr über mich als ich auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ja, also die scheinen ja alles zu durchkämmen.
Vorwürfe, er verstecke reaktionäre Gedanken hinter linker Rhetorik, wurden laut als Schmitz 2021 ein Video über Diversitätsregeln bei YouTube Studios, Amazon Studios veröffentlicht. Darin warnt er überspitzt vor einem Ende der Schauspielkunst und bezeichnete die neuen Vorgaben als gefährliches Neusprech und so weiter und so fort. Das einzige, was mir hier auffällt, was ich mir markiert hab für einen Podcast, ist, dass die Präsentation bietet Schmidts Werdegang reichlich Erzählstoff vom YouTube-Pionier zum Podcast-Hos, vom Nischendasein zum Gast in der Tagesschau-Runde. Weiß ich jetzt nicht, da hat er mal einen Fehler gemacht.
Das gibt ja keine Tagesschau-Runde.
Genau, das wird irgendwie noch mal so ein Presseclub-Ding sein. Ja, ansonsten, es ist natürlich nicht sehr tiefgehend, aber für jemanden, der dich gar nicht kennt und das einfach liest, ist es gar nicht so verkehrt.
Das ist wirklich ganz erstaunlich. Also wenn ich jetzt bedenke, ich meine, das ist jetzt ein Spaß, der zu nichts führt, aber nehmen wir mal an, das würde jetzt bald eingesetzt werden von Assessment-Centern, um Leute einzustellen, also Dosiers wirklich über Leute zu machen. Wo das jetzt ja bei mir, also ich bin ja jetzt von Anfang an als öffentliche Person aufgetreten quasi, also ich hab ja nicht noch irgendwie private Profile unterhalten, die jetzt auch gescannt werden können. Das ist ja bei sehr vielen Leuten dann anders und was da jetzt die KI alles so hervorhebt in so einem Dossier, da muss einem ja eigentlich Angst und Bange werden. Also hier, das sind ja alles bekannte Quellen, sag ich mal, wo irgendwo drauf zugehört wird.
Die Fragestellung war ja auch, schreibe ein Dossier aus den Öffentlichen und so weiter.
Man kann ja wahrscheinlich da noch in ganz anderer Richtung weitergehen. Du wirst das mit dir ja auch mal gemacht haben.
Noch nicht, ich mach's nachher. Ich hab's gestern schnell gemacht.
Ja, weil das ja doch interessant ist. Also man kann jetzt sagen, das ist ja ein sehr fairer Umgang. So wie ich das jetzt so höre, scheint das ja so gut abgedeckt zu sein. Aber die Frage war natürlich auch so offen und fair gestellt. Aber ich frage mich halt, was passiert, wenn man diese Programme darauf trillt, dass sie mal versuchen, die heiklen Stellen herauszukommen. Und was wissen wir eigentlich noch nicht so ganz und so weiter. Und da eben bei Leuten, die jetzt nicht professionell im Internet immer nur tätig waren, sondern auch sonst einfach random irgendwas bei LinkedIn oder Twitter geschrieben haben.
Ja, also wir haben hier eine ganz interessante, wie soll man sagen, Analysemöglichkeit für in dem Fall jetzt öffentliche Daten. Entscheidend ist natürlich auch die Datengrundlage. So und ich möchte jetzt noch kurz anmerken, das wichtigste Thema für heute Morgen und die nächste Zeit ist Elon Musk. Elon Musk hat jetzt Zugang zu diesem Zahlungsverkehr Amerikas. Also alle staatlichen Überweisungen, das sind ungefähr so vier Milliarden, Billionen im Jahr oder so.
Versicherungsnummern.
Anzahl der Überweisungen. Versicherungsnummern haben wir zu lang. Also die ganze Datengrundlage des amerikanischen politischen Handelns, das sich in Geldströmen niederschlägt, ist jetzt angebunden an das größte Rechenzentrum der Welt, das dem reichsten Mann der Welt gehört. So und darin liegen Gefahren.
Ja.
Und der deutsche Journalismus muss jetzt von diesem Gaza-Lago und so weiter, das ist alles wirklich, das sind Nebelkerzen. Kann sein, dass in zehn Jahren irgendwann mal da ein Haus gebaut wird, auf dem Trump-Namen steht oder wie auch immer. Das wird dann die Geschichte schon zeigen und das kann man auch dann behandeln. Das ist sie wirklich gerade nicht das Thema, sondern das Thema ist Regierungshandeln, politische Praxis, das größte Rechenzentrum der Welt, also das von XAI, das Elon Musk allein gehört, das jetzt einfach als Datenfusionsreaktor und es ist völlig freie Hand. Also Trump hat eben alles eingeräumt und sorgt dafür, dass der Kongress dann nicht dazwischenfog.
Was ich mich jetzt frage bei diesen Dossiers, nun bin ich ja jemand, der im Internet zu finden ist als Person des öffentlichen Lebens, so wird das dann wahrscheinlich da auch für eine KI verständlich sein. Weil es Artikel über, also es war ja immer so, man hat früher ja sein Twitter-Profil verifizieren können, was ich nie gemacht habe, wenn man nachweisen konnte, dass man in der Presse schon mal vorgekommen ist. Also wenn man jetzt ein paar Artikel hat über einen, weil man weiß ich nicht, was den größten Fisch gefangen hat, dann konnte man sich verifizieren lassen. Jetzt ist es ja bei ganz vielen Leuten so, die sind eigentlich privat im Internet. Das heißt, die sind keine Person des öffentlichen Lebens.
Die Datenspur ist genauso.
Ja, würde die KI mir auch dafür ein Dossier machen? Das wäre jetzt meine Frage.
Dir nicht, Elon Musk schon.
Eben. Und das ist der Punkt, an wen wird das ausgeweitet, dass sowas dann möglich ist. Weil du könntest ja jetzt nicht einfach irgendeinen Namen nehmen von deiner Nachbarin und sagen mach mal ein Dossier. Dann würde da ja wahrscheinlich die KI sich dem verweigern. Aber die Daten dafür wären ja da.
Also das, was ich jetzt vorgelesen habe, kommt aus ungefähr 30 Quellen, die Kibiti angelaust hat und gelesen hat.
Aber das, was du jetzt, ich hab ja so ein paar Sachen da erkannt oder worauf da bezugenommen werden, das kriegt man ja auch zusammengegoogelt, man muss es beeindrucken, wie gut das zusammengeschrieben werden kann.
Und wir müssen uns dabei vorstellen, alle Transkripte aller Podcasts und aller YouTube-Videos, die du jemals gesagt hast, alle E-Mails, alles und dann so ein Dossier. Dauert fünf Minuten, dann ist das fertig geschrieben. Und dann weiß wirklich jeder Bescheid. Und das findet gerade in Amerika statt, als vom Präsidenten beauftragt ist, Klandestin ins Regierungshandeln.
Ja, unter dem Deckmantel, wir müssen die Bürokratie abschaffen.
Ja, also es ist wirklich bedenklich. Nicht gut.
Wir kommen ganz kurz nochmal zu Trump und Musk. Die haben ja vieles vor. Du sagst ja zu Recht, wir müssen uns darauf gerade konzentrieren. Ich glaube, das ist an sich auch richtig. Wir haben natürlich auch noch Platz für ein paar andere Gedanken zu Trump. Diese wurden sich gemacht in den Blättern. Dort hat Jennifer Stange, eine Historikerin, aufgeschrieben, was es mit dem Weltraumkolonialismus von Musk und Trump auf sich hat. Sie schreibt, das Schicksal der Vereinigten Staaten-Liga in den Sternen erklärte Trump bereits im Januar 2021 in seiner letzten Rede als 45. Präsident der USA. Er meinte das wörtlich und lobte sich selbst für die Gründung der US Space Force der ersten Weltraum-Armee. Diese sei eine, Zitat, monumentale Errungenschaft. Er hatte außerdem ein Dekret erlassen, wonach der Weltraum nicht länger globales Gemeingut, sondern Gebiet legitimer öffentlicher und privater Ressourcengewinnung sei. Und sie geht in diesem Artikel ein bisschen dieser Sache nach. Wie ist denn das eigentlich mit der Ausbeutung des Weltraums? Eigentlich ist es ja so, dass man versucht, immer diesen Weltraumvertrag, den es da gibt aus dem Jahr 1967, zu erweitern, zu erneuern. Aber es gestaltet sich alles sehr schwierig. Hinzu kommt ja, dass dieser alte Vertrag noch gar nicht enthält, dass private Unternehmen im Weltall tätig sind. Das hat man einfach nicht gedacht, dass das möglich sein wird. Das ist ja doch eine Weile her, als man darüber nachgedacht hat. Jetzt versucht man da so das eine oder andere zu unternehmen. Wir sehen hier zum Beispiel, dass die europäische Weltraumorganisation ESA versucht, private Unternehmen wie das von Elon Musk, also SpaceX, dazu zu bringen, eine Karte zu unterschreiben, die Zero Depress heißt. Sie zielt darauf ab, heißt es im Text von Stange, bis 2030 die Entstehung neuen Weltraummülls zu verhindern, soll aber auf Freiwilligkeit beruhen. Wir wissen ja, was da von dann zu halten ist. ESA-Generaldirektor Josef Aschenbacher betont, die Notwendigkeit private Akteure einzubeziehen, um die zunehmende Verschmutzung des erdnahen Raums durch private Satelliten wie die von Starlink zu bekämpfen. SpaceX betreibt mit Starlink eine der größten Satellitenflotten im niedrigen Erdorbit und dürfte schon heute einen nicht geringen Anteil an der Vermüllung der niedrigen Erdumlaufbahnen haben. Es ist so, dass Elon Musk und Trump eigentlich sich das jetzt zu Nutze machen können, was Barack Obama auf den Weg gebracht hat. Er stoppte 2010 das Constellation-Programm der NASA, das den Weg für neue Mond- und Marsmissionen ebnen sollte, jedoch als zu teuer und ineffizient gerät. Das ist eigentlich auch der Moment, in dem also diese private Weltraumnutzung und Forschung wichtiger wird. Dann im Jahr 2015 wieder Obama. Da gelang es der Obama-Administration ein Gesetz namens Commercial Space Lounge Competitiveness Act. Zuerst durch das von Republikanern geführte Repräsentantenhaus und dann den Senat zu bringen. Es liegt fest, dass alles, was ein US-Bürger von einem Asteroiden oder einem Planeten bergen kann, bergen Anführungszeichen, auch diesem US-Bürger gehört, genutzt und verkauft werden kann. Das heißt also Obama, wir hatten einmal, an einem der frühen Salons so ein Buch zum Weltraumrecht vorgestellt, da war das auch schon angesprochen. Also Obama hat diesen Weg geebnet und dann haben sich andere Staaten angeschlossen. Als erstes interessanterweise Luxemburg. Warum Luxemburg, denkt man? Sie schreibt es hier, naja, das ist der Sitz und Fondsstandort internationaler Banken, Versicherungsunternehmen, Vermögensverwaltern, Heimathafen für die Weltwirtschaft. 2020 gab es dann von der NASA initiiert Artemis Accords. Da strebt man nach bilateralen Vereinbarungen, wie man Mond und Mars nutzen kann. Und hat dort auch gesagt, naja, so eine kommerzielle Nutzung ist doch eigentlich gar kein Problem. Deutschland hat das auch 23 dann mit unterzeichnet, wusste ich auch überhaupt nicht. Der Weltraumvertrag verbietet zwar die nationale Aneignung, lässt aber Privatpersonen und Unternehmen unerwähnt. Das heißt also auch mit dem Weltraumvertrag jetzt, wie er ist, lässt sich natürlich vieles machen. Jeff Bezos kommt auch hier vor, äußert sich ähnlich. Beide versprechen, was auch immer uns auf der Erde bedroht, wir können davor ins Weltall entkommen. Bezos will mit seinem Unternehmen Blue Origin die industrielle Produktion und Millionen von Erdbewohnerinnen in erdnahe Lebensräume sogenannte Space Pots bringen. Denn ohne Zitat technologische und räumliche Expansion, so Bezos, werde das wirtschaftliche Wachstum und damit die gesamte Zivilisation zum Stillstand kommen. Elon Musk, natürlich noch verrückter, hat bereits sein eigenes Sperma einfrieren lassen, Zitat als Geschenk an die zukünftige Marsbevölkerung. Und man kann sich vorstellen, dass mit diesen Leuten schwer auszuhandeln ist, dass wir den Weltraum friedlich halten und müllfrei bekommen.
Du kennst ja auch diese Sendung Albert Carban, Altered Carban.
Nein.
Da die spielt auch so und so, ne? Science-Fiction-Future, irgendwas die Menschen, die es geschafft haben, leben auf irgendwelchen fünf Kilometer hohen Türmen so oben vor sich hin. Und unten ist der Mob. Und mit der Besonderheit, man kann seinen Körper wechseln, den Sleeve einfach wechseln. Das heißt, die Serie handelt davon, dass einer dieser Superreichen ermordet wird. Und dieser Superreiche engagiert an jemanden, der aufklärt, wer ihm den Sleeve, warum er jetzt einen neuen braucht und so, weißt du? Und da finde ich wird der Ton gut getroffen, was solche Szenarien angeht. Also die Zeit stellt neue Grundbegriffe vor, denn wir brauchen neue politische Grundbegriffe. Das ist natürlich super attraktiv zu lesen. Ich möchte zwei kurz und einen ausführlich vorstellen. Inselkonservativismus. Beschreibt die Politik von Friedrich Merz, der nämlich keinen Nomadenkonservativismus mehr macht, sondern eine feste unbewegliche Position einnimmt und dann hofft, dass jemand bei ihm anlandet. Inselkonservativismus.
Ganz egal, wer mit mir den Kompromiss teilt.
Klingt im Text so, der Konservativismus von Friedrich Merz ist sesshaft geworden. Die CDU unter Merz verbindet kein gemeinsamer Kontinent mit den anderen politischen Erdmassen, stattdessen schwimmt sie allein im Meinungsmeer. Reaktionärer Modernismus finde ich auch ganz gut. Damit ist gemeint, dieses mit Raketen in die Vergangenheit fliegen. Opfernationalismus kennen wir eigentlich soweit schon. Also hier wird ein Begriff vorgestellt, der nicht neu gefunden wird. Nun aber zu dem sechsten Begriff, der uns hier vorgestellt wird, nämlich Sichtbarkeitsregime. Und du betontst ja auch immer wieder die Meinungsfreiheit. Und hier wird das in einem interessanten Fall mal thematisiert. Es geht also um eine Bezeichnung für die private Kontrolle über Informationsflüsse in sozialen Medien durch wenige Akteure. Was zu unterscheiden ist von staatlicher Zensur. Und in diesem Textverlauf, der Text übrigens von Johannes Schneider heißt es dann, wie also soll man Phänomene nennen, die Zensur und Propaganda ähneln, aber sich nicht in staatlichen Institutionen, sondern in Sphären des Privaten vollziehen, also Sichtbarkeitsregime. Damit beschrieben ist ein autoritär strukturiertes Social-Media-Präsidenten zum Beispiel, also einfach so ein Chef von so einem Laden, der als Netzwerkbetreiber natürlich den Diskurs bestimmt, allein durch Überflutung mit Unrat. Also wir machen jetzt hier keine Kontrolle mehr, es darf alles gesagt werden und so. Ja, es sei jetzt ja erstmal, dass da relativ viel los ist dann. Damit gewinnt man eine Macht über Öffentlichkeit, weil man das Know-how der Öffentlichkeit, nämlich diese technischen Unterbauten, einfach unter seiner Kontrolle hat und auch weiß, wie sie funktionieren, anders als die Nutzer. Sehr wenige Personen entscheiden also darüber, was wahrgenommen wird. Genau das ist es, was das Sichtbarkeitsregime aus Bürgern am Ende des demokratischen Zeitalters wieder macht bzw. machen kann, untertanen. Auf einmal sind wir hoffnungslos vereinzelt, einer gemeinsamen Öffentlichkeit beraubt und damit auch der demokratischen Willensbildung. Also hier wird über Medien geredet, wie ich gerne das in ganzer Buchlänge hätte. Den Plattform-Betreibern kann niemand etwas nachweisen, schon gar nicht, dass sie bestimmte Meinungen mit politischen, im politischen System unsichtbar machen. Als kritische Öffentlichkeit ist man zum Raunen gezwungen. Äußere ich den Verdacht auf Manipulation, breche ich selbst die Regeln des faktenbasierten Diskurses. Ich verstumme also freiwillig. Und spätestens diese Spirale, die dann da ausgelöst wird, in die Selbstzensur, die krasseste Folge eines funktionierenden Sichtbarkeitsregimes, ist perfider als Zensur es je sein konnte.
Ja, Zensur ist ja dann auch wieder sehr transparent.
Also das ist sehr klug, Herr Schneider, lassen Sie sich doch von einem Verlag anrufen, um das nochmal auf 150 Seiten. Das ist jetzt das Thema der Stunde, finde ich.
Zum Schluss noch Musik. Wir alle kennen die vier Jahreszeiten von Vivaldi. Das sind vier Violinenkonzerte.
Endlich weiß ich mal wovon du sprichst.
Ja, jetzt wirst du sagen, aber die haben wir doch schon auf CD.
Die habe ich doch auch.
Tausendfach kann man sie doch überall hören. Und ja, das sollte man ja auch tun. Es gibt ganz viele verschiedene Einspielungen und viele davon haben ihre Berechtigung. Jetzt kommt eine Neueinspielung dazu, die es in sich hat, die faszinierend großartig ist. Ich bin nicht überrascht davon, denn ich habe die Musiker schon live gehört. Und zwar handelt es sich um das Orchestre Le Consort mit Theo Thiem Langlois de Svart. Die waren in Frankfurt im Sommer zu Gast beim Rheingau Musikfestival, haben dort nicht wie Waldi gespielt, aber anderes. Und ich dachte, meine Güte, sind die gut? Und ist dieser Geiger herausragend? Und das bestätigt sich jetzt hier für Harmonia Mundi. Haben sie die vier Jahreszeiten neu eingespielt, wahnsinnig frisch, in einer Geschwindigkeit, die zum Teil atemberaubend ist. Dann zeigen sie aber auch, wie Waldi will Naturklänge darstellen. Er will auch ein bisschen das Chaos in der Natur. Die Wildheit, auch das Tänzerische, wenn man durch die Natur geht, all das zeigen, bis hin im Winter zum herumwirbelnden Schlittstuhllauf, zu dem man sich anstecken lässt. Und das zeigen sie mit ihrer Musik, indem sie auch die nicht so wohlklingenden Töne zulassen. Also nicht, die verspielen sich nicht, sondern die zeigen auch ein Instrument kann auch mal ein bisschen knarzen, kann auch ein bisschen schrill werden. Es ist einfach das Erwecken der Natur, weil man das will, weil die Vögel auch einmal schreien. Das ist nicht alles immer nur wohlklingendes Gezwitscher.
Hast du Kolipris gehört? 500 Herzschläge?
Kolipris nicht. Ich glaube, das war bei Vivaldi nicht im Sinn. Jedenfalls hat das wirklich was Pulsierendes. Es ist eine ganz großartige Erfahrung, das zu hören. Ich kann das sehr empfehlen. Relativ großes Orchester, deswegen auch wuchtig, also großen für jetzt Vivaldi-Orchester. Man kann schon all die Farben, die Vivaldi da komponiert hat, erklingen lassen. Ich bin sehr begeistert davon. Und man kontextualisiert auch diesen Vivaldi ein bisschen dadurch, dass man ihm noch Zeitgenossen zur Seite stellt. Auf der zweiten CD sind dann noch weitere Violinkonzerte, die zum Teil nicht nur wegen der Tonart, sondern auch wie sie komponiert sind an die Violinkonzerte der vier Jahreszeiten erinnern. Aber darüber hinaus gibt es dann auch eine Komposition Tänze von Gregorio Lambranzi, ein Zeitgenosse Vivaldis. Und diese Tänze waren durchaus einflussreich für Vivaldi. Auch die sind da zu hören. Es ist ganz großartige Musik und jeder, der meint, na ja, Vivaldi das ist doch vielleicht alles so ein bisschen seicht und das ist doch abgetroschen oder so und das wurde doch überall schon gefiedelt. Ja, es mag ja alles sein, aber ich verspreche, wenn man sich hier diesen Vivaldi anhört, diese vier Jahreszeiten und die anderen Violinkonzerte, dann wird man das auf eine ganz neue Weise hören und wird begeistert sein und wird auch erschrocken darüber sein, welche kühne Modernität bei dem Vivaldi zu finden ist.
Okay, dann sag ich dir, ich werd's hören und dir dann sagen, da ich ja die Töne im Ohr hab so ein bisschen, zumindest da, ob ich einen Unterschied gehört hab.
Also garantiert. Also da bin ich mir sehr, sehr sicher, dass du da sagen wirst, das ist schon spektakulär. Wenngleich es auch andere spektakuläre, gute Aufnahmen gibt und hier geht man ja auch auf alte Instrumente. Also das finde ich sowieso ganz gut, auch bei Vivaldi das zu tun, das mit alten Instrumenten zu spielen. Beziehungsweise, ja manche Instrumente sind natürlich neu, aber so wie die Alten dann konstruiert. Das ist sagen wir die historisch geschulte Aufführungspraxis, die hier vertreten wird. Ich bin da auch nicht orthodox und sag, das muss immer so sein. Ich finde nur hier, was hier klanglicher vorgebracht wird, ganz exquisit und ich finde vor allem diese ungeheure Modernität, die da drin steckt, beeindruckend und es hat überhaupt nichts von diesen Sachen, so classic for the mood und dann haben wir noch irgendwo die vier Jahreszeiten drin und das ist dann alles so ein bisschen schön, sondern hier geht es schon richtig rein in die Natur.
Also da soll man hören und nicht nebenbei Hausaufgaben machen.
Man kann auch irgendwas, aber ich würde schon sagen, man kann sich auch mal darauf ganz konzentrieren und es passiert so viel. Das sind ja kurze Sätze, in denen wir reden. Sonaten sind sowieso nicht, Konzerte sind sowieso nicht besonders lang und dann haben sie ja noch drei oder vier Sätze und da passiert richtig viel und da gibt es so viele Stimmungsschwankungen, so viele neue Farben, die da auftun. Es hat ja auch ein bisschen was von Programmmusik, was blüht jetzt da gerade auf, ist jetzt schon im Sommer angekommen oder so. Von daher kann man sich da schon mal drauf ganz konzentrieren.
Okay, sehr gut. Das werden wir alle hören.
Dann hören wir uns.
Dann warten wir mal eine Bundestagswahl ab und sprechen uns wieder.
Ja, da kann man sich schon drauf freuen.
Mal gucken, welche Fragen noch so diskutiert werden die nächsten zwei Wochen.
Bis dann.